Sorry, sorry for being late.
Oh, I was doing a practice with my VTuber rivals team.
I can't really say who's in it because it has been announced yet.
It's like there was a lot of things going on.
Like people were getting rotated and stuff like today.
So like I'm like worried that like I was like, is this finalized?
Well, we just had a scrim.
So so like we practiced we had well, we didn't have full team scrim.
tank player wasn't couldn't make it um so i had to get a ringer like well i had to get a pro player to ring for us because i was just like i don't know anyone so so like obviously it's not very much fair but like he was also like coaching us at the same time so you know it was like coaching plus uh also ring as a tank player so uh um guys yeah we were casually just playing against like diamond gm teams uh so uh so yeah we were playing against diamond gm teams um and i'm nervous i'm really nervous because like i feel i know it's for fun and stuff like that but you know i i you know i just want us to win at least one game i just that's really it i want us to win at least one game everyone's working really hard i mean leave at like 4 30 because obviously i have to do the stream and so um so four people actually we we actually everyone else stayed behind um the entire team stayed behind to get additional coaching uh from our pro so like he's doing like a vaude review for them and like
giving them tips on how to play and like what comps they should run and stuff like that so you know you know he's he's helping out a lot and um and i hope we get you know i hope we win a game that's all i want that's all i want for us so sorry for being late anyway small announcement small announcement so some of you guys might have already seen this announcement because it was on our official doki merch twitter yes the doki merch twitter account is associated with you know doki buried it's associated with me and um and uh they already announced it already on the twitter account but we have let me pull it up because this is technically a hashtag sponsor technically it is hashtag sponsor but like it's just a very small portion um but there is an msi aim lab challenge that is going out right now and they are currently doing a giveaway for their monitors so on this stream i will be doing a giveaway for their monitors at around five um so like in 25 minutes um it's 25 510 so in uh not 25
sorry 15 minutes in 15 minutes i will be doing a giveaway for their monitors that the monitor that i'm using right now the mag x50 monitor um it's really good i'm actually i actually managed it when we're doing a soundproofing thing um i managed to swap ask them to swap um swap the uh yeah 15 minutes sorry you know i'm bad at math so i managed to swap my really old monitor with the m finally the msi mag x15 monitor so we're going to be doing a giveaway slash raffle um ticket for this monitor but there are requirements to it regarding aim labs so first off please download aim labs right now it is free on steam so let me i need to read my instructions to make sure that um that i got everything so um it is free right now on steam And there is a little challenge that you have to do.
I'll show you guys the challenge real quick.
But let me do the pin promo message.
Check out the MSI monitor.
And very good.
I love it.
I use it to get.
All right.
You know how good it is?
I got top 500 yesterday.
good it is.
All right, I'll show you guys I'll show you guys how fucking good this is.
So as you guys know, I've been playing Rink for the last two days, and in two days I got top 500.
With this monitor, by the way, here we go.
Let me pin this real quick.
I got the picture here.
Don't worry, I took the screenshot.
Of course I did.
this is the per i didn't expect it to happen but this is the perfect time perfect way to chill so so i played gambit wow look at that 4.5 hours played literally start playing like two days ago the first time the first season um the new season and then i played gambit and i have only lost two games on gambit this is how sexy it looks like guys by the way i'll show you how sexy this is um look how sexy this uh this looks chat uh where is it there you go look how not the last book though like um you know like the what the pros say the pro players whenever they tweet this out like never kill yourself like
yummy yummy so so it has 500 hertz for this monitor uh it's sexy one of the keywords so so um so that is how good this msi monitor is i literally by purchasing this monitor you can get top five not me top 500 and then there's the little asterisk not everyone could get top 500.
You just, this monitor doesn't actually guarantee you top 500.
So, yeah, results may vary, not guaranteed.
You had a little disclaimer on the bottom.
So, you know, it's been pretty good.
It's been pretty good.
Anyway, let me read it.
Let me make sure.
So, MSI, like I said, has graciously provided us one MSI Mac x50 500 hertz monitor as a giveaway for one lucky dragoon during the stream so dragoons please open your aim labs and um click on this link i think this is the right one yes click on this oh my gosh this link this is not a spam link guys and it'll redirect you to the msi aim labs challenge i'll do a demonstration of it and all you have to do is um if your name gets chosen uh Give me a sec.
I'm getting the MSI.
I'm getting my aim live.
So if your name gets picked, you will have to send a screenshot that you did the challenge and send a DM or reply to, you know, Doki merch, the Twitter Doki merch account.
And just throw a screenshot that you did the challenge.
That's really it.
But you have to have aim that.
You have to have a screenshot that you did the challenge.
The link doesn't work.
No, you need to have AIM Labs open to have it work.
That's the thing.
You gotta have AIM Labs open to have it work.
But if your name gets picked, you gotta make sure you do the challenge and send a screenshot of it to the Dokey merch or DM.
Don't worry, I'll send the Twitter link to the Dokey merch account.
So for those who did get picked, it's just one lucky dragon.
But there are other prizes.
There are other prizes.
this is a campaign from the 17th of november to the 17th of december and this is an msi ranking challenge so there's a grand there's several prizes so grand prize gets also gets another like if you get first place in the msi aimlapse challenge you can get uh you can win a monitor basically like the the ms meg vision x mpg monitor and the second place and third place gets two monitor the attending prize 10 and until 10 lucky players can also get a hundred dollar steam wallet so this is randomized so you don't get first second third there is a chance by participating in this challenge you will get a hundred dollar steam gift card um and 10 winners will be randomly selected so the in lab leaderboard closes on december 17th but if you want to get if you want to um get a right now do the aim lab challenge right now and be here for the giveaway is this locked to n a mod is this not that is one thing i actually don't know mods is this locked to n a like actually i actually don't know this is
not in my briefing um
that's yeah that's not that's not in my breathing so sense make sure you download aim labs click on this link i'll i'll send the link over to you guys now um again have to have aim labs open for this and and click this link and it will um it should be able to take you to the challenge so i'll show
aim labs there you go i have this is like the one time i've ever used aim labs is for a sponsor so i clicked on the link this is me clicking and then it took me here but if this is your first time doing it you'll have to like confirm something um you'll have to confirm something so so it took me here i clicked on the link and it instantly took me here and this is the challenge it's like a one minute challenge let's go all right i did the challenge like to test it out so yeah i do that and then whoa oh no i'm gonna fuck up my challenge now i messed up already i was warmed up too from rivals and then you guys must be like what the fuck is this it's welcome to aim labs this is what everyone does before they play video games but that's not me apparently not me though but it does help a lot it actually i will say it does improve your aim a lot too um i just it's for like like this for the really serious gamers that actually want to climb um this actually is really good warm-up and does
improve your aim i just i'm a very lazy individual but if you want to be a better player um do aim labs because um because it it does help you improve a lot yeah okay yeah i'm not this is a bad number this is a bad one for me.
I'm messing up.
It sucks because I did warm up, too.
I was playing Ravos for two hours.
I was in a...
I had to play DPS.
By the way, I have to off-roll.
Um, not because, like, it's in the rules, but, like, um, because of the comps we're running, I have to off-roll.
Uh... 71?
I was so close!
Oh, no, that's my score that's my high yeah i have no i can't play gambit um because like we're running 222 and stuff so i have to play dps so i gotta grind dps so look at that so yeah so you can send this screenshot um okay legal residence yeah okay so these are the places that can apply uh but uh so yeah and you just take this screenshot and then post it in the um i think it says yeah it says task me how about what does it say it where's the msi challenge so this is the leaderboard so if you get first second and third um you'll be able to like win the bonus prizes as well so the neat thing is that you can watch this guy to see how he did it like how did he so he started jesus christ what What the fuck?
So do the challenge right now, because I will be pulling the giveaway winners.
I will be pulling the...
Should I do it?
No, I won't do it in the stream.
I will be pulling the giveaway winners maybe in 10 minutes.
In 10 minutes.
So do... Yeah, he is a machine.
So you can see how he does it.
Jesus Christ.
How long... Bro, he wants that PC.
So wait, I want to do it again.
Give me see if I can break my record.
He was free, right?
He did it here.
bro he like knows where to flick instantly too that's the crazy part oh no this is not a good record for me either i already don't think we're gonna hit anything oh no oh no all right we're fine
all right there you go i gotta lock in i don't think i'm breaking any records, though.
I don't think I'm getting a high score.
I might be messing it up.
I just want to get 69.
That's all I want.
Give me 69.
Come on.
I don't ask for much.
I just want it to be nice.
Is that too much to ask for?
Oh my god, there were four people living here?
There wasn't four people.
Not anymore.
There was four people living here.
Oh, 48.
We're climbing.
I'll be like, bam, this is a home invasion.
Yeah, I'm top 50 out of 3,300 people.
I mean, this is like my first time doing it.
So I think that's pretty good.
That's pretty good for my fourth time.
Uh, fourth time?
Uh, they're still downloading!
No!
Okay, okay, how about...
Oh, man.
I feel bad for those people who are still downloading, guys.
How about this?
Alright, guys.
Alright, I'll be nice.
I'll be nice today.
I'll be nice.
I'll be really nice.
I will pull the raffle in an hour, for those who are still downloading.
So, at...
In an hour, I will pull for...
I just see, like, some dragons...
are still downloading the game um okay but metty how long have you been doing this for metty how many tries to take you to be 17th hmm i'm at 17th you can't keep up with jaguins because i know some of you guys have been already for those who are already following the dokey merch account i know you guys have already um have already been trying to do this challenge so in an hour um has been trying all day this is my fourth try and I've already broke top 50 um but anyway for those who are still downloading I will pull up I'll do the giveaway in an hour um and then I'll do the I'll do the giveaway in an hour for everyone just so to make it fair because I know some people are still downloading it um and yeah i look forward to see who wins who wins the special monitor but make sure to follow the dokey merch account if you win don't worry there is if nobody said if your name gets pulled and you don't we give you a five minutes we will give you five minutes um to uh to uh send in the
screenshot so it's not like nobody said anything so let me I'll do the dokey merch link as well.
Dokey merch.
Twitter.
Let's see.
All right, here it is.
All right, here is.
Let me just get the...
Actually, I'll do a new pin tweet.
Here is the dokey merch.
I'll do a new pin tweet too.
Boop, boop, boop.
Join.
Join the...
I'm gonna say my word join the MSI challenge here okay oh wait I can't okay it's just gonna be a join the challenge there you go there you go join the challenge there you go it has the link here you go you click on that and then uh oh wait that's not the link oops give me a sec oh there you go it tells it gives you the thread it gives you the thread look at the thread and then it here it's here do we need a twitter for that yes you will need a twitter because you will have to contact uh um you have to contact the dokey merch uh uh twitter account or reply to their tweet with the picture of the um of the emla chat but only if you're chosen only if your raffle gets chosen chat's moving too slow can you spam the link more okay all right announcement done i gotta head over to the cloud layout but i think that is every oh um oh sorry my mom was like i'm gonna be going away in half an hour
so sorry the mod that's running this was like i did not i thought you were gonna do this like right away but okay um i was gonna go in 30 minutes so i guess i have to say it now yeah okay oops thank you to the mod that's handling the jokie merch twitter account for staying overtime so not to make sure um but he's like oh okay i'm okay i guess i'll stay another hour thank you to the turkey merch mod for staying an extra hour to make sure we do the raffle so make sure to download amabs do the challenge that's the only requirement to be eligible to enter the giveaway uh but that's really it i played eight hours straight and formed the gooner but we can leave that part up.
Many thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See, at that point, it's just muscle memory at that point.
Anyway, all right, let's hop in the car.
Sound guy, are you here?
I accidentally fuck up my sound balancing because I forgot to save.
Also, I need to delete all my tabs because Battlefield's going to take up a lot of shit.
So give me a sec.
Let me...
Um...
Uh...
Pupupupupupup...
oh give me a sec real quick i gotta close everything because i don't know if i can run battlefield like if i have all these things open all right there you go let me boot up battlefield also remember that guy that was like level 200 plus um apparently he revealed that he was actually revealed in the comment section of that mod um that he was very drunk when he played with us so oh my god boot up marvel rivals by mistake give me a sec so it was maybe a mistake to let him join us because we were trying to win and he was apparently very very drunk uh when he joined us
aware that he was not sober at all if I knew he would not have been playing he would not have joined our squad if I knew that hello tell us money instead S&P 500 whoa hey guys are you ready for a 12-hour stream today not really not really sorry not really why are you not ready don't you love playing battlefield i thought you you love battlefield i don't know man i don't know about battlefield you love kind of hard bro it's kind of hard man this game it's okay we will adopt someone into our squad by the way i found out remember that winnefield guy that was level 200 plus that was oh yeah yeah he was very drunk when he was playing with us he and he still did
commented in that vibe like and was like sorry guys i was very very wasted like uh men have too mood either they're completely wasted and they're completely locked in you know yeah yeah true true true he was he he was so better than all of us like we're only half a man he was all the way i just want to say thank you for thank you for uh organizing the cloud axel i know you that you know you guys are really wanting to push for this yeah yeah thanks i'm so ask i'm so glad that you like decided to keep playing with that you're like you're so okay you know he was like in our discord messages he was like bro we gotta keep playing man like we have to get one win he was like man we gotta do this again and then they're like but he was like oh i'm embarrassed though he can use can you and can you and i can you know tears say it on stream because like i'm a little embarrassed because like i am what the but we decided to call you out But we want to give him credit,
you know, we were like, no, come on, Axel, he should take credit for setting up such a wonderful idea.
Yeah, everybody say thank you.
Yeah, thank you, Axel.
Thank you.
I literally just said, yeah, the time has been still.
I just said, yep, okay, sounds good to me.
Yeah, yeah, and then we're like, really, it sounds good.
What?
You're so right, Axel.
It does sound good.
God, he's fucking gaslighting.
Jesus, no, we would never We would never Look, Axel, they're all saying like Aniki the goat Axel's the best, look at that What a saying, thank you so much, Axel Thank you, Axel You know what, I'ma be like one of those Street performers, I'ma put out a box I'm like,
hey, if you really want to thank me Drop a Twitch Prime sub Guys, yeah, if you really want to Thank me, you can super chat on Dokeybird's channel and I'll Don't worry, I'll make sure that Axel gets the cut I will make sure that I'll send Axel the money do later same over here too yet same over in Altair's channel membership only no super but here you can send the memberships to Altair and then the super chats on my channel and then you can I guess you can subscribe to axe so no way that's crazy bro what the fuck this is shit there shit is like paying taxes they're the fucking government oh it's because the people it's because of you people You people who is winning live with that you people.
No, that's how the government speaks to us.
It's all because of you people.
The government is able to run and all that.
But also we're going to fucking tax you extra.
That's what that's what you guys all doing.
Whoa, whoa.
We're not taking money from anyone.
We're not taking.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, thank you for the super chat gator.
Thank you.
Thank you for the gift of membership.
And us.
Thank you to super chat.
Thank you.
Man, it really pays off to be these people, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It really pays off.
These people.
Yeah, we're good people.
Why would they give, if we were bad people, why would they give money to us?
I don't know, man.
Why do we give the money to the government, you know?
Same question I'd like to ask.
I don't want to pay taxes.
I want to just doesn't the government like take care of the internet for for Australia Ooh, I don't know about that bro.
Yeah, no the internet in Australia is like government owned That's why the internet Australia fucking sucks Yeah Makes sense actually.
Oh my god.
This guy's level But too bad.
I'm not in Australia no more.
I'm actually I'm actually mr.
Japan now.
Oh my god Yes, sir sushi now you know damn you got the jp internet now no more i do i can download battlefield in like 10 20 minutes you know oh my god you do that sometimes you like unassaw some big games just oh yeah yeah yeah yeah sir i just the flex on him you know just the flex yeah it takes longer for the game to patch than the actual game to download that's like no yeah no i guess that it would take like an hour some yeah all right i believe in gaku nukem the level 107 oh someone get the a from gaku gaku got oh gakin sorry gakin nukem guk nukem oh it could be guk nukem wasn't he's a war hero don't say that word oh is it a bad word bad word oh i thought it was like not spelled like
so so what is it no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no i thought it was an item from wow let's go let's just go guys first what if we win this first game guys what if we re-end game we end stream i thought it was either the guma carry a couple or i thought it was the item from schedule what just call him nuke him not guma guma yeah it's guma carry isn't that a good and then he said area is tapering you guys don't know it's just me maybe i'm just too big of a league fan hey all right
gun oh that's my knife everyone's so scared of now actually playing league in japan because because if you know the word if you know the word you'd be scared if you know the word you'd be scared if you know that's all i'll say if you know what the word is you'd be very scared i'm not chronically online like you guys it's not no no no no it's not a chronically online thing i will tell you that it's a thing i experienced in my childhood yeah yeah yeah i think i got it indeed my friend indeed yeah yeah it's you know yeah yeah there's only one thing that you guys will be scared of it's racism okay it's a word that every game will censor it's like you can't type it in game chat why the hell is it his in his name no because it's not spelled like that it's not spelled like that but you are surprisingly pronouncing it very very close to it
Or the coke thingy from Schedule 1 that they have, this ingredient.
Oh, what?
Yes.
Cute.
Oh, they cute.
Yeah.
Oh, you haven't played one of the best games in the world.
What is the best game in the world?
Schedule 1.
Oh, so you know, I have, but I got scared of playing it on stream.
Why?
Oh, I can see it.
Yeah, I can see it.
Yeah, yeah, you can see it?
I still have my like...
It's why we can't play it.
Yeah, because I still have...
Well, you guys can't play it, right?
oh people okay okay i'm coming over because like you know i'm like still have like the fear the corp of fear oh there he is nucom look at nucom bro nucom's fucking oh what bro he killed everyone yeah bro nucom's doing it bro i think we're gonna win let's go no i'm gonna jinx us yeah i'm so down for that Okay,
if we don't want, we have to invite him.
I'll be like, okay, I'm going to glaze him.
Bro, you're so good.
Just risen up a little bit.
Hey, I'm a V-tuber.
Get down.
Oh, you're afraid of me?
Oh, never mind.
You lose.
Also, to my sound gap, is everyone okay?
I don't know if my sound team is alive.
All right.
Bro, where do we go?
I'm just following Axel, but I don't think Axel knows.
Oh, I don't know.
Yeah, let's just do it.
I don't know how to do the missions.
Yeah, how do we do the missions out there?
I think they press M.
And if we finish the missions around the map, we get experience and some really good loot.
Where's the missions?
Oh, three missions nearby.
Decryption, evasion, the script, aligned.
Oh, that's true.
That was a signal hack.
I don't know how to do this, but let's do it.
Oh, there's a signal hack.
cool all right look at this guys we're top 2014 let's go boy i'm going to the line of lieutenant shit if i get shot i get shot someone will i will be the war hero i'm getting shot okay wait no he's down where oh wait where that's our carry wait where did he die wait all the way back there it's okay he gets back in don't worry about Yeah,
we're still doing this.
All right, align the antenna.
Go to the other antenna so we can line together.
All right, it's over there.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm not aligning this.
Signal string.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, oh, there you go.
I got it.
I lined this.
No hose or watch it.
Let's protect us for a bit.
I'm hacking.
Hacking.
He's back.
I'm hacking.
I'm covering.
I hear shots from the northeast.
I hear so many shots.
Did we do the mission?
Northeast 30.
Right over here.
On ping, on ping, on ping.
Okay, okay.
I'm looking.
Okay.
Oh, hey, let's go.
Some gifts.
Oh, nice, nice.
One down, one down.
On the track.
Yeah, good luck guys.
Keep talking those gifts so you guys keep killing them for me.
Mission completed.
Let's go!
One more, one more.
Behind this truck, behind this truck.
Let's rally on that RV point.
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
There's one more guy up here on this house.
I'm down.
Where you're down?
Whoa!
I'm ping, I'm ping, I'm ping.
Okay, no!
How did you die?
He's on the hill on ping.
Whoa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Careful, careful, careful.
He's the guy's sniper.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if I can do anything about that That shit's scary you could cry you could you could be a little pathetic and you know, okay, I'm just gonna chill It's okay.
You can res yourself Where are you okay over there?
Did we loot that thing back there?
Did we loot that?
I don't know.
No, I'm being a little goblin.
No come come come over here Where where is he?
Don't worry, Nukem, I'm here for you.
I'm following Nukem.
Because I'm pretty sure there's like a read up their teammates res or some shit.
Mr. Nukem.
What are your orders, sir?
Wait, oh, what?
Are you fine?
Yep, just a sniper shooting at me.
Here.
Here's a med kit.
Thank you.
Take what you need.
Is he still sniping?
Oh, I see him.
Yeah, he's still sniping.
I hit 42.
It's still sniping, really.
I got like 42 on him.
He's such a little bitch.
Whoa!
Fuck you!
It's just one guy!
Are we getting one guy?
You're getting one guy.
I'm getting hurt.
We're getting one guy.
Ouch.
Thank you.
I'm without body block.
I have no armor.
i didn't drop some somewhere i body blocked you i appreciate that i think we should leave this area i don't want to be here anymore unless we unless we like run it up to him all right you how confident are we to run up to this guy how confident i'm not that confident i'm not gonna go to mr new i'm going to mr newcomb yeah he's our leader he's he left us already oh my god oh this guy sniping yeah yeah no wait no wait people involved us
oh nice nice oh i knew okay nice you knew one more one more one more i got him i got boy i got shot from back behind behind behind behind behind don't worry i still have a rest oh oh oh oh okay we just got it we just got a rest me and axel we can we can clutch this we gotta clutch So new come can stay with us.
Thank you.
I'm not joking.
Where do we go?
Whoa, whoa, where's mine, man?
Where's mine?
Thank you for the super chats.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
Let's bump Axel to the next tax bracket.
I know.
Thank you for by super chatting me.
I will help Axel out.
Come on, guys.
What's with all the greed here?
Where's my super chat, guys?
Don't worry.
You can't be hoarded.
We're redistributing wealth.
Oh, I don't know about that, dude.
We're here to redistribute.
That's what it means.
Actually, I swear to God, if I die...
Oh, one of us.
Oh, you got one and I got one.
Yeah.
I think this one's gonna go...
Are you against the team leader or you're against?
Oh, thank you.
If you die now, I can get you...
Oh, okay.
I got the squad.
Leader, what is this merch that's just dropped?
Axel, did we drop merch?
Uh, did I drop merch?
When?
Did we drop merch?
I don't know which much.
What did we draw merch?
Did we draw merch?
Oh, I'm going to slow down.
Oh, that's not good.
Guys, we won't be safe here, so we got to leave.
I got shot from somewhere north.
Looks like this way.
All right, I go.
I'll go west.
Oh my god, Nukem.
Wow.
It's on me.
It's actually on me.
Oh my god, guys.
You guys have to rest me now.
You're gonna have to rest me after.
Oh, I see.
I'm getting airstruck.
Okay, Altair, there is people behind me, so good luck.
Good luck, everyone.
Okay, I'll watch behind.
I'm covering you.
This time for real.
Oh, oh my god, that's you.
That's you.
Apparently, there's more mascot plushies of us.
Yo, check out dokeymerch.com for more merch as well.
you do you know i have a custom controller as well you're the boy gaming doc jp uh
oh i need armor okay it's fine how do i get up you guys guys i i don't know who he's shooting at but i don't know how you got down the hill guy down the hill okay ping did you ping yep i pinged okay that over here i don't see it's another guy on the hill He's hit 56.
I see him.
Oh, this is a really bad guy.
It's so hard to use.
This gun is bad, bad.
Wait, I'm getting...
Whoa!
I don't know where I'm getting shot from.
It's a shipping container right there.
Okay, I'm gonna back up a little bit.
Yeah, Mr. Nukem is like in fucking Narinia, bro.
But Mr. Nukem ditched us.
Shall we do a mission?
Wait, this is defying the laws of gravity.
How the fuck are they going up?
What?
Custom weapon drop.
Let's go to that.
Oh, that's what he was going to.
Guys, we can't let Nukem die.
We let him die.
Wait, wait.
Someone dropping.
Oh, right in front of us.
Right on the...
I got shotgun.
Go the hole.
Kill the hole.
Oh, wait.
He's gonna get really, really good gun.
So we gotta be careful.
He's dead.
Oh, shit.
I'm a dead.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, I can't do that.
that's crazy they're just crap that was a beat that was a beat that was a beat no
the nuke of got nuked i see the strap we're trying to go with every time we lose we get a sub that's how it is we'll be millionaire get shroud all right yeah yeah okay but nukem was pretty decent okay but he ditches a lot so i don't know i don't know that is true as like i don't like his name which part it's hard to say i don't want to say yeah which part which part the name is you not like can you say it out loud for us so i know what you're like you guys are too paranoid this is why being blind to a lot of things in life is just better you know you know what i'm saying sometimes you might get in trouble so there's a korean proverb called don't put your head under the pear tree you know don't put yourself in that position right yeah yeah put your head in what why do ostriches do it it's like so don't stick dick and crazy ostriches aren't humans yeah why do ostriches do it huh be an ostrich do you want to yeah aren't you a bird ostrich just can't Fly so they can run Oh,
those fuckers What's an ostrich?
Those guys with big eggs You know, a big emu Axel, a big emu But they run so fast though They're very fast runners Yeah, they're like emus They're like emus We have emus They're like, they're like Emus But like I don't know which ones I think I think ostriches are faster than emus I'm pretty sure They're like emus without horns They both taste like shit They both taste like shit.
Have you ate an emu?
No, but I can bet you they taste like shit.
They have like the top part.
Is it don't emus have the little top horn thingies?
They have horns?
I don't remember what emus look like.
What does an emu look like?
Axel, is that why they lost the emu war?
The horns?
What?
I don't know.
I don't remember what they look like.
They have the little thing on top, right?
The little...
Oh my god, it does have a horn.
Yeah, right?
I was like, don't they have that?
Yeah!
I don't know.
I knew.
I knew it.
Bro, okay.
What did the Australians win?
How?
Wait, but like, how would you lose the war?
They literally threw criminals on the island.
Like, don't you guys go hard?
Like, why else did they banish you from the United Kingdom?
Banish who?
That's how Australians were born.
They took all the criminals from the United Kingdom and then shipped them to Australia.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
So how did you guys lose the war?
What do you mean?
How did you lose the war against animals?
It's all against animals.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I thought you guys were talking about like the people losing to the British people.
No, I'm talking about the evil war.
Yeah, who cares?
Yeah, I'm talking about the evil war.
I don't know.
Fuck, maybe they thought that'll...
Oh, all those fuckers don't taste good.
them that i'm just you know yeah just shoot it maybe just do it do what there is a lot of people heading to this mansion by the way oh yo yo yo yo it's a great idea it's all right no discrepancies i believe in him no discrepancies i don't have a guy i'm dead i think he's dead guys okay cool all right okay i got i got some guns all right well see you later guys is that a lambo that is a someone sent a nuclear strike down to on us and i hope i live sounds balanced don't worry this house is a mansion i'm okay wait where where are wait where are the other you guys Oh,
I'm running.
You ran?
Because only a squad or three were sent to shoot them.
Over time, they learned to send out scouts to warn the flight to run.
That's insane.
Bro, I got two and you ran!
Good job.
Good job, though.
Okay, all right.
We both died, I guess.
I'm so sad.
It was such a good gun.
I didn't know what gun.
Guys, what gun was it?
It was so good.
Someone's like, oh, they dropped at the golf course.
sucks oh thanks guys oh i'm watching out here sniping no pressure good job i'm watching you i'm gonna touch you and kill you nice yeah good touch i'm watching you still out there no pressure okay okay i'm going i'm upgrading my sniper yeah yeah yeah oh oh i'm no longer watching you can start shooting again oh wait watch me again So what does a dude gotta do to go on the front page of Twitch again,
yo?
What do I gotta do?
How the hell did I get on the front page yesterday?
That's right.
Oh, you were on the front page?
Hot tub.
Oh yeah, yeah, do a hot tub.
Everyone loves the hot tub stream.
The Twitch meta.
Yeah.
It is currently hollow day, so if you guys want to go check out hollow live production talents on twitch.tv.
Or you can check out my channel on YouTube.
It's dokey day too.
It's Doki Day.
Well, Doki Day.
Every day is Doki Day.
Is that why I got on the front chain?
That's crazy.
When you're playing league, you need every help you can get.
Whoa!
I got a rat on my ass.
Shit, I got a swan down there.
Wait, where are you?
There's someone down there.
I don't know.
I'm running over?
Hi.
Did you guys kill the rat?
I think so.
Oh, hey, nice.
Someone on me, I'm here!
Okay, I'm here.
I'm actually not here, I lied.
But like, I wanted to make sure you're feeling comfortable.
Talk about it's on the ass, bro.
Yeah?
So...
On the roof, on the roof, on the roof.
It's on the roof?
Oh, shit, he's right here.
Another on the roof, careful.
Wait, what the...
I was like, who's that?
Who's that as running?
Wait, I'm getting shot at by something.
FURF, FURF, FURF.
Guys, guys, guys.
Oh my god, he's 100, 100, 100, 100, 100.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm still dead.
Okay, never mind.
Great weapon just really said, hey, I'm gonna- Axel, run!
Run, run, run, run.
I don't know, press M.
Hey, you think I have to- Let's go straight for it, straight for it.
Wait, our fourth left.
Wait, he left us.
But we were- Okay, you're right.
We don't need him.
He doesn't us appreciate real talent yeah now we gotta we gotta look for like at one you know we gotta appreciate flightless birds oh oh oh oh i don't know i don't know you can get that reader point now i believe oh whoa whoa that is more than one person shooting by the way whoa you got killed by jenna the giant yeah they beat those kills bro they been playing for for like ever since this game mode came out and he still haven't won yet but not like us though we're gonna get it today guys fucking jenna of course it's jenna you have a redeploy yeah this guy's this guy's oh this this is rap he called him them a rat this is rat hey hey chill out okay guess guess guess why you're able to come back to me because i you're gonna get shot at i was a good man crazy how this gladiator has a coliseum yet he's so get it running away from fights i know right that's how that's how he's never died in the coliseum fight he just runs away until the guy just watch the people he runs he loops him around
he runs around the coliseum until the guy gets tired and then he shoots them humans are endurance hunters i just watch the people fight instead of me fighting what about the lion how do you live through the lion the lion obviously do lions taste good i wonder i don't think they taste good I'm exactly me don't taste good,
you know, that's why humans don't taste good too apparently Because it's dark meat Dark meat never tastes good dark meat doesn't apparently like because it's too firm because the muscle our muscles are too firm Oh, but you know what firm meat goes good with hot pot.
Oh, that's true.
I wonder what it tastes like Didn't mean sliced firm meat like the red meat is really nice.
I agree Yes, sir.
All right.
Watch our roof.
I have a snipe.
When are we going to have that pizza party, by the way?
Oh, yeah.
Pizza party.
Pizza.
Pizza time.
Pizza is kind of- Yeah, AXA.
When are we going to have the pizza party?
Yeah, we should have a 3D pizza party.
All of us in our motion capture.
Can we have something else?
Like, can we have taco just on TV?
Taco Tuesday.
Yeah, taco Tuesday.
Something like taco are better man we get pizza and tacos and then we have to be next to a bathroom just in case i don't know the pizza in japan is so disappointing when i heard that's true oh man that's not scary actually come enjoy the pool it's like it's because like cheeses i mean fuck the pool man i don't even go to the beach don't worry altair i'll be in the pool girl that's right i infected the pool with my cooties that's i'm getting shot at They're shooting at the pool!
The pool's close!
Pool's close!
I'm still getting shot at!
I know she was piffing in the pool, bro.
She just goes in, sneaks in, and chucks a little bit.
Wait, airstrike?
I'll be okay in this house, right?
Let's move over houses.
No, I should be okay.
They won't know.
Wow!
Hey, guys, so I thought what if...
I thought it'd be like the tiny airstrike you know where it's like you know the tiny ones little do i know it was not tiny i don't even know what the hell they are i don't know either but they sent out this goddamn airstrike that's messed up that was pretty messed up it's so hard it's over here you guys see them yeah but it's so hard for what i'd What gun do I have?
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Hit one for 38.
They're going over this way.
Yeah, they redeploy.
They're outside the map though.
I'm trying to, I'm just trying to find a better gun.
Oh no, there's no more better guns.
That's the best we can get.
Oh, I knocked one.
We did?
Nice.
He said I hit something.
We're going over right side, right side, right side.
Right side?
Oh, I see, I see them.
This gun is really bad to shoot, though.
So, I don't know how much I can help.
I don't see it.
What the fuck is shooting people under the re-deploy?
17?
33?
125 on the ball.
I hit 33 on flesh.
I feel like this is going to be bad if we...
63.
They're going right side, right side, right side.
They're going right side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like here.
Oh, they're shooting back.
How dare they shoot back?
Keep the high ground on them.
ground i don't really think we have high ground here we just gotta move in this yeah we should move in i'm gonna move in whoa i'm moving in a zone i'm getting my knife out okay oh look there's sliding really cool like open this chest in the open i don't want to be out in this golf course for long weak coward you're a coward like sometimes like don't give you cover you gotta take it sometimes you gotta get a bird instead of a car sometimes maybe good sometimes maybe sheet always 50 50 what do you mean yes sir yeah oh oh environments environments environments in front of us i'm shooting up the hill ah oh no i'm dead i'm going nice i'm getting shot behind us the people we were shooting at no way guys we might get flames oh my goodness i whipped out my god okay on my way on my way there's one view there's one view i'm grabbing this you're my now am i now i have dfib i have dfib oh wait it's so quick dfib what the hi okay wait i think that's a sniper here i dropped a sniper car car car car
tank tank hide If you get close enough, you can attach a thermite to it.
Yeah, I'm not one of those people that's good.
I'm not going to die a hero.
I'm dying a...
I'm not dying here because I'm live.
Because I will live.
You are live.
I'm running, by the way, guys.
I'm very far.
You're like 10 feet away from me.
I'm so far from you guys.
You're so far.
Sayonara.
Uh-oh.
Bro, he's one.
Bro, I hate this recoil.
I hit 140.
This recoil, fuck, he sucks.
Ouch.
I might die.
Is he inside?
Whoa!
Yeah, he's sniping.
Oh, there's a tank!
That tank is sniping!
Oh, shit.
I need armor.
Fuck.
I have armor.
I can't drop your armor.
I'll drop your armor.
Okay, you're healed.
i got tanked by 20 miles away i don't know where i i don't understand i go red hey yeah go red i'm gonna try to hit the i don't understand when we get a tank we get instantly destroyed when they have a tank they live like that's not fair i equal rights it's because i'm how do you attach a thermite do you need to be holding a thermite there's someone there there's someone there's at the redeploy no they're at the redeploy
they're like camping it
it's hurting yeah let's go to the zone let's go to the zone there's another redeploy right here okay like to your right just don't don't get near the tank oh i got he's like walling or some shit wait he was just ratting there oh no it sounds out there our life is in your hands clutch or kick wow there's people up there oh no oh no don't worry this wall will protect you this is my wall it was made for me guys don't worry oh it was got made for you it was not me for you this wall deported you
it's okay it's gonna be the third game don't worry i believe it we're getting those here we from from 16th place the 13th place guys we're getting there we need a squad member who who can be loyal and not leave yeah that's right you know what because that guy that guy fucking left us yeah i'm gonna blocking him i'm gonna block him because that guy left us i'm stream
Play recently met what was your name?
shit No discrepancy Wait, I'm gonna oh we got him I was gonna send him a message and be like not ggs Wait, wasn't no discrepancy the guy before this no, no, that's the guy that left us.
I don't worry.
I'm petty names all right i know i remember there is you notice oh he's so lucky we got oh wait here he is f1 okay yo i got 100 gifts from twitch what holy thank you twitch dang hey youtube where you guys at hi youtube wait and just dunking on him like that so i sent the guy that saw emoji fuck you wait i got salt emoji yeah i gotta send i sent him a salt emoji assault emoji yeah yeah you can do equipment none of them have ever replied back to me other people have sent messages to if only they knew what they're missing out on wait we got a level one guy guys i think we should leave i think oh he's a he's a controller and his name is soft actuary bro it's like his birthday is this is this 10th birthday 10 year old birthday finally he finally got playstation 5 and he does his mom give them a battlefield 6 2 and now he's here with us i'm sorry we appreciate it mr twitch big love yeah i had a question if mr twitch if you still here how the hell did he get on the front page again are you
not on the front page what i don't think so what do i gotta do be on the front page because they gifted you a hundred subs is that how it works i don't know because why would they be on your your stream right now i don't know maybe they're like maybe there's like an insider in twitch who's like where are you multi-streaming or or exclusively on twitch exclusively on twitch wow an exclusive twitch stream yes sir wow that's crazy because we love YouTube versions.
Exclusively.
Okay, Axel, watch your language.
I'm not for that shit, you know?
It's fine.
It's okay.
He's on Twitch.
They love me for who I am.
You can remember out there.
On Twitch, you can say all that stuff.
On YouTube.
Yeah, yeah.
On Twitch, you can say everything, anything you want.
They love me for who I am.
I'm an honest man, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
I keep it real.
I keep it 100% real, you know?
I don't want to do that like, oh my God, I'm such a nice person.
You want to be like, What's this name?
Nice to meet you.
The guy that's...
Team right there.
Watch out.
Who's that guy's name that does the whole...
The Fortnite guy?
God, I'm can't remember.
I don't play Fortnite.
No, no.
The guy that's like...
No!
Oh, I got killed by Kanoli.
I don't know anybody who goes like...
Oh!
No, he got my dog tag!
No, the guy...
No, I'm not talking about Ninja.
Is it...
Is it Nick?
No, Nick.
this yeah nick the guy that's like uh god what was this fortnite thing
what was this famous thing that he says to this child i don't remember his child he's got a child never back down never what yeah never back down never what how did that guy just oh one more one more going your way i'm coming me go back yeah on me on me but that guy never swears at all because he had his entire channel to anybody with his children i'm gonna try to find one singular gun how did i broke my ankle again oh there's people on me there's people on me actually can you raise me oh sorry there was a person combat you tend to forget about me but it hurts no i just i just I just know deep in my I'm camping.
Bro, my aim is all over the place.
God damn it.
It's like me on a drunk night trying to take a piss, man.
Jesus, fuck.
Like, whoa.
There is a team here.
So I'm...
I'm a little...
Oh, shit!
Is him again?
I thought you guys killed him!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Dog attack for you!
dead again i'm not giving him my dog tag bro fuck the canoli guy that guy is crazy nice colossal yes sir yeah there's him there's him okay our child is dead whoa i have 11 bullets i don't know what i can do with 11 bullets just hit it all you don't have you have 180 what do you mean 100 you must be blind lady bro you have 11 in a mag what do you mean is that the gun that i'm trying to use though yeah hell no what the is 11 out of 180.
oh wait i okay whoa bro i was putting armor on man this guy's a rat out this guy's a rat so how do you check the twitch front page i need to get like more familiar with twitch you know go to twitch.tv okay twitch twitch.tv when i type that cage will just pops up and i think is i watch him too much i watch cage a little bit too much oh so that's how it works from I'm gonna mess up a little update with the with the microphone.
I'm sorry, the monitor thing.
The monitor is NA locked, but if you do win the monitor and you're outside of NA, MSI will work with you to get in-country equivalent or a Steam wallet code of equivalent value.
So just let you guys know for the monitor.
Hopefully they let me loot.
Yay!
Wait, where are you guys?
There's a counter mission.
We can do this.
boys bus all right here we go i got fine i swear to god if i see canoli again i swear to the fucking guy if i die that same guy who put this
was an airstrike
axel let's go and learn some of tennis come over here where's the child yeah the mission where's the oh there's a child okay i'm just saying oh there's people ahead of people ahead people okay i only have one gun North.
Let's just kill him, man.
We already died so many times.
If we kill them, we can get their guns.
Think about it.
How bad can it get?
Yeah.
Wait, where are they?
You lied.
Are you, I...
You wave either?
One shot, one shot, one shot, one shot on the hole in front of me.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
No!
I got fucking- I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
What happened?
He's down, he's down, he's down.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Let's die.
Darkness?
Oh, wait, I'm here, me, me, I'm gonna like...
I'm gonna slice it.
i got him i got him i got him i got him nice okay he didn't want me to grab his dog tags i mean good for him nice me too can i get rid of that all right oh axel's down wait what we got resist got to pick up axel you didn't pick him up that guy's that guy he's on a chopper look at look at our rabbit wait what the bro what is he doing he's flying wait there's someone in the air that's is where i'm not i'm not even gonna bother i know it's not gonna work i don't know i know i'm not gonna i can do anything about that you just gotta believe dokey i don't believe i don't i know my limitations i'm a oh wait our guy died let me res him oh the hose right watch yeah guys we gotta res our boy all right he died in the chopper already yeah i noticed that he was dead guys he died in the chopper but um hey we all stand on this it'll be a little faster sorry i'm doing some i'm doing some singing we all and we all stand on this it would be a little faster guys
i'm hockey i helped yay uh is there another signal thing uh nah where do we go do we just we should go no we are in zone yes can we go closer to zone or nah let's try to let's try to do some apex strats and just find a spot inside yeah let's just rat oh there he is wait which way is inside okay we should woohoo oh we got lit yay where's our loot where is it should be airdropping soon where is Yeah,
it's coming down.
It's this one.
Watch out.
Don't get crushed.
Oh, wait.
That happens Whoa Money money money All right, let's go.
Let's go.
We gotta go to zone.
Let's go Yummy yummy yummy Yummy yummy yummy What's that bro?
That's mama mia Oh, it's mama.
No fruit salad Oh, fruit salad Wiggles, wasn't it?
Wiggles.
The fucking what?
The big expendable?
Oh yeah, wiggles are Australian.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, the Australian.
We got what's he called our wiggles.
Yeah, you guys invented the wiggles.
Yeah, the wiggles.
Oh, someone's pressing.
Someone on my ass.
Where are you?
Where's your ass?
Oh there.
He doesn't have one.
That's true.
That's why I'm like, where is it?
That's why we're trying to find it.
Well, just kill from the skies.
We're all trying to find his ass Axel Where is it?
Where's his ass?
You lied Dude, Axel Axel?
It's like a piece of paper floating in the wind I literally just saw some dude Looking like Jesus falling from the skies It'll be a cardboard forever It's so sad Guys, we gotta go Let's go deeper in the zone Wait I'm ping I'm ping Oh yeah, I see him He's above us.
I do have an airstrike.
Granade!
Airstrike!
Okay, I'm leaving then, I guess.
I'm gonna fucking cut this tarp.
Oh my god, he's double-gated.
Granade, yo.
Oh, I see him.
He's up!
Okay, okay, okay.
I see him.
Over here.
I'm pinged.
I broke his armor.
I broke his armor?
He's dead.
Whoa, car on my ass.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
What?
I literally just died that easily on a car.
I need up, I need up, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Oh, no, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, no, oh no, oh no, it's over.
I had such good loot too, no!
Bro, how the hell does a car just get destroyed that easily?
Oh, no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Liv!
Where's our- where's the child?
Oh.
Oh!
Axel, watch the child.
Watch the child, Axel.
Watch- Watch him.
How do I watch him?
You press E.
Oh no!
fighting for his life.
He's trying.
Oh, no, bro.
He's taking cover.
Oh, he got the bait.
Oh, he's burning.
He's burning.
Oh, how do you miss every shot?
How do you miss every shot?
You're on a shotgun.
No, what are you doing?
Is that the zone?
Let's get out of there.
Oh, there's a guy camping on next to him.
He nearly had him.
Oh my god, Tare's literally fighting for his life.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I was so focused then.
Yeah, you were so focused.
You killed so many people.
Who is a good battlefield player that we can just be like, we need a fourth.
Hop on in.
We just grabbed.
I just...
twitter who is good at battlefield come join now once in a lifetime opportunity we are one hour in we've already given up it's oh guys it's only been one hour guys we can do it i it's the other hour it's the other hour that will make it it's not about the first hour it's always about the
and the third out guys we have nearly 12 hours like we can do it wait what yeah we only have 12 hours left we have 12 hours oh wait exclusively on twitch so we can go longer what if you think about endurance time yeah because on twitch you can stream longer than 12.
hell no hell no we could do like a subathon
up with that one week one week is there a butt sufi this was all axel's idea guys that's why he's that's why he streamed it on twitch because he knew he was like oh i can stream longer than 12 hours if we all do if i do it on twitch so it was his idea gas sliding what is this idea thanks axel thank you why am i getting gaslit bro jesus by who so thank you for the super chat too and god wow so generous and kind so generous that's crazy man what will we do about generous generous access crazy all right we got section 10 20.
that i want to walk into section 10 19.
we killed him because he didn't do good enough yeah it's taking again he's been playing every time he dies he deletes his account and makes a new one He deletes a Steam account and he makes section 1019, section 1021.
Someone's like, did they win a game?
I don't know, Mr. Little Big Planet Shin.
Are we still playing the game?
No, we already won.
What do you mean?
We won the first one.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I leave the moment we win that game.
I will literally, when I see the win screen, I will end stream right there.
Like, no, I'll just...
Even if we don't win.
I'll leave even if we don't win, yo.
No, no outro.
I leave call and stream.
My contract says I can leave even if we don't win.
No, no, no.
This is, it's in our title.
It's in our title.
Our title says, our title says, also where the fuck is this guy landing us?
Nah, my agent said, nope, my talent is not continuing.
I'm your agent.
No, no, you're not my agent.
actually your agent it was me all alone it was me all alone i know i'm your agent oh the deadline the trade deadline has passed already it's me you were too late no it's me do you not remember we had amazing earlier today no i don't remember shit i didn't do this ladies happen i was there at the meeting well too bad i don't remember I have the meeting where we all get a thousand dollars.
I remember.
Oh, you weren't there.
That's unfortunate.
Oh, yeah, you weren't there.
That sucks, bro.
Random is dead.
Yeah, no, he's dead.
He was not being helpful.
Well, I'm looting alone, so what the hell?
Why is this mag gold?
I am so scared.
I only have a pistol.
Why is this magazine gold yellow?
It's like piss color.
What the fuck is that?
our homie died oh my god okay what's you okay i don't have much ammo left god maybe we should be nice to our teammates maybe that's maybe that's what's stopping us from winning now oh you guys are fine now all right if you win with us i'll buy you dinner whoever you are okay sure not not you no no no oh well you gotta buy me dinner so i can be nice what does that have anything to do with you being nice Where is that gun?
I literally dropped.
Oh my god.
That's...
What the...
People are just dropping in me.
Well, that's a, you know, problem.
More, more, more, more, more.
Please!
What's going on?
I'm on my way!
Die, die, die, die.
Someone west, I think.
There was one more person, I think.
Guys, I don't know what's going on.
I've just been...
this area all right i'm fine now who is this gun okay this is this is a semi sniper you want this it's mine it's mine i'll give the seal tear thank you yeah oh you want a shotgun no but what else can i do i can find another gun later what is this battle pickup whoa oh cool from one shotgun to a shitty shotgun.
Let's go.
What the heck am I using?
Oh, by the way, I dropped a shotgun.
That was actually a shotgun.
I lied.
Yeah, I kind of noticed it was a shotgun.
It looked like a sniper.
I was like, whoa.
It's so long.
Like a sniper rifle.
Why?
Thank you.
I killed like five people here.
Axel, I have a weapon for you.
Huh?
I have a weapon.
weapon.
Come here.
What's this?
Check it out, man.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
It's a railgun.
Huh?
I found your railgun.
Yeah, give it a try.
Ooh, artillery strike.
I want that.
Someone's over here.
Over here.
Oh, my God.
I just saw him.
He literally landed right next to us.
Raider next to us.
He literally landed in front of me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I got two.
Nice.
We got all of them.
What the fuck?
Why are they?
Why are they all landing on?
us like what guys actually we lost i'm pretty sure we lost too many games that the sbmm is like on our side now oh yeah no sb oh oh there's the lady no the eraser this is called i wow so sad i am so sad i wait is that another guy on us there is no way section you cannot oh my god wait he's doing movement bro okay this is that everybody no there's a guy in front of section yeah there was a guy all that nice thank you for loot people appreciate it nice oh it's the same guy i killed before they came back just for revenge they thought they could take us down i swear to god i think bro this is not natural i got like so many people running at my running at me i'm coming in where's my body dude this this this gun is op the one you gave me but it takes so long to people people you scared me where are the other guns oh there you go oh are we really gonna do the okay no i don't want that i don't want the responsibility no no Someone else take the gun.
Axel, what is that gun?
Someone else take it for responsibility.
Try shooting this.
Shooting what?
Huh?
Vehicle.
No, don't shoot that vehicle.
We'll need this car.
No, no, no.
Should have blown up and killed us off.
Yeah, it's okay.
No, no, no, no, no.
Do not kill us.
I worked too hard to be killed right now.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I like, oh, I like P20.
I'll take an ammo drop.
I have the P20, and then I'll grab the car by.
Okay, we're really far from the zone, so let's start moving in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll agree.
We have a car.
We can move in with the car, guys.
We could also blow it up.
That'd be pretty cool.
We can, okay, how about this?
We drive a car into someone and then blow it up.
Yeah.
Oh, I like it.
Yeah, yeah, you like, yeah.
I'm cooking right now.
Guys, I don't like being the fucking driver.
Well, you don't want me driving.
Let's go to the defense nexus and just sit in the house and wait.
This is our best bet.
Also, there's people fighting defense nexus right now, so I don't know now.
But we got a car.
But the thing is, is that if this car blows up, we're all just dead, you know?
Yeah, but then it requires to blow up our car.
Just don't get blown up, forehead.
Yeah.
I think it's safe right now.
kind of sucks after constantly carry this when i'm like lng kit we just stay here wait let's find a good defensible position oh
wait there is another shotgun hey guys there's a blue shotgun over there where do we wait i'm away here actually no we should wait in a room where like there's no entrances and exits or Maybe there's one exit.
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
That makes no sense.
I'm going to find a room and I'm going to live there.
Maybe right here.
Isha.
Where are you living?
Where's your...
What apartment did you rent?
Stop stalking me.
I'm in my own place.
Away from you crazy people.
Oh, hi, Doki.
Oh, what's you people?
I'm renting this room.
What do you mean, you people, huh?
You know what I mean.
Whoa!
Wait, that's a one-drop place to us.
We can probably look for it.
Oh, you're gonna go grab it?
All right, I'll cover you.
I'll cover you.
Don't worry, I got you, bro.
I got the high ground.
You got the finest two covers right here.
I've never let anybody down.
Yeah, I have, but not this time.
People, people, people.
Watch out, they're running over.
All of Mississippi.
Where?
Oh, this way?
Okay, I'm coming over.
Oh, at Axel?
Okay.
I hear them.
Ow, ow, ow.
Wait, I don't have like an angle here.
Oh, I got one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, with the rail gun?
That's crazy.
Where are they?
They're right at that smoke.
Oh, I see them.
Right here?
Is there someone running below me?
Oh, no, but...
That area looks bad to me.
I don't have long range gun.
Inside, inside.
Oh, on my ass.
What?
It takes so long the rail gun.
Can't be just fucking...
Bro, it's a rail gun.
Have you never used a rail gun?
I don't play Western games.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
Res Axel, he has a rail gun.
Res Axel.
Bro, that's crazy.
I realized my gun is not long range.
Wait, the Axel's coming back in.
We stay here.
We'll live.
It's a section 25.
The forbidden section.
Okay, this one is definitely more firing.
Ooh, more ammo.
I can give more ammo to people if needed.
Air strike, air strike, watch out.
Where?
No, section!
Oh, no!
I'm coming over, I'm coming over!
Yeah, there's a lot of good loot on, like, sections body.
We gotta save his ass.
Saving, saving, saving.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, no, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Guys, maybe this was not the perfect place to live.
Just maybe.
Fucking couch noodles.
Right up, Doki.
Right up.
Okay.
No.
I'm trying to head over to the next closest redeploy.
Oh, this is a little.
Oh, I'm getting artillery strike right here, but it's okay.
Why is this game so hard?
You think they're right below me?
I missed the days of PUBG.
Guys, guys, do you think they're right below me?
You got this.
You think I got it?
Uh-huh.
You know what?
I'm going to be a little evil.
No, I don't believe you got this.
You're right.
Sometimes you need a doubter, you know?
You're so right.
Wait, no, no, Ducky, no.
Why do I even try?
No!
You're so right.
No, yes.
Just give up right now.
gonna be my 13th reason watch this axel was the previous 12 reasons yeah he's already hitting you with 10 already just just need three more dokey hey if you can if you can withstand 10 you can withstand 100 you know what i'm saying just think about it like that well just because humans can suffer doesn't mean they should right yeah exactly wow guys this is the worst redeploy i've ever seen what the why are the other real boys so open like what is this i'm where i'm just like i'm gonna look everywhere there's no way if there are stream snipers you're gonna protect me hey stream snipers i know you guys want to drop those custom weapons
I'm gonna go loot my dead body again.
You are not gonna loot your dead body.
Yes, I am.
I'm going so hard.
There's a- You're stopping me.
It's a bad idea.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna loot my dead body.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Ah!
Maybe if you were here, you would have been.
I'm coming back!
Ah!
Axel.
Why are they so?
so greedy man it's just my dead body bro man people nowadays dude inflation has made people go crazy oh you don't realize just how crazy people would go over for your dead body all right how much how much do i get paid all right i'm going ahead i will negotiate i can i can negotiate i can negotiate why are you still there axel why the are you still in there you got shot because i tried to go get purely in oh section no is there is there a team there oh my god that software is we go we go we leave we leave we'll resume the uav outside we gotta we gotta show for a little bit what's a uav uh it's like uv online you know oh like a strike i got it i got the rocket launcher i'm guided rocket launcher by the way i'm guided oh someone's using a redeploy right now the only real player is like literally right across the map we go i guess we do don't we all right ladies first i use my grenade the long shirt yo yo i'll show you guys something cool check this out yeah what the did you do i'm
watching i'm watching i'm checking it out i already i already used it oh you put a little wrap for us why are you such a quick shot bro come on a ladder Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's dangerous.
All right, we're going to have to go to that next read-up play.
We're going to run in the open field, saving private section.
Oh, bro, a chopper.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my God.
There's a chopper here.
You want to use a chopper.
Whoa, this chopper is like on fire.
Holy shit.
Yeah, this is why we don't use the chopper.
Hey, if I die, I die.
I don't know if I can make it there in time.
there.
We got it.
There's a lot of ash, fire, gunshots, but like, that looks so safe.
Yeah.
I'm a dead guys.
Wait, you're getting shot at?
Axel.
Oh.
I'm kind of fucking them, though.
Okay, if you're gonna die, you better.
Look at this.
Look at this cast cover.
Axel.
you gotta die soon you gotta die soon five seconds i'm out of here with the vehicle die axel come on i'm drive maxin right now who are you shooting at super far north okay i got the reload oh my god i got out i got out i got somewhere over here i might just said i'm gonna drive out of the fucking oh my god he actually did it he actually made it that madman what a madman come on i'm a lot of fucking i've watched a lot of initial be initial be and it shall be hey welcome back yay welcome back but we'll go we gotta leave we gotta leave we gotta leave we gotta leave we gotta leave we gotta leave strike strike strike strike strike strike strike strike strike strike all right so can you save my life over there i didn't do anything what did i do i saved my own life you know what i'm gonna do i'm safe now I am dead.
No.
Where did he come from?
Wait, where are you?
Why are you over there?
Guys, guys, come here.
Come here.
I have the best spot ever.
Guys, no, no, no.
There's no way.
Unless they throw an artillery strike, we're fine here.
Yeah, unless they use that one ability that everybody has.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
No, don't worry, guys.
Look at...
Okay, but we don't shoot.
Oh, come on.
why did you have to notify everyone because i killed someone okay that's cool do you need help wait what the hell you don't need help right because i'm just gonna i'm lying i think i'm good oh i can refill ammo by the way if you want ammo squads left six squads yeah that's why we gotta we gotta make sure we have all right quiet quiet i'm gonna go get lunch then good job guys wait wait wait wait wait wait what if we die i'll say i'll say we die he's gonna have to keep playing fucking hose we're also gonna have to keep playing yeah yeah but but he wants to eat lunch though it's okay i had dinner already i had chicken an hour ago so i'm not that hungry oh okay yeah yeah all right you know yeah just oh my god what the was that did you see that it's my drone oh that's your drone Wait,
the wind field said I'm ready only if you're not drunk
Wait, we're in zone guys the guys we're in the zone guys guys don't don't know attention we chill we chill We chill.
Let me try to kill this guy.
We chill.
Um, that is the opposite of chill No, no, I've got a drone.
It's okay.
Intense moment.
What if I become like that one dick streamer and be like okay I'm running ads.
I'm running ads.
That's what they call a dick move.
A dick move.
Are we good?
I don't know.
I'm chilling in my building.
I wish this is so good for us.
It's so good until they throw in the artillery strike, but this is so good for us.
Like...
Honestly, I think we're fine even with that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's say, bro.
chilling yeah bro we chillin hey bro his face is so bloody man we're still in zone we were still in zone guys we are not gonna be in his own soon we are not gonna be in zone we're gonna shot we're getting shot at we're getting shot at where we are oh shit leave leave leave leave leave leave leave
Okay, chat.
I'm running ads.
Oh, stop!
No, no, no, no!
I think it's GG's, guys.
I think it's GG's.
Got one, got one.
Hunch.
Hunch, punch.
Oh, no.
From the back.
Oh, my God.
There's a sniper right there.
There's a sniper right on me.
Don't, don't, don't, don't pick up the hill.
This hill has a sniper.
In front of me.
Yeah.
Mr. Backshot.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
This is bad because that team is literally looking at us and there's last two teams and they have oh Um, I'll tear.
I don't know.
I'll take the only thing I could do is maybe I can airstrike this This is a huge poor economy right now.
We shall and I'm fine.
It's fine.
My airstrike went off my airstrike went off, but I died for us I don't know if you want can rest me but my airstrike went off Oh, I can try.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is a good idea i got killed i gotta kill i gotta kill my airstrike did it i i see this is it this is it okay i got your back always this is it i gotta kill i gotta kill let's keep laughing let's keep smiling okay am i gonna get to run my ads man these guys are okay oh god oh god okay okay they're fighting they're fighting they're fighting they're fighting should we go should we go should we
There's one west, one west, one west.
I'm dead!
No!
Second!
They're fighting, but the fight fucking ended so fast!
All right, guys, I guess it's time to run the ads because they lost.
You know what?
I'm also gonna run ads.
This is evil time.
I'm gonna get to the bathroom.
Yeah!
I'm so sad we were almost there we were at so close we were almost there they're so close they're just guys like the drunk guy was like I'm ready but I can't I want to ask him if he's drunk are you drunk I can't ask him that okay we invite him for one game And then if,
and then we, and then we kick him.
No, no, think about it.
Like, you know those, if he blows over at 0.07, then we keep him in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Haven't you ever seen those, like, Chinese Kung Fu movies?
The strongest guys are the drunk ones.
You have the drunken style, you know what I'm saying?
That is so true.
Be right back.
I'm going to go to the restroom, okay?
All right, all right.
While you guys are waiting, I guess I have to do my giveaways thing, so I'll be right back too.
Wait, you do giveaways now?
No, no, I have a sponsor with me.
msi right now so all right yeah yeah yeah yeah so i'd be right back real quick too i'm gonna death in real quick all right guys almost did not forgot about the giveaway everyone uh
i didn't forget about it guys anyway so let me let me pull up the giveaway rules real quick
okay um all right so the key way we're gonna give away let me next all right the key wait am i i'm on the wrong one i'm on my twitch nightbot give me a sec i'm on my twitch nightbot give me a sec guys let me get on the youtube one because i was like vip i don't have vip here i don't have vip on the oh i have to access it all right Give me a sec.
I got...
Yes, it's me.
This is me.
All right.
My YouTube channel.
So for those who don't know, if you've done the AIM Labs challenge with MSI and you...
Yes, continue.
And you have a screenshot ready.
If you get picked, please have a screenshot ready for the MSI monitor raffle.
The monitor is only...
restricted to uh restricted to n a uh citizens so uh if you do win the raffle msi will look into getting you another monitor that or i don't know uh get you something else that they can ship you for in your country or get a street steam wallet code of equivalent value so i don't know i think the wallet monitor is like a thousand plus dollars so you win this monitor uh but you don't live in n a you get a thousand dollars worth of like like steam money basically so if you guys win the raffle but you have to make sure you do the aim labs do the aim labs challenge and be able to have a twitter account so you can dm the dokey merch twitter account that shows in the screenshot if you get paid for the raffle anyway let me check all right so the key word is exclamation point msi this is the key word to enter the giveaway so let me do done all right i will be pulling so use exclamation point msi to enter for the monitor i will have i'll have it play for hello and no i'm not okay good winfrey's
not drunk now okay this is winnable this is so winnable guys i'll have everyone entry i'll let it play for uh for like two minutes until like uh 621 and then we'll pick it to make sure to use explanation point msi for a chance to win a monitor yippee oh my gosh so many participants so many people
participating no he's not getting drunk guys we have what we are so close i can't believe we got to say i didn't know i thought they were i thought they were the guys were up the hill i should not have just ran out i was like they're up the hill that's where we left last left them and i was so god damn i was too in that game bro i was fucking killing everybody with a goddamn pistol too one more minute guys one more minute to enter that i got so excited i was like they're fighting they're fighting with third party with third party and then my apex unga bunga brain went off
all right 621 the moment it's 621 i am pulling the winner i'm pulling the winner guys uh yeah the fact that they ended the fight was so fast too like the moment i went off the the team already died oh we got in a oh wait we got in a game i didn't expect that i was still doing my giveaway guys i'm oh i got timed out we got timed out for an activity i was like what oh we're still in the lobby together thank god i was like where are we all right calling for the winner and all right i'll give 10 seconds for those who want to enter at the last second 10 9 8 7 6 5 Four,
three, two, one.
Choose a winner.
Pocket Printy.
Thank you for winning the giveaway.
Congratulations.
Woo!
Please, like I said, take a screenshot of your AIM Lab participating in the AIM Lab's MSI challenge.
The screenshot of you, of the, you know, if you're the, you know, the stats...
It's a stats page that I did earlier.
So, basically where you get to see leaderboards and like what you got and everything.
Take that screenshot.
Send it to a Doki merch Twitter account.
We are going to confirm.
I will be on stand down right now.
Stand by.
Sorry, stand by.
Let me see.
So this is the Twitter account.
Please make sure to DM or reply with a screenshot of the result with your Twitter account.
So they can confirm that it is.
is you and also you know confirm not you know confirm that it is you if your twitter account is a different name to your youtube channel please give us evidence that this is you that you are pocket print me make sure so we are i'm on standby right now i'm on standby right now to get confirmation that you have sent the information but to be fair we will give you five minutes to do this so make sure you get all this done in five minutes guys i can't sign it it's not even sent by me i'm not the one sending it it's sent by msi oh they did it okay i'm waiting for confirmation right now from the mods i'm waiting i'm still waiting i see waiting for them oh we're waiting show please show the youtube handle as well if you can pocket that you that it is you show that you own that youtube uh youtube channel so we don't it's not like some random person yay congratulations pokey congratulations we're winning the modded yay all right back to battlefield add done but thank you again msi for the
sponsor please feel free self i have been using this monitor for my gaming the last week or so i mean i literally got a top 502 days with this monitor so like it works like 500 frames is crazy it actually is makes a huge difference all right anyway here i'm i'm deaf in hello i'm back i finished my ad welcome welcome just in time for our ad hey buy your regis alter and axel serious hoodies yeah sure okay i'm done we got the drunk man on our team yippee yippee all right i'm ready i'm ready too wait are we are we matching all right he's not drunk this time so like okay okay like i swear to god if he doesn't get us top 10 in this game we kick him dang hey that that's what you said that's what i said that's right that's right we have standards here also if i don't want to kick him i just want to punch him i mean you can punch him are you gonna punch him in the balls uh in his bloodline maybe in his fields yeah what would you say to make to mentally hurt him windfield more like loose field
no no thank you for the pity laugh now i appreciate that oh wait look at what windfield said you see how you see the hose we're watching yeah he sees our hoe
how fast fast are your feuds we got an honorary hoe here huh look are you are did you see what winfield said look at our look at the chat look at the squad the party chat i'll let you punch me in my field like the ball sacks does that mean you know what they call it they call it a sack whack a sack wax how do you know so much about sack wax oh bro you got whacked in the sack fuck yeah wait for fun oh yeah but I but I was like I was I was like an insane magician at doing sack wax bro I'm not even kidding oh so you would just do like like abracadabra and whack someone's back yeah yeah i was literally like the voldemort of backwacking i'm not even kidding the one who showed up in me like people in seventh grade they would have their fucking hand over their crotch because they were so scared of getting whacked from all angles it's like he's right behind me isn't he guys i was like i was the magician Walter White of Sackwack.
The Walter White.
I would grab, I would have something, right?
And I'll pause it to him and say, yeah, I'll like, I'll say, hey, can I borrow something?
Oh, wait, I'm the jump master?
Okay, sorry, you're jump master now.
Well, yeah, I'm giving it, I'm giving it.
You can give it.
I don't need that code for a second, right?
And then I would, like, throw it in the air.
And because he had to catch it, he said code, right?
You gotta catch it.
Yeah, I'm over here.
of the f***ing asteroids of nowhere so you gotta catch that shit and as soon as he catches it yeah i unsheave my hand you're unsheave your hand and i would no whack the strength that that's yeah you would whack and dine sack you would whack dine sack right and it's just bgs you know it's just jgs they don't they have no extra that yeah they don't have human rights after that you know yeah yeah i have to really good at it i was really professional you're really professional too yeah i'm very proud of you man i'm so proud of you the only i can tell to my grandma look it's also serious you know the sag wacker yeah that's why that's why you don't have children grandma that's why you don't have grandkids i was just too good at it you know it was like it was a legacy wow you were it was a legacy what happened why did you stop some sacks were not meant to be whacked any sack he he whacked too hard too far oh this is my grenade too close to the sack let's go let's go let's go they must have
yeah i was like I was like, I was like, you know, I flew too close to the sack.
Have you got, okay, but have you, they ever like got you though?
Did it get you?
Oh yeah, it did, obviously.
You know, Michael Jordan didn't just have only wins, you know.
He had some loss.
He also sacked whack.
You know, Kobe Bryant, Michael Jordan, LeBron James, they all had losses in their career.
All sack whackers.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can't have a perfect record.
Exactly, you know.
It doesn't make the game.
Okay, guys, I think we got a help out here, guys.
Ow!
Can I have some healing, please?
Sure.
And KK, you slut.
Whoa!
Only because I must!
Only because you must.
Oh, shh.
Oh, my god.
I got one.
Oh, shit!
There's an air strike!
There's a strike!
I got kill confirmed, though.
We're good.
I'm gonna assassin a tour.
Let's go!
That's our grenade.
Grenade.
Where's their homies?
I'm gonna steal their items.
I'm gonna steal your body.
Don't get me over there.
Wait, where are you?
Don't get me, Hank.
Nice.
Where's the bodies?
I marked them, but...
Yeah, there's one more over here somewhere.
I'm here.
Wait, I'm gonna get the dog guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's dog tag.
That's right!
Cheek him!
Tell him where- One ahead, one ahead.
One ahead.
oh ammo drop well shotgun how is this judge oh he's throwing a grenade we gotta run at him right i'm going right yeah he's dead yeah yeah he's not living that there's a sniper right below here wait whack is sack whack is we're here to continue axel's legacy oh that that was all that was it i was like we're a continually legacy it was it was a short-lived legacy you know it wasn't that long though we gotta continue it we could be the sack whackers yeah yeah we're the sack whackers i hate this name guys tsw tsw the sack whackers all right let's whack their sacks okay nice we have tsp at home
I'm down.
Wait, where are you?
I got you.
Don't worry.
I already have a...
I already have a deal with blue balls.
You know what you want to do.
Thank you.
I'll just naturally return.
Thank you very much.
Or I'll just die.
You know what?
Hey, real fact.
So fucking selfish.
Where the hoes at?
One more hoes.
So unappreciative.
Sometimes I can do it.
Sometimes I can't.
I learned how to whack the sack.
Wacking the sack.
It reminds me of that fucking sack whackers.
The South Park song.
Taisetsuna mono protect my balls.
You know what I want?
It sounds better with this with this person.
Let's fight.
You guys don't know?
Oh man, we should have grabbed the car.
Taisetsuna mono protect my balls.
just the sackwackers I'm mad Oh, there's a mission Wait, what's our mission?
It's just kill someone Should we hunt someone?
Oh, I guess it's just us Finding someone to hunt, yeah Oh, there's a package in front of us Wait, there's a guy Wait, there's someone to kill On our left side I think that's the mission, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah Oh my god, guys this guy is 200 miles away I'm not I'm not Fuck that Oh, we gotta go with the chopper Chopper And then we just gunned it down guys chopper chopper all right i believe guys surely we won't die right surely hey i'm just gonna jump okay i don't want i don't want to i don't want to fight excellent excellent it's up i'm gonna be the gunner i want to be the gunner okay winfield winfield drive the plane you have 200 no no get the game oh gosh i shouldn't fly i really shouldn't fly winfield no get winfield winfield fly the plane you have 200 levels my ice cream please level 200 that's like oh goodbye all right kill him kill him it's right here oh oh oh oh i see him i can't oh my gosh
suppressing fire a10 warthog oh i got him i got him you got him you got him yeah i'm gonna jump out i'm gonna jump out i'm gonna jump out another one another one another one no more i got you let's go i'm gonna go over there this is america You got him.
You got him.
I'm stealing his armor, too.
There is an enemy.
Oh, whoa.
That's completed.
Dude, that was actually pretty easy.
Yeah, that was pretty easy.
Yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
We gotta let him drive this way.
This guy inside.
Yeah, I'm coming over.
How did that work?
How in the world did that shit work?
Oh, wait, someone redeployed on top of you guys, I think.
Oh, on top of us?
This guy left side of this building.
Alright, I'm here.
Wait, there was a... Oh, I didn't take the mission reward.
Wait, we got a reward behind.
us guys we finished oh yeah but he gave us a reward and we didn't even take it okay let's just go to the woods whoa whoa bye guys i'm going helicopter so yeah they didn't know we failed why did it give us a reward all the way wait someone took our reward someone took our reward in front of me let's kill them whoa oh jk i lied protect your sacks i lied you're really good at gaslighting Take care.
I lied.
Oh, we got another vehicle.
We got tank.
Tank.
Oh, shit, actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooh.
It's tank time.
Don't mind if I do.
Wait, there's a car in front of us.
Watch out.
Your line.
I think he saw me.
I think that was a tank.
I see a big explosion.
Oh, yeah, that's a tank.
No, that's a tank.
I thought that was a car, but that was a tank, guys.
Oh, you can be like, oh look it's a rabbit.
Oh, it's a killer rabbit.
Oh, no, don't hurt me.
I'm just a little guy Who's sniping mr.
Sackwhacker all right Protect your sack here comes the whack
That's good.
That's really fucking good.
Yeah, hey, that we could honestly it could be like A pro game.
Go go go go go.
Go go go.
Go go.
Oh, three.
I hit something.
Oh, they're gone.
Bro, this LMG takes 20 years to aim.
Okay, their car is so fucking fucked up.
Yeah, if they get shot, it's just GG's.
I think they got off the car.
Oh, behind, behind, behind, behind.
Oh no.
wait he was they were the ones that we gunned down oh these are the people we gunned down earlier too oh we're all back in psp is now team sack beaters no i'm gonna go to the custom weapon drop why not bro i might as well yeah sack beaters oh no honestly my mom's gonna cook with me pro gaming team you know and then it's like a goblin holding like a fucking sack you know the sack whacker don't doubt your inability tsb brings infertility what oh people on me oh you are so far el tear you are so far noted i'm leaving we gotta leave you've got a new mission ready ow what's this why is there an ice truck yeah what am i gonna do oh elter we said we are leaving it's okay i had to drop really far what are you doing bro don't worry he's raising you it's called a quick teleport that's true it's okay there's a custom care package here too so you guys can get a book that job i learned from league it's called quick backing ah the proxy the proxy people Disgusting.
All right, don't worry.
See, I helped out too.
I one second changed everything.
Thank you for the save.
You guys be careful.
Oh.
Oh, is it?
Indiana players.
Indiana Pacers.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Get copyrights striked.
It's gonna happen to you.
I'm on Twitch.
That's true.
I got snatched.
I see him.
He's over there.
Come on, you can outsnip that.
Indiana Pacers.
If he peaks.
He's pussy.
Also, there's still 20 squads.
I feel like I've been fighting a goddamn war.
All right.
What's the call?
What do you mean, what's the call?
Oh, hamburger.
Hamburger.
Bro, those guys just drive the cars.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a car in the fucking mall.
I mean, that's pretty normal.
I've seen the car.
Yeah, you probably really love the mall.
Really American.
Yeah.
Do people not do that?
Oh my God.
I don't know about.
It's like a car.
inside of your moss guys it's like a battlefield right now
i feel like we can literally chill in this area bro we can like we can literally chill like live here if we wanted to in a mall yeah in the mall if you never lived in a mall my school one of my schools was was in a vehicle vehicle vehicle where is it wait someone's resing too have you guys ever wanted to make those videos that's like hiding in the mall for 24 hours yeah but then i'll remember it all right guys this is my new yeah there's like a zombie apocalypse you know i would love to do that kind of stuff but who would be watching your youtube channel in a zombie apocalypse me the hose are watching i'd watch it wait where am i Oh,
I should be going to you guys.
I just realized I'm not in zone.
I've been walking away from zone.
I was walking up deeper and deeper away from zone.
Vehicle, vehicle, tank, tank, tank, tank, tank.
Don't show your face.
You're going to blast you.
I think they're going to blast that place, aren't they?
Guys, this is my new hiding spot.
They will never know.
I love how everyone just stops shooting as soon as the tank comes.
People, people, people, people.
They're like, we got...
Oh, shit.
Okay, okay.
Below us, below us.
Don't worry, I have their backs.
I have their backs.
They're all...
Is that all drone?
I got one.
I need help.
I'm coming.
I think they're gonna res.
He's right here.
Feels dangerous here.
Use caution.
Get domed.
I think they res.
My guy's gone.
I killed one.
Not sure if he was related, though.
What is this fucking beeping sound?
I killed him again!
All right.
That's right!
Squad white!
Okay, shit, that's right.
Kathy works!
Familiar with your gang!
Wait, wait, oh shit, I'm grabbing that.
I'm grabbing this.
Wait, explosives, explosives, watch out.
Alright, alright.
We'll just expand.
This anti-vehicle drop, I'm gonna grab this.
Grab it.
Getting armour.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
On my way on my way, on me, on me, on me!
on you where's on your oh my god you're on the roof no not on the roof i'm inside the building how are you i'm riding somewhere riding in one of the yeah i don't even know how to get to this guy i gotta rally on uh yeah it's the same guy okay okay he's real low up there he's real low okay I don't know how to get up there.
That's the thing.
Go outside.
There should be a staircase.
Oh, wait, wait.
In front of me.
Bro, he's one.
He's one.
No, it's the same guy.
Winfield!
TV, TV, bad aim.
Oh, he was so low, too.
Guys, I don't feel like that's bad aim.
Help me.
Winfield, please.
I am so healthy.
I told you.
I knew I was healthy.
Wait, can we...
get you winfield winfield how would you do that he's ratting so hard this ttv guy goodbye okay that's not win that's what's not the ttv guy though
oh good luck you got this oh no oh no i believe i believe oh my friends are dead Push me to the edge.
Oh, my friends are dead.
How could you guys die?
Oh, my God, I went the wrong way.
How do I get out of this house?
I mean, odd time, because we died.
Oh, my God.
How do I get out of here?
I'm so scared.
Oh, there we are.
Oh, TV batting died.
Nice.
Guys, there's no relapse, like, guys oh is there no more there's no more oh come on how are we gonna win this okay there's a report button at the below dokey this is how we're gonna win this guys i'm gonna make sure nothing bad happens report dokey bird for uh master beta we gotta we gotta make sure okay so we did get top so windfield lives another day yeah oh god oh god oh god i see this isn't there like a respawn bacon no there is no respawn bacon wrong game axel wrong game hey wait wait wait why the american people love bacon so much i don't get what's so good about bacon anyways it's okay Really?
It's okay, but it's not that good.
Come on, right?
Does someone agree with me?
Wait, I hear people behind me.
You hear that?
I think that's the radio, isn't it?
I don't know.
Three footsteps near.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I literally hear them right behind, they're right behind me, aren't they?
Oh my god, they're right beside me and right behind me.
They're here.
Guys, I have this.
Four squads, four squads.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
That's some walling shit right there, bro.
That's an ad worthy death.
There's no way.
There is no way.
And they owned this guy's walling.
I refused.
This guy had to be walling.
Like, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Or you just got stream sniper.
There is no way.
Don't see.
He knows.
exactly he went in there shot the building and then left like there's no fucking way there's no way crazy how did he know that's just life sometimes maybe good sometimes maybe sheep oh they have recon what the fuck is recon i know every there's recon in this game i think i just unlocked my trying wait how the fuck you unlock in this game level up on level 10 now there's a monitor sensor oh my god there's a there's a recon class there's a recon class that's a sniper class right is that the sniper i think so oh they have motion sensor oh my god
I'll tell you, why have you not been reconning?
I'm trying.
I'm having trouble believing that because I think I remember that, like, you have not given me intel on...
I gave you intel when they were running up on us and then we died anyways.
No, no, that's not true.
Yeah, you gave your intel via your eyes.
But what about your recon?
Yeah, my bad.
I'll give you guys wall hacks next time.
I got you.
Yeah, where are my wall hacks?
hacks oh it doesn't spot you if you're prone or crouch there you go see our level 220 man knows how what it knows how it goes you can sprint while crouch too oh yeah okay i'm gonna next time i next time i'm just gonna prone respect for not using armored vehicles thank you we tried and died no axel tried and then he fucking come on what do you mean did you not get shot at no no i try to i try to block their vehicle and then they just blew me up it was kind of crazy man i don't know what they used against me but how about that about the chopper method hey that's pretty cool you know we just went in gun them down that was sick but i ran out of yeah yeah that one was sick though i like that game plan we had we're getting better though we're consistently top 10 yeah we are yeah we're getting better too yeah yeah all the children are on as well which is great i'm glad more children please play this game bullying kids exactly guys finished school came home finished that's how it should be
games you can play for 30 minutes today honey and it gets destroyed that's how it should be get destroyed by sack whackers bro talked about well they're gonna make sure they their boss never come out oh my goodness we're gonna make sure their boss never drop they are not bawling no yeah i need to advocate for these guys it's okay i will like type in all chat saying we're doing you a beneficial thing in this time and economy yeah yeah it's not a good time to start kids in this economy yeah not a good economy right now guys we're doing you all a favor we're relieving you of your line up line up we'll charge tickets too wait we can do that yeah yeah we can do that now well I think now I'm I'm I'm getting yeah now yeah you used to do it for free and now look if you're moving up in the world once you can monetize you can do anything yeah exactly oh i don't have a shotgun i don't like this i got an airstrike let's like you go i like that
anyone else mad i'll just grab those intel cases to give you more experience yeah i don't know where it is it just it's it's yellow oh yeah i grab it when i say him is it just me or did his accent get a lot more australian recently
dude i wanted i wanted i want an accent technically you do have an accent it's american yeah it's an american accent yeah yeah vanilla's also a flavor sure yeah yeah vanilla is a flavor that's why it's called vanilla yeah i want to be chocolate frosted you know sometimes i want to be strawberry pudding well i'm sorry but your expectations are a little too high in this time and age you can be anything you want out there you can be a broccoli for all i care and he's gonna be so disappointed when he's not you gotta would you love me if i was a brocoy no well you know that's why you just i wouldn't love you if you're a tomato okay even if you truly want one you can just you can just leave here one you know oh no that's what that's what's important wait someone landed here wait someone landed on this i'm getting towards axel wait they're on the roof right now i'm looting i think that was me we just Is that you?
Orlando there?
Oh, okay.
I literally saw...
Yeah, okay.
Maybe it was you.
Wait.
Why are people in my chat asking me if I would fuck a veggie?
Hell no!
What is wrong with you guys?
Axel's after that veggie tail.
Veggie tail.
Why would you guys fuck a veggie tail?
Did you not...
I mean, look at Larry though.
Have you seen Larry?
Where the fuck is Larry?
Larry the cucumber.
He's Larry the cucumber.
I don't know.
What about Bob the tomato?
respect my veggies man but like what's his name the asparagus guy bro he's vegetals i respect my vegetables yeah cauliflower okay cauliflower is good all right what's like your what is your go-to fucking that's your go-to vegetables shut up axel we are having a moment is this what you american people do in your spare time um i'm canadian that's okay i am canadian you racist um how dare you profile me just because i'm an na you profile me as an american yep too bad what are you gonna do about a cry huh i'm gonna report you changed after he moved i'll report me that's
bound does anybody have rpgs because you can blow up this building i think um no if we can take out these pillars i got a bomb there's someone said something in my chat but i can't say it out loud but it was why say it say it oh you just say it are you sure you say it you want me to say it i got oh oh my god there's a there's a plane There's a choppy choppy.
There's two choppers!
I'm chopping down, guys.
There was someone sniping at us from up top here.
What?
My ankles broke.
Did you not use your fucking parachute, bro?
I don't think so.
My ankles broke for a reason, you know?
Hey, it's called saving.
Saving what?
Saving my parachute, you know?
the environment i don't want to you know what the parachute that is like
one cracked up top no they're not peeking you need ammo here you go take it thank you they're not peeking anymore yeah they're scared they're such a whoa wait i have this
There you go.
Pick me, pick me, pick me.
That's my air strike.
Oh shit!
Nice air strike.
That's mine.
That's my air strike too.
Oh yeah, no, they're dead.
Yeah, I think I killed them.
I, okay.
I sent it mine as well.
I sent it mine.
Let's go, let's go.
Guys, the building's gone.
Guys, I don't think I can get on that building.
Nothing anymore.
I think the building's gone.
Yeah, I think it's gone.
There's people shooting from over here, I think.
Goodbye.
I got his shit.
Noink.
Over here, over here.
I'll top the roof.
I'll top the roof over there too.
On ping.
I'm on top of the roof.
Right over here.
Oh, this one?
Down on the roof.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, good.
I thirsted.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I shot you guys because I was like, who shot me?
Wait, over here, over here, right here, right here.
Wait, my gun got jammed.
What?
It did not shoot again.
Guys, I can't get over to you.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He's not going to shoot.
He's not.
No!
It was the fucking tallest shit ever done.
Bird behind you.
Why did my gun get jammed?
sometimes gets jammed when i'm playing wait wait don't don't don't i'm sorry i can't get over there guys bro i thought he wouldn't shoot but he Oh no oh no they're doing a thing we did to them they're doing a thing we did to them get out of here get out of here bro winfield is living on a certain nation what happened to you uh so the zip line broke after you guys went over there yeah it's all stuck on the find you guys bro that guy like stared at us for so long when i was trying to rescue uh we gotta we gotta like go back to that place and that's the that we got
all right don't worry oh i'm here thank you winfield thank you winfield's got a purple bro that was my purple what the where's my purple i think i deserve a purple as well i'm alive oh my god there there they are coming back that's like the death oh my god i'm gonna shot at oh my god oh my god he's right here he's right here he's right on you oxal dude how the hell does he know i'm just there man oh because he knew i was there dang it's just like you know where we are every single time oh no oh no winfield winfield winfield don't do what i did get him oh my god go good job winfield that's my level 200 and oh never mind never mind oh winfield weird he can rest us oh wait he can loading feed oh winfield redeployed
Just go for a rest.
Don't be a hero.
Don't be a hero We need a hero Just rest us and then we will be the heroes streaming on Twitch, man Why?
Oh, because YouTube is a bomb when it comes to music.
Oh, you're listening to music right now?
Oh, no Not really.
It's just when you sing DMCA stuff.
Oh Wait, have you guys ever got marked?
Have you guys ever got DMCA?
from something you just hummed nope never yes you cowards wait really what song i don't think so um i was doing a guitar stream in my in my membership and then i got flagged for it okay but that doesn't count you're like literally playing the notes to the song that's not that doesn't count i meant like something like you know yeah but maybe maybe today
Oh, you know what we'll actually get to, Mark?
Baby Shark.
I'll kill you.
I can't believe this was a stream that I found out that you were a terrorist.
For those who don't know, Baby Shark is like the most anal company out there regarding their properties what property do they have baby shark we're going to ip they're using baby shark you can't uh baby shark what's that one crab rave song it's like don't don't don't do don't do no yeah that one need the deer it's the crab the crab rave
there's a crab rave all-school league players would know You just send each other that shit when you win lane at the fucking end.
Dr. Mundo walking up.
Boosh.
Guys, we'll be okay, right?
I'm gonna follow Winfield.
He knows.
No, Winfield, Winfield has the idea.
Look, he finds a house and then sits in here like this.
This is how we get first place, guys.
I believe.
LMG kit.
We can do a super chat.
readings while we're here axel axel donation readings you know whoa whoa whoa whoa where's my thank you for the uh where's mine yo where's mine yo yeah if you don't if you super chat to me don't worry axel will eventually get the bunny guys don't worry where's mine don't worry don't worry if i get the membership thank you those who are not watching twitch and are actually youtube watches don't worry don't worry here in whatever you guys are standing i ain't getting it on dokey on dokey bridge channel you can get you can donate here and axel will get your cut stop singing baby shark baby shark there's a weapon drop over here in the middle of the street we can watch it for kills okay you get kicked for afk ah mr platinum sky i think even the five gifts you see that's what we're talking about that's what i'm talking about thank you for the five
sack wax that is five ball sacks to your way yeah every gifted every gifted sub gets a gets their own whack in this someone's resting over here well okay west from axel to axel will give you that whack oh all right it's a hundred subs we'll let you guys guys guys guys there's a team on the other side of that roof right now oh my god and i think he has a bazooka that's a bazooka right yeah I broke my leg accidentally.
Oh,
combat vehicle.
Guys, we're outside the zone.
Hey, 47, 67?
Oh, he got my armor, too.
That sucks.
Don't worry.
I also have a smoke grenade.
That's a thermite.
I threw a grenade in myself.
There's a team over here and a team over here.
I thought my grenade was a smoke.
It's okay.
me man oh zekra thank you for the 10 gifted ships guys wow don't worry axel will come over to whack your sack very soon why do i gotta do that handy handy sack man yeah yeah you whack each gifted ship no no no you are the sack you're like no no santa claus you know axel's gonna use his max dexterity stats yeah yeah i don't do i don't i don't do that examinate your sack and then you're like a contractor i'm outsourcing the sack wax to an x you know you're an expert you guys need your sack wax like introducing they don't want to be waxed by an amateur they want to be at wax by an expertise and you're an expertise weren't you you're so confident an expertise i mean yeah but you know i don't do that shit for free you know i'm a hired merchant you guys hiring for $29.99 plus tax hey billy they're thinking for that five you see this is the real ones that want to get sack waxed by me oh subchart thank you for the five
You have been queued up to get your sacked whacked by Axel at your local establishment.
If we ever do a 3D collab, we can just easily sackwhack him.
Oh, it's someone's birthday today.
It's Devlin's birthday.
Can you ask Axel to sing him a happy birthday?
That's all you ever want.
Axel, someone wants you to sing happy birthday.
His name is Devlin.
Deblin Yeah Really You really gonna do this shit to me Oh god You don't care about Devlin Yo I never said that Hey Deblin Happy birthday yo Happy birthday To you Happy birthday To you Happy birthday Dear Deblin Happy birthday To you
That's right, you lost.
Yeah, I don't really have to go control.
That's looking right.
That's right.
To the next building we go to.
We can't keep riding in the same building.
We gotta keep moving.
Yeah, we gotta ride in the new building.
What is your homie to remove the venom?
What the fuck?
Why is there a flying car?
Don't worry.
It was just made in a flying car there.
Oh, there's a flying car.
I see it too.
fucking harry potters what the fuck no there is a flying car up there oh there's dog food look at that dog biscuit for your dog i'm just saying yo uh you don't have armor though you like oh yeah i don't i'm like a baby right now i need some armor thank you you broke yeah yeah guys i gotta cover i gotta cover it up here you go oh i hear something What did you hear?
I'm closing this door.
I'm going to deal with that.
Oh, Sturkey's behind.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
The hill, the hill, the hill, the hill.
I see the nerve.
I ain't got a marksman rifle, man.
Shit.
I don't have anything here either.
Oh, there it might.
I don't see them anymore, though.
support i don't see them assault rifle kit oh i want that kind of do you or do you not want it come on i want it whoa okay we are going to i got a mox we got top 10.
one down people at the at the uh phone oh shit okay i didn't see it oh my god oh my god i see him i see them in the hill they like instantly fire squad me i was not expecting it this is a That's a moxman key, if you want.
I see them.
Wait, wait.
They're pushing up.
They're pushing up right now.
Got one.
Oh, I got tanked.
We're all right.
This is where it is.
Wow.
Tank is south side.
South side.
Guys, we got to go in, but I don't know which way to go.
Let's go from the right side.
I'm on the right side.
Okay.
Guys, how do I go?
From the...
I'm stuck here.
What the fuck?
There is no way to...
We gotta go around.
Wait, wait.
There's another guy right here in front of me.
Okay.
I guess we'll just kill him.
Go for it!
He's what?!
Oh my God!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm dead!
Oh my God.
There's an entire team right there.
I thirsted him too.
Nice, nice.
There's another guy too, right?
Fuck me.
Bro, they're ratting as well.
They're also ratting.
Oh no, oh no!
Oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, wouldn't you?
Oh, my goodness.
What a fucking rat, bro, this guy.
Where's the rat?
There's a guy right in front of you.
Oh, my God.
This guy's a fucking rat.
Bro, the guy is not going to play his game, man.
What?
Why is he doing this?
Go to the zone, man.
He knows why he's doing this.
like but we are top 10 we got he lives another day winfield lives another day are we killing winfield after this i mean the moment we oh my god bro this guy is just casually sniping everyone bro these guys play we this guy has a fucking helicopter too god oh i got another hype chest gotcha time i guess i gotcha i got the love love love evo use it oh what's this what does it say uh 10 sub 100 bit what does that mean huh 100 bits that's uh that's one dollar ah hype chest on your way it says how do i how do i unlock that so one of the guys that killed us was a hacker or something i I don't know.
Oh, apparently.
Oh, never mind.
It's a bug.
Okay.
I hope it was a bug because I literally just watched him run through a house.
Like, he paced through.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was just like, what did I just saw?
Like, okay, he was just paced through the wall.
And I'm like, oh my God, what's going on?
Don't worry.
I gotta use my drone more.
Yeah, you gotta use your recon more recon, man.
Hey, I've been reconning.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, you guys just don't listen.
What did you do last game with your recon?
I've spotted people.
Yeah, with your eyes, but what about your abilities and your tools?
I pinged them.
What about, yeah, with your eyes from the people you saw your eyes.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you know who, you know, someone else who could do that?
Me, I have eyes too, bro.
I'm sure you do, buddy.
you do but I got third you know what I'll show you how oh wait that's not I'll show you how it's done no that's right I'm gonna beat you at your own game all right so what does he do then so you scope in you can see people and point them out and then you have a drone that you can send up into the area you can point people out all right but what is prediction more sensei
Look at me.
My turn, Arika.
Yeah, we're doing predictions on my channel.
Let's go.
This is the real gambling.
No, you should do.
Yeah, you should do Gamba and be like, is he going to win?
Oh, big CSGO cases.
Am I going to get a gold?
You should do a prediction.
It was like, well, will they win this game?
I don't feel like I even want golds anymore, even if I were to open CSGO cases.
Don't you want reds now?
trade up yeah you want reds now right i wanted icarus fell that's my favorite skin oh i want a neo-noir usbs bro i love the neo-noir skins what are you guys talking about we're talking skin man yeah you wouldn't get it yeah because i don't waste my money you're right who said i wasted money i invested sure you did Sometimes...
Where are these people that you speak of?
Yeah, wherever you see the gun I found.
Sometimes the gun disappears.
Ow!
Oh, yeah, I see that hoe.
I see that hoe.
Do you, though?
I got no gun, though.
I got no gun.
I'm with you out there.
Use your pistol.
Artillery is down.
Oh, that's not our artillery.
Wait, that's our artillery.
One down.
Do we get hurt by our own artillery?
By the way.
I'm gonna find out now.
No, we don't, we don't, we don't.
We can run in with our own artillery.
There we go.
Got him.
Whoa!
Oh, I was thinking about the same thing.
No, no, no, he's right there.
No!
Fuck me, man.
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
One down, one down.
Okay.
Finished him.
Yeah.
Last person's on the roof.
Yeah, he's on me.
Okay.
fuck no oh he's one he's actually one he's one he's one he's one how do you get to the how do you get to the i don't know i don't know i don't know but i fell down hello there just flop in front of me i don't you know what i'm still jumping hostile jumping i'm getting i don't want to be medic i don't want to be recon anymore i like artillery that's not art artillery too by the way stay with you down oh no oh they're going up the stairs they're going up the stairs just staircase wait there it yeah that's how like I fucking got up oh my god this oh no oh no why are they such cock suckers man wait there's a shot from oh shit this other guy was oh shit this other guy was behind there's another guy here too how many people how many people one is it doable no I should I should have died.
Why gave him a dog tat?
It's okay.
We have read up to the.
Bro, I can't kill him with a pistol.
This one's so weak.
Jesus.
I'm getting back here.
Oh, that's not enough.
Oh.
I'll tell you, there is a flow team.
There is a flow team out there.
I don't know if you should do that.
Oh, oh.
Okay, that guy was AI.
Whoa, whoa.
There's one more.
Oh!
Wow!
Just massive legends that guy.
I hear him healing or resing.
Alright, you're good to go.
This guy's dead.
Alright, I'm coming over and grabbing your loot.
What are you seeing?
Oh, give me a sec.
I'm trying to grab loot.
Nobody.
Alright.
Where's the other guy?
Okay, I don't know where the fucking other gun went.
Oh, there it is.
all right oh thank you mister i think so appreciate it thank you thank you i grabbed the artillery strike too parish i think i have a do i have armor on your guys this game yeah you do okay let's just glitch that i can't i can't yeah all right let me thank you oh my gosh i can't even use my recon abilities what's the point
here we go i'm gonna head up people are flying to you guys watch out yeah yeah yeah careful guys south south 210.
i'm heading over we're we're heading over because we're a team we're heading over yeah i'm slightly faster if you have your knife just like that indecent exposure shut the gun the indecent exposure that's right he just has his knife running out just like that in public it's so just my drone and spawn inside of the house b or v i'm in london whoa i want to eat fish and chips in london though seems pretty good you can do that anywhere i went to london i like you can have fish and chips that's the one thing i didn't have really well that's just fish and fries get five fish and oh i actually want fish and chips right now i Yeah,
yeah.
We're going to the app for our fish and chips right now, guys.
I'm going to Uber eat some fish and chips.
Wait, are we in the middle?
Bro, we should just go in the middle.
Bro, come on.
Get over here.
We're going to go to the middle and then find a house.
All right.
Say, everyone.
Wee.
Are we there yet?
all right is this the middle no that's not the middle wait wait wind field is way back there isn't he no it's fine it'll be fine dude we just gonna leave him like now what the if we die he'll live on for us oh oh there it is there is remember that remember that place no no okay wait wait we gotta go to like an outpost and just live there yeah you just got to the dead Yeah,
right here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
This is where we live!
That's where we got time to!
Okay, okay, first off, I'm gonna put the car all the way back here so people won't know that there's a...
We're like, we live here.
Like...
Smart idea.
Like, I'm trying to make sure people don't know we live...
They're like, why is there a car?
I'll tell you where you're going!
No!
My house!
They so do fucking know.
Bro, I'm so sad.
Okay.
I'm so sad.
coming on back with a car don't worry no worry i'm picking you guys up the world is a scary place no worry i'm right here pick up your uber is here oh your uber's not here no no no no someone bazooka best someone bazooka zero star they didn't come even though they were bazookas oh my god i got bazooka oh my god guys i feel very very uh very scared right down nice oops wait so what are my what is this anti wait what are my things that you have what is this what is this that I just put down is that motion sensor so hard like does it not tell me oh it is during time Oh,
so this is what they do.
Oh, they broke my drone.
They were down here.
Yeah, they're over there.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll also send out my drone.
They'll never expect the second drone.
Yeah, they'll never expect the second drone.
Suddenly, third drone.
Oh, where did they even shoot your drone?
I'm just chilling.
Wait, what did I do?
i fired something wait can you fire things with your oh my god wait you can damage people with your drone why did you tell me that elton oh no my battery is low now guys didn't shot my second drone oh no i'm just bullying them with the sniper hi you guys this is our home we live here we want a worm trail with me come on come on we're where where where i got another motion sensor right here watch this but it gets jam alone wait can we have more than one oh we we can right yeah don't worry watch this my second motion sensor i'm a worm a home surely no one's gonna artillery strike us i'm a worm yeah
i've been cooking these guys with the sniper i got another drone i'm a stabbing worm okay oh second chance no more guys i like how actual is actually playing the game we're just like we just cry no wait they got my emotion sensor oh Those fuckers!
I got you.
Check this out.
Yeah?
Did you get it?
Ain't no way, bro.
Ain't no fucking way.
Ain't no fucking way, bro.
That just happens like that.
Yo, wait, huh?
How did they...
What that?
How does it accurately hit me like that?
What?
Oh my god, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
What was that?
As you were saying.
Oh my god.
Look, how many airstrikes do they have?
What is this?
Wait, what are they using?
What is it?
I don't even know because like we didn't even see anything.
Literally, yeah, we're not even seeing anything.
They're just firing something at us.
How many airstrikes do they have?
It's a mortar?
How do I get...
What did...
What?
It's okay.
It's called a mortar.
A mortar?
Isn't that what they use with the pesto?
Mortar and pesto.
Yeah, they like grind the pepper.
Right?
Yeah.
Pesto bismo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can pick it up as loot.
Winfield, you're fucking crazy!
Winfield!
Oh my god, he tried.
I didn't realize he was going for this.
Okay, so there's a team that Rita put...
I won't say I didn't have his back.
Uh-huh.
But, like, you know, he's...
But you know what?
No one's gonna expect this.
Oh, hammer drop right there.
No one's gonna expect this, guys.
Uh-oh, this might be a JJ's.
No, no, no, no.
There's another...
There's another Reaper.
deploy there's another redeploy and i think I'll tell you I think we can make it to this other redeploy okay let's do it let's do it let's go okay you you go for it the one to the right I'll go to the one to the left we split up okay all right I'm smooving one of us will make it like we split up i think if we both do one read-up i don't think it's gonna work i don't think just die before i told you i told you i knew it i knew it i knew it we were never gonna make it if we were both there to get it we were not gonna make it i knew it you should have came with me no no it just had to yeah you're not getting my dog tag you're not getting my dog that's looking
Bro, that guy smoked my body just so he could try to do a finish rate, but I had him.
I showed him.
I fucking...
I fucking killed him.
Make sure I killed, got killed instantly.
I don't think you should use a drone while you're by yourself.
I don't know, man.
I think it's fine.
Wait, do you feel that kind of cool?
Oh, look at that hole.
It's dead.
Oh.
there he is oh there's another check the guy oh he's coming over he's coming oh we got that let's go all right where do we go ladies where do we go this this is people over on one ping over here i'm gonna slowly float towards the zone i'm not banning anyone i'm just heading to the zone Wait,
you're down?
No, no, sorry.
I'm...
I'm hit with the cool kids.
Let's go.
I'm landing here.
Ooh.
Anyone wants to get in the car with me?
No.
I can drive.
Hmm.
Above, above, above, above.
Windfields right next to them.
Oh, shit.
I don't have Kobe.
No, wait, Sam.
Don't worry.
I'm next to a redeploy.
I'm next to it.
Whoa.
I'm dead.
There is another team here.
You have to redeploy me, please.
There is a...
There's not a star-hot control.
The thing is, there is literally a team right beside me, guys.
There is a team right beside me.
Just go out there and do a little dance.
The moment I click that, they're all going to be, like, turning around and be like, what the fuck was that?
oh quick find if any of them are streaming and then we'll give subs distract them wait okay are we ready
do you think he they saw me do you think they saw me yes you're good good good luck Oh, God.
Guys, just stay very quiet.
Just make sure to not make any sound.
Remember, guys, we don't want to wake up Axel.
Just make sure not to make any sound.
Yikes.
Oh, he's so close.
We almost got it.
seconds it was two it's okay top 10 he lives another time yeah all right we go again there's another day oh my god two seconds how does it feel windfield to have your life just precariously hanging up by a string exactly nine plays he was almost there almost there
though despite what happened not bad not bad yeah yeah we're consistent you know we've been top 10 all the time you know it'd be really nice yeah we got top one yeah that'd be pretty pretty nice that'd be pretty cool windfield windfield why aren't you getting us top one um come on the closest that we all got was when it was just out there that's all i'm saying That's all I'm saying.
When it was Altaira now, we got second place without Winfield.
Toki, you wouldn't do this to Winfield.
He's been so great to us.
If he's been so great to us, why haven't we got first place?
I'll show more back to support.
I like my heal packs because I can save myself.
Bro, this stream ain't never gonna end.
Oh, boy.
Guys, no, no, it'll end here.
Right here, right now.
Right.
here right now attention soldiers attention bro he's gonna go grab a fucking tank for us oh tank go grab a beer too i can i believe maybe he plays better inebriated or something that's true that's true that's true that's true i believe actually you gotta drink too it's it's morning time perfect time drink what uh strong zero oh no thank you come on man strong zero has zero percent alcohol come on too too tired to drink you got this too tired let's go again i believe in us i don't want pizza i want to order pizza right now nah you know you want to eat fish bro it's the i know i do i don't know if there's like face open right now for fish and chips it's 7 p.m but i feel like fishing chip places like the good ones close so early oh they guys are like four or five yeah because they're like the fish just are asleep we gotta go now the fishie said good night yeah the fishies are had to go to sleep someone's like pop eyes no why did he get something else like that fayella express Here we go,
Altair.
We're going here.
This is it.
This is the game.
I believe this is it.
Why don't you get some tacos?
Like Birya.
Birya?
What do you say about me?
Birya.
Birya?
There you go.
Birya tacos.
Birya.
There.
Ni hao.
Okay.
Well, we went Chinese after that.
Chinese is good too.
That's true.
Also, there is a...
Chinese panda.
There is an engineer thing right here.
Oh, there is gunshots right here.
Yeah, but someone...
I've double shot them.
No, Winfield!
He's our only engineer!
one down what the two down are you serious what is this shotgun there's another guy right here lisa one one outside one downstairs one on me there's no way there is no way dad there's no way you fucker
one right on my body outside what fucking no jesus Second chance.
Bro, I had the shittiest shotgun.
It's crazy.
We're so far, holy shit.
I guess we'll just loot these shit scavenge house.
I'll loot whatever is available.
Whatever is here is better than what the fuck I got earlier.
Bro, what is this?
There's just someone sitting here.
Where were they sitting?
Oh my god, it's another goddamn shot.
you serious great game guys great game crazy where did you die in the building where is the building in the building wait you're died so far yeah this guy just camping in the in house man I got crazy oh shit but I love campers in this game jesus the more i'm covering you with you that's a shotgun i know i know you think i don't know that you think i don't know that he has a goddamn memory yeah you think yeah yeah yeah there we go i'll cover you all stuck these guys with a shotgun okay this guy missed in the the artillery what is my Reach out.
Are you fucking...
Get out of here.
He's 168.
I have a pistol.
That's goddamn right.
My turn.
There you go.
I got my shit.
Guy walking up.
Two people walking up.
Look at it.
It's not okay, but...
I'm shielding.
What the...
oh my god send it my guy says send it all right what it's over here somewhere i killed one right behind this thing over here i killed phil collins nice how do you feel about that man fuck phil in his and his family too yeah that's goddamn right remember yeah phil yeah okay Maybe not.
I'm leaving.
There's an artillery.
I'll let it a left one then.
All right, all right.
I'll come with you.
Okay.
All right.
I believe in us.
I'm going to do an interview with Winfield.
Yeah.
While we're fighting for our lives.
Mm-hmm.
It's like having a subway surfer while playing a game.
Oh, that's you.
Oh, yeah, that's you.
I think I know what to do with the reading flow power.
Winfield, you don't believe it.
Even us in live, oh wait, you go there, I chill up here.
Don't chill up here.
Don't chill.
There's a team right here.
There's team right here.
There's 19.
No, no, look at me.
Look at me.
They don't know I'm here.
All they do.
Shit.
Never mind.
No.
That's crazy.
unlucky unlucky unlucky it has been it has been a pleasure but this game is bullshit man it has been a pleasure we'll adopt someone in the wild i believe Winfield, it's been a pleasure.
It has been a pleasure, Winfield.
But you're out.
You're out, buddy.
I'll forever remember you as the person who was super drunk.
Super drunk.
Maybe we'll get a maybe we'll get a game re-after, Winfield.
You know, maybe we'll get Winfield 2.0.
Winnerfield.
I believe.
Winfield, if you get in our game, kill everyone else for us.
Yeah.
He's like one of those backpack people who just like dies in front of us.
Windfield.
If you're Q snipers right now.
Q snipers and then land where we land and then we'll adopt you as our fifth player.
I'll let you join Tempest.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll adopt you.
Just land on us.
Oh, Windfield.
Wait, Windfield.
Why are you here?
yes we fired you how are you still here you didn't even kick because we're expecting you to leave if we kick you it means we have to give you severance pay we need you to quit on your own
that's how it works if you quit we don't have to pay severance
you're abused i
can't believe it winfield what is that curse word that that i said what i won seven letters wait i've got an idea flocking guys guys today is my birthday can i win can you guys let me win
golf course
Happy birthday, Doki.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to me.
What did you get me as a birthday gift?
Altair?
I got you this rock.
No, I meant like monetary value.
It's a rock.
Oh, so you didn't get me anything for my birthday?
You don't care.
Listen, I got you the most important thing.
What, and it's free?
How is important is it free?
One of the most expensive things in the world is land.
And I got you some land right in your pocket.
it rock isn't land could be it's not land you don't care about me it's a dragon egg it's a dragon egg get me anything for my birthday because you don't care you know what you're that maybe i don't care he doesn't care he's a mean person dude oh i got shot at happy birthday that what a great Are you fucking kidding me?
How did he die?
Okay, great gun.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa, out there you are crazy.
How am I crazy?
What do I do?
Oh my god, there is a...
Oh wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I'm okay.
I'm so safe.
I'll tell you.
The railings are too safe.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I swear to God, I'm so safe.
You lied to me.
I swear I said, hey, look, you lived.
You lived.
Who's alive?
Because I'm a gamer.
You can't rely on people being gamers.
Nope, because it was so safe.
I was safe.
Where was this guy's gun?
I don't know.
wait wait oh shit i'm gonna shot again oh okay okay look i don't have nades this game is fucking bullshit why we spawn it doesn't give me nades bro welcome to the real world i killed one james is fucking right oh my god he also respawned too nice i'm gonna chase him too oh on me where is he where is he
one outside oh 20 20 oh we don't even know how much i hit him for it over here we are behind me nice i'm so safe i'm so safe guys nice see i told you guys i knew i was safe bro this pistol oh shit wait who are you how does he have a fucking revolver man where is he what is it Over here,
Axel!
Nice wind field!
This game is bullshit, bro.
I'm coming back in.
One gun in this whole area.
Second chance.
What do you mean dropping in my location?
God.
Kill the guy.
Oh my god, everyone is just here for I wish I could attach explosives to myself so I could just get fucking run into them Like Oh my, wait, that's ours.
Nice, Winfield.
Yeah, Winfield.
Yeah, Winfield killed everyone.
Winfield, thank you.
Oh my god, Winfield.
There were two people approaching my location.
Winfield heard what I said and is like leaving for the old form of all.
You know what?
You're rehired, Winfield.
Oh wait, they're resing.
They're resing.
Okay.
In front of me?
I got, he's slow, he's slow.
He's right.
Oh, did you get him?
Nice, nice, nice.
My turn.
Nice.
Up top the roof.
My turn.
There's people on both roofs behind us.
Watch out, Doki.
Both roofs?
Yeah.
Which one's the other?
One ping, on ping, on ping.
Oh my.
Yeah, I see it.
He's one HP.
I'm just gonna grab his and then try and get Axel real quick.
Are you fucking straight?
Oh my god.
I think I can.
I can't.
I can dodge this.
I just gotta sidestep.
Don't die.
I can dodge this.
I got it!
No!
I told you.
I got this.
Man, we're so good.
Wait, he's still sniping.
He's so low, though.
Where is he?
Is he on the roof?
Bro, he fucking did another!
He's trying!
I have to get out of here.
Oh my god.
I'm fine.
That's my last shield.
We just ungabongered his ass.
Oh my god.
sprinkler trust oh my god yeah cool cool fucking rats once again in the building just two guys sitting in a corner okay great game great game where is the okay good job coming back from the guys i'm gonna go to the next redeploy great game i'm running to the next one jesus how do people have so many rockets and mortars to strike yeah i know where do they get all of these i hear you no one i know where's our mortar strikes oh oh that looks so cool i'm gonna be in the grass right now something like that all right i'm heading over i'm gonna start the boomer corner oh well you used your recon ability that's no i just killed someone oh okay
Okay, Winfield, you gotta die, die.
Winfield, go die, die.
There's people around me.
I think there's people around me, too.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Lisa!
Okay, I'll tell you.
You gotta die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die,
die, die, die, die, die, die, okay, did you get it?
Oh, I tried I tried I'm heading to the next one.
Don't worry.
I did it ASAP.
I'm running to the next one right now I got that well.
Oh my god, I broke my legs.
It's fine.
Oh, yeah, thanks for always having my back, Axel Thanks for always having my back, Axel.
All right.
All right worries.
If only don't keep it would do that.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm just gonna hide in here then.
They call me Mr. R because I keep Come on, hide here.
Did they call you Mr. R?
No one will know.
Resing.
How would they know I'm here?
No one will know.
I am so safe right now.
No problem, Mike.
But we like literally use them all the redeployers.
Oh, they're coming.
Wait, I hear footsteps.
Out, out, out, out, out.
Oh.
Oh, that was you guys.
Hey, what is the exclamation mark drops?
What does that do?
Uh, if a game has drops for Twitch.
Yeah, it depends.
I don't know if Battlefield has drops.
But like, it's like the amount of hours you watch on a stream acts gives you access to like, uh, extra stuff, like custom skins or like badges or whatever.
It depends on the game.
Nice.
I'm ready.
Oh I hear a lot of gunshots Nice again like that 20 squads 20 squads guys.
That's a lot of squads Oh wait, I got a special weapon here here been fighting for our entire life Oh my god, we have because everyone got raised don't worry the moment the moment the seconds.
Oh, hey nice There's a gun Oh artillery strike guys, it's time marksman.
It's time I got my artillery strike now.
Oh, Winfield!
Winfield, no!
No!
I got one!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here, I need someone to...
I can cover if someone wants to res.
Oh, Winfield's dead.
Ow, ow.
I'm not lizard.
Oh, no.
Lisa.
Wait, I'm gonna shop by something else.
Hide behind this truck.
I think this truck is safe.
Gotta heal.
Winfield, no!
Yeah, I'm okay.
All right.
Winfield.
They're trying to push up.
This guy's second floor?
He's cracked.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Don't get knocked.
No more do-over.
I'm heading to the next redeploy, guys.
There's a car.
We have a car.
This is our only chance.
Get in here.
Axel, get in here.
We got it.
Oh, I'll kill him.
Nice.
Or down to that list.
Oh, no, it's okay, everyone.
It's okay.
Holy moly.
Okay.
Okay, we all get through here and then we all get here and we'll use the car as color.
Okay, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight!
Go, go, go, go, go, and then I'll tear it now.
We were going to this fight.
Okay, let's go!
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him!
I don't see him.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, there's something right.
Oh, oh, something exploded over there.
Over there!
Oh!
Oh shit.
Oh shit I think I did I'm dying.
I'm dying.
Oh No, oh no I'm down Die now die now die now die now die now die We said die now.
You could have got the rest out there I could still get rest If you die now you could have got it You could have got it I'm gonna grab another car I'm gonna grab the guy and pick us up.
Wait, guys.
There's a res northwest of me.
No!
Oh my god, I got sent.
I got sent.
But I'm okay.
Okay.
What a cinematic view.
Got me.
All right.
It's a car.
We go.
Yeah, we go.
We go to the next...
Red phi.
We go to the next one.
there's another one right here it's okay finally paved routes okay all right there you go there you go re-deploy re-deploy i'll park the car right here we need to go these are teammates right here right here right we've used like five re-deploys guys I don't know.
How many are there?
I don't know.
Fucking hell.
We're redsmapping.
On the bridge.
Which bridge?
To your right a little bit, Axel?
Yeah, right there.
I saw a guy running on top of the bridge.
What?
Here?
Looks suspicious.
Watch yourself.
Apparently.
I'm looking.
There's another car here too that we can use.
Check your map for new mission details.
I feel so safe.
What?
I have artillery strike too if we need it.
Team in that building right over there.
Oh, across the street, across the street.
Ping, ping, ping.
Okay, I see.
Didn't mean to do that.
I got the one we filled down.
Nice.
There is Nice I'm trying to thirst him but I gotta go I thirsted him, I thirsted him Nice I got shot to him Oh my god I got snipe, I got snipe, I got snipe I got snipe
Don't let me get sniped Don't let me get sniped Oh my god I hanged in there.
Get stabbed.
Hanging in there.
Fights north of us.
We can look to pick off some people.
I don't know where the sniper came from.
So, like, he could still be there sniping.
Uh, people running across east, across the road.
Bro, where the fuck was that sniper that fucked me up?
How are these bullets just not hitting?
I hate this custom sniper.
It stole us.
Good damage.
Where are you guys shooting at?
Uh, east.
East?
Okay, I'm looking.
Hey, we're on that truck right over there.
It was just one guy?
Two people, I think.
Okay, so there has to be another guy there then.
Oh, I'm so paranoid right now.
They could be anywhere.
Oh, we gotta go to zone.
We gotta go to zone.
Zone, zone.
Shoot him in the dome, dome.
go in the zone no oh wait wait in front of me okay okay he's one he's one i hit 40 i hit 40.
30.
that's a squad white 115 meters got a huge gunfight right here if you guys want to stay dying made down there there's also a huge gunfight and this guy he just ran across the street to our our building okay there is there was a drone near me so i'm a little afraid about that also we have to go to uh let's see you okay okay oh air strike air strike oh we're gonna get out we gotta get out i'm okay i'm gonna i'm gonna try the back i'm gonna try on the back oh they're just wrapping around in the oh my oh my god they're right behind us fucking hate players like this bro really you come back from your fucking nine to five and then you rat your whole game come on guys let's run at people instead hey come on oh i'm trying to do it until he strikes i'm so sad i didn't get i was i didn't realize no wind field oh the red sick dads aren't good people i didn't think they're gonna come out i said i do i should have ran i should have ran with him oh my god i can't believe they're right us oh my god
we're doing it guys we're doing it guys yeah we're doing it i believe it's getting there how do we kick winfield does he want to be kicked no no he redeemed himself because we got someplace he redeemed himself hey winfield i ordered pizza i'm gonna order pizza right now what pizza is your favorite pizza you know the pepperoni with honey spicy honey that is so good not had that it's so good it's like spicy honey no it's not a canadian thing it's actually really really good i'm gonna say i like i like spicy honey spicy honey yeah like uh the hallucinogen hot honey it's like hot honey it's crazy good all right that just sounds like some donald's nugget dip hot honey you don't know you don't know you don't know good when you see it It's so good.
That doesn't really sound like a pizza pizza.
Oh, pizza pizza is also good.
Hot honey is so good.
I'm like, you know what?
All right, I went with a pizza.
Would you guys try that hallucinogenic honey?
What the fuck?
There's this honey.
That's all right.
That this tried, like, they, they, they, they, they harvest the honey.
And apparently it gives you like hallucinogenic effects.
It's crazy.
I think.
I think that's them getting stung by the bees and they're like fucking losing no no no no I promise it's not the sting honey it's the actual honey isn't it like really expensive that one I think was like so I think it was like two thousand dollars for like one small like bottle of it or some Jesus yeah I mean I feel like it takes a while to get that shit like in the middle of the rainforest and they have to climb like these big ass fucking trees yeah all the way at the top of some ship but they like why don't we just ask rpr or or or knock knock to uh climb the trees for us that's true and get the hundred why did you do it we're the talent we don't do that just be american just shoot everything down you know we the talent or you can do the bushfire method if that what's the bushfire method oh you just set the bush on just set it on fire Yeah,
set it on fire.
Come on guys.
It's just that easy.
I'm worried.
Yeah, just set it on fire.
This item is unavailable.
I just gotta get you.
Get just gotta get yourself a pineapple and ham.
Bro, I don't want to order from Pizza Hut.
I want something.
Bro.
Come on.
Pineapple and pizza is good.
I don't want to order from Pizza Hut.
Why does people hate pineapple and fun?
Because it's weird.
It's weird.
because the sweet is too it's too much the sweet and like the sourish kind of clashes with the hardy of the that's why it's good the oil oh no oh no the game is about to start i was looking at my pizza but i don't know what to eat why don't you get yourself some chinese takeaway instead you know because i want pizza i'm craving pizza you should get bulgogi pizza or kimchi pizza okay i don't think they have that in oh i'm the jump master i don't i'm passing i don't think get a chinese pizza that's like the ultimate the chinese pizza it's not what i want though i want like i want italian pizza or like well actually we're gonna chicken and honey he's not in town that does not sound italian at all on there okay i want to say oh wait where oh there's people inside here already fuck me i am trying to find any kind of gun i don't know where the loop where the fuck are the loop boxes in this area i i was in that windfield oh my goodness i found one box there's a guy with a gun on me okay i
have a another shotgun as always all i get is shotguns i guess i'm so safe i'm so safe no you're not my safetyness is so safe it's rated as for safe you're not safe and i know you're lying are you kidding me like are you hate this game maybe i should just stop playing hey maybe i should someone was here no no no we can stop playing after we finish the stream well yeah yeah you can stop playing uninstall after after the stream bro i hate this game yeah uninstall after the stream it's axel we gotta have we gotta have zen okay zen embody the regis altar there's a lot of people dying in front of me separate those murderous thoughts to somewhere else my long-range shotgun pig shit is such an issue slug rounds i have so many bullets just not registering it's kind of bullshit hey you know what what though what were you doing bro snappy snappy snappy yeah the aston altar stands for safe you're right you're right i agree i feel so safe
all right winfield's dead winfield's dead again Winfield, come on, buddy.
Why are you dead?
Okay, I'm gonna, like, chill a little bit, and I'm gonna stay here.
Wait, whatever I do...
Oh, does the artillery strike work in here?
Oh, shit.
Wait, Axel!
Let's go, Axel!
Shake him!
What?
Okay.
Okay, it just took me like 10...
Okay, I...
Look, it took me 10 years to get the bomb pad.
Oh, my god, his friend came over.
I'm coming No, no, don't come over He res, he res, he res Don't worry, I leave, I leave I'm getting pinged It took so long To get the fucking command for Taking the dog tag, man So, oh, Winfield's like, I'm trying to kill them But I was 1v3, so I'm sorry Yeah,
you should be sorry, you should have 1v4 In fact, I'll switch teams 1v5 Yeah, exactly, Winfield God damn.
Oh, I can't order pizza.
No!
I can eat a pot!
It's my safe tunnel.
I'm a little worm.
I'm an old caterpillar in my chrysalis.
Yeah, I'm gonna boil you in the pot.
Wait, Axel die.
Axel die.
I'm gonna boil you in the pot.
I die.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go find another re-deploy.
Sorry, I died.
Wait, did you use that one?
I don't remember.
Alright, then I guess I'll go to the next read-a-play and hope that one is safe.
That's a chopper.
I said, went to the fucking...
Where the fuck is the read-a-play?
Oh, wait, that was the read-a-play.
I went to the goddamn mellic.
Oh, wait, no, it's over here.
I was like, where the fuck is it?
Hey, the chopper strat is a method, you know?
It is a method.
Until they shoot gunners down.
Just don't get gunned down.
I don't like this because I'm on low ground too.
Ah, it's fine.
Did you guys know that assault class does these redeploys faster?
Whoa.
Oh, really?
Who's in the assault class?
Who's in the assault class, Axel?
I am.
Oh, I hear people.
second life second life second life let's go let's go let's go alone with my pistol we back it's like you guys never died heroes never die oh my god i keep getting shock all i get is shotguns like there's no other gun in existence in this game it's just oops all shotguns
okay yep there's no loot great No, there's nothing here.
Don't forget to check the cars.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I'm going to jump off a building.
Whoa.
Guys, do you think we're going to...
Guys, do you think we're going to get the win in 12 hours, guys?
Oh, I don't think so.
Probably not.
Within 12 hours, just one win.
Guys, it's going to...
But like, when we get that win, it's going to feel so good, though.
You know?
oh yeah it feels so good also there's a team right here nope i literally saw them redeploy there i saw a parachute up top okay we peaked like an hour like two hours ago that's the saddest part what do you mean that's the saddest part we're still growing are we see i'm i'm all about cautious optimism are we are we though we in the middle wait guys technically we're in the middle technically yeah i'm gonna go underneath this parking lot and then what is this watch this guy oh wait there's loot here guys we loot a little bit and then we find a spot i think technically you know i think you know i get able to do something here if there was any loot to be had like what if i just hide like there's not they're not gonna send a strike here what if i just cry oh i can order my pizza give me a sec pizza oh it's fine that's in there i'm literally out out of the ring for that i'll be fine me star pizza deployable cover it's like like next to me but i'm okay let's see oh oven a cheesy alfredo flying
in wait wait wait wait northwest what northwest just flow in watch out axel axel are you okay oh my god oh he's uh up top up top top yeah yeah yeah they're up top yeah wait they're above us yeah it's okay we're safe here oh what's my three what is this how do I show it oh c4 oh I have c4 four guys nice we should have five sniper someone coming down or up no no we're safe we're safe here this is like so safe guys i think this is end zone people up here this is end zone guys all right i can upgrade my smg how oh upgrade oh you guys should have seen the barrels fighting
Ooh, maybe I should get my pasta with my pizza too.
Ooh, oven, big, cheesy Alfredo pasta.
Yummy.
Ooh, chicken, food.
Oh, I should get the chicken Alfredo pasta.
Oh, that sounds so good.
Yeah, that sounds so good.
Pasta is so mid.
I'm sorry to say it.
Okay, well, nobody's asking for your wrong opinion.
Pasta is mid.
No one's asking your very wrong.
Coming, coming, coming.
Oh, shit.
She went back up and went back up.
It's okay.
to order i can order my pizza right yeah i'll move like here oh oh one dead nice nice don't worry guys i'm i'm helping a teammate artillery strike i don't really like supreme pizza i haven't had pizza in so long so it's so hard to decide what i want rila thank you the super chef 48 hour stream oh wrong gone fuck he left that oh pepperoni duo
Is this the highest part of the of the building?
Not quite.
Oh my god.
They look the same.
This all looks like a fucking a yard.
First up, pad.
Roof is clear.
It is?
Okay, cool.
That's good.
We chased them off.
Nice.
I believe in you guys.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Smoke's green.
Well, all out Italian sausage, classic pepperoni and caramel.
Oh, that sounds good.
I'm grabbing that.
Axel, do you see this over here?
huh there was some smoke in front of us right here yeah where they're deploying there oh i'm gonna get this stuff crust i love stuff crust okay so low windfield's down oh shit windfield no do you guys need help oh from behind us it's somewhere somewhere okay i'm coming over i'm coming oh did you raise windfield yeah yeah yeah okay okay that's good okay i'm going back to my pizza Oh my god.
Okay.
Get to the bottom.
Wait, wait.
Get down here, guys.
Get down here.
Don't worry.
This is a safe spot.
All right, back to my pizza order.
Oh, I want to grab some.
Ooh, I would love.
Is it the roasted garlic or like the roast type?
You should get some island.
It's so shit.
Is it just me?
Okay, let me, all right.
I got mine.
All right, let's see.
Now I'm going to see what kind of beverages I want.
Do I want any special beverages?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, draw a dick.
Draw a dick.
Yeah, yeah.
Draw some boss and then grab someone.
Draw someone whacking it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Draw someone whacking it too.
Like an actual dick, you know?
Yeah, PP.
About PP.
Like with all the hair and shit.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Guys, guys, I'm still ordering my pizza.
Calm down.
Defend Doki while she's ordering her pizza.
I'm ordering my pizza right now.
Calm down, everyone.
All right, I got it.
Okay, we should be fine.
Okay, oh, what do you feel?
No, they're right here.
Got him, got him, got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I can actually play the game now.
All right, guys, we're fine.
There's a custom SMG here.
Oh my god, that's a different gun.
Alright, I dropped a sniper here if anyone wants it.
We've got to move though.
The zone is not at all.
No!
We're not in middle of the zone?
You know what?
Never.
That was a good place to chill when I was ordering my pizza.
I hope you ordered it very fast and very well.
Oh, well.
I won't say fast.
How do I get out of here?
Yeah, I was like, I don't do it yet.
I like how we were outside for a bit and we went back inside
Secret tunnel Yeah On top of this roof Okay Great Okay we actually try to get over here Yeah We'll try There is a car right in front of us Like a car to Wait how do we get out of here?
I think we might need to take the elevator Or stairs Ammo?
Oh, here you go Take my ammo you hoi I'm gonna take it not everyone's a whore because they want ammo take it it's right in front of you that's right that's right yeah you know your place
are you still above us oh i think we're good okay we gotta go well there's a car in front of us we risk it Do we need it?
There is a chop.
All right.
You know what?
I'll take the car.
Gunshots.
Oh, yeah.
Are we going for the gunshots?
Should we go to zone?
There's a car.
Yeah, I'm getting the car.
I thought you don't trust the car.
There's a car right in front of us.
No, there's a car right in front of us that's driving around.
Well, I'm going to go into zone.
See you guys.
This guy right at zone next to us.
I'll meet you guys in zone, guys.
I'll meet you in zone.
I think me and Winfield gonna die.
Oh shit.
We trapped.
No, go upstairs.
No, wait.
No, I'm heading to the next arena boy guys I've got you We just stuck here Wait, wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
I'm gonna come over.
I'm coming over.
Oh, no.
Oh No, okay.
Okay.
You had so much time to leave.
Yeah, oh my god.
What the fuck would you okay?
Okay.
I'm fucked.
There is a car next to me Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize there's a car.
No!
Oh my god.
There was nearly...
There was a rat.
Oh, I don't care.
There is one redeploy all the way in the middle of the zone.
I believe.
Yeah, take the car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Am I gonna make this?
This game is a scam, bro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
Yeah, there's only seven squads.
You just gotta sit there and get I.
No, but he's not gonna 1v4.
There's no way.
Of course I'm gonna 1v4, huh?
Don't you know who I am?
Okay, yeah, let's sit there.
Shroud 1v4.
Yeah, but that was Prime Shroud.
That was Prime Shroud.
Yeah, he's just an old man now, you know.
Shroud signed my Steam profile, so I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm.
I'm just channeling the energy that I saved since 2017.
Where is it?
Did it get used?
No.
Oh, it's getting used right now.
Literally.
Last redeploy.
Oh, wait, wait.
Someone's getting shot at that redeploy now.
Yeah.
You should rat it until they're gone and then use it again.
Fiverr, man.
Wait, wait, wait.
At this point, just rat in the grass.
You're not going to know.
You guys see that rock?
You see that rock?
Just prone on it.
Yeah.
Oh, my goodness.
There was no one else rapping already.
I heard him, too.
Oh, he took your spot.
He took your...
No!
Ain't no way, bro.
He took your spot right after that's crazy.
It's actually crazy.
What a timing.
The fact that he took this spot after.
He got out reddit, bro.
You actually got out reddit.
What a timing, bro.
Winter leaves again.
Bro was like, this is my spot.
Yeah, bro.
Just like trying to take my spot, bro.
Crazy.
Get out reddit.
Let's play next game, I believe.
next game i'm gonna kill i'm gonna kill and watch this i'm gonna kill yeah i said it whoa kill the whole hopefully not my teammates with grenades i'll try my best not to do that
let's go you know what i'm guys i need to confess something i'm purposely playing bad so we can play longer that's why i keep dying guys I My dad works for Nintendo I'm giving me band Yeah guys I'm purposely sandbagging Right now Yeah I'm sandbagging at the moment Windfield our battle angel We need your buddy We need a 1v4 We got a win Come on bro Well you're stuck with us for 12 hours I think he doesn't care Hey,
Winfield, you got a Twitch?
You got a YouTube?
Winfield, come on, bro.
Come on, buddy.
Why aren't you trying?
Why aren't you trying, Winfield?
I thought you were a gamer.
My dad went to get milk.
I hope he never comes back.
What?
I am your father.
That's kind of crazy.
life's tough where yeah life's tough okay i wanted to have like false hope damn toky that's crazy yeah and we still haven't won a game so technically i'm allowed to say that we got so close we got so close we got so close i missed that day when we got that was such a nice I'm looking at my pizza word right now,
but when when we got second place together, Altair man those were the days those were the days those were the good old days big torn Japanese tournaments for Apex?
Nah, nah, nah.
That one time we got second place in battlefield.
That's where real gamers at.
Right there.
What's the watch?
man reclaim our former glory all right where do we go pochinkie pochinkie pochinkie's my city let's go to linden b johnson oil works linden oil works man i want to marry an oil baroness bro please take care of just get an oiler you mean like a saudi princess get an oil rig easy oh yeah i mean if i could just you know oops i suck at this you want to marry an asadi princess what would you do with that money like would you be like a house husband no no no i'll like go to the pokies maybe go gamble all the money away gamble your wife's money yeah gamble your not even his wife's money gamble his like His father-in-law's Money But you know those guys Can get you assassinated Yeah Yeah Like you think Oh come on Papi It's just a little bit Of your money Yeah If you Use up All Like you know His daughter's money He's gonna get you He's gonna get you Bro He's gonna give you More money Watch out Yeah He's gonna give you More money He's gonna Give you You're gonna handle More money Yeah Show me
He's gonna make him Disappear Bro So I'm going to show him the strat to win the pokies, and I'm going to get him into it, too, you know?
Bro, he's going to make you gamble it at his casino.
So he gets back his own money.
All right, so money laundering, right?
So he gives me the money, but in order for him to get the money legally, I go to his casino.
No, he builds a casino just for you, so like, it gives you like monotony.
Just like...
yeah it is yeah only him in this casino and he's like yeah but he doesn't he doesn't tell axa he's like yeah yeah look look at this new casino that like um that just opened up but it's actually owned by your father-in-law just so he makes sure that you don't fucking gamble all the money hey money laundering come on it can't be that no he doesn't even give you real money he just he's like hey please please send a lot here's some allowance and it's like fake money this is this is paper money from this place called monopoly they're like oh yeah in saudi arabia we have this new currency that we are just introducing right now and it's green yellow red gold too yeah yeah Yeah,
it's our new currency, bro.
Yeah.
I'm not finding any good loot.
Where am I hearing this...
Beep, beep thingo from?
Someone flying in right in front of us.
Not in front of us.
I feel like there'd be someone in that...
I feel like there'd be someone in that area.
Maybe?
Ah, it's this one here.
It looks scary enough.
Somebody just redeployed.
I got the I got the UAV Ooh, a good assault rifle right here Ooh Nah, oh wait Ooh, yeah, I'll take that I still don't even know what gun is good I've just been grabbing whatever I find Honestly, SMGs are goaded They're so stable Nice I'm going Whoa, I'm going to this house in front of me Okay,
there's a team in here Careful I can use a UAV Don't worry there will be i'm gonna make sure the team disappears oh there was a team here you don't believe me no i definitely see that there's one person one person one person there gotta be more gotta be more yeah he's gotta have more landing more guys artillery oh no i think we'll live oh that's our artillery now too oh they're not gonna know How will they know?
How will they know which one's ours and which one's theirs?
Is he asking me?
They're not.
That's right.
That's the fun of it.
Where the fuck are they?
I don't know where they went.
Yeah, where are they?
They should be here still.
His teammate and then they, like, pussyed out.
We are not in the center.
We are not.
rotate into the center you guys want to do that we could wait there's a smoke over here did they oh invite me okay okay i see him i see him they're literally oh my god they're literally trying to fucking oh my god bro i'm getting pinged the diff man it's just so much faster there mate jump there they are oh all right it's fine going upstairs going upstairs it's not fine wait you're Oh,
wait.
Winfield, it's okay.
Winfield, I believe you can 1v3 this.
You ain't no nerd.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
I knew it.
It's okay.
Winfield's coming.
Winfield's here.
That's right.
Nice, nice.
We got a res.
Winfield, get over here.
Res or kick?
Res or kick.
No, let Winfield.
No, no, no, no.
Winfield has to res.
Winfield has to Rez or kick, Winfield.
Wait, why am I not not Rez?
Guys?
This people, this people, this people.
Winfield!
Alright, guys.
Winfield, when I said Rez or kick, Winfield did not, Rez.
We should kick his sack.
It's time for it.
We should whack his sack.
It's whacking time.
Yeah, it's whacking time.
I don't see him.
They may have fallen back.
Oh, I'll throw your axe his back.
Hello.
I don't need her back.
Yeah.
I think they left.
Leave that man's sack alone.
But it's going to be lonely, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, you should hold his hand.
Hold his sack.
Axel, you hold his sack?
Oh, whack that shit so hard.
behind behind behind oh no what oh my god i'm stuck in the bathroom i'm safe i'm safe i'm safe thank you i'm heading over i'm coming over artillery inbound i'm turning inbound i'm gonna take cover right now same zis we're technically at the edge of this artillery oh i'm not in the artillery range now we should go help her all right i'm gonna go over it we got help Winfield.
Winfield's going at it.
Winfield's wild.
Oh, shit.
Winfield!
No!
Why Winfield!
Dude, fucking Elvis.
Oh, my God.
It's not it.
I have to leave.
Oh, my God.
See, Bobby?
I don't know.
I don't know, but I have to...
He's on me.
Where are these guys?
I don't know.
I'm just...
One HP on me.
I need reload.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you okay or nah?
I'm dead.
Okay.
We're not okay.
I'm just gonna leave.
I don't trust.
how do i leave this area though just jump out the window climb up there and jump out oh my god i gotta find the redeploy i'm going for the redeployer windfield no windfield you're wild windfield why i'm not gonna lie that uh aiming scheme wasn't the greatest idea but it worked i guess Winfield,
why were you a hero?
Hello.
Oh my god, hey.
Never be a hero.
But I was born to be one.
Yeah, sometimes you can change your career path.
What if the world depends on you being a hero?
No, I don't.
Wait, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Wait, what?
Die, Winfield, die.
Winfield, die, Winfield!
Winfield!
Yay!
Wait.
I don't think he made it.
Oh, Winfield, you first.
Oh my god.
Winfield.
Alright, let's keep going forward.
Oh, Winfield.
If we circle around security gate, it should be a little bit, should be a little bit safer, right?
I mean, Axel, okay, I was surprised Axel didn't try to redeploy to the other redeploy.
So like...
Where's the redeploy?
Ah!
Nice.
I got one.
Nice, nice, nice.
I don't know what to do.
There's another on the right side.
Hang on.
I have a default.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, artillery inbound.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to go redeploy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
People dropping in.
I'm running.
I'm running as fast as I can.
I left.
I'm heading.
I'm going over to...
Going over to Axel.
There's custom places.
There's custom loot boxes.
Those are...
No, no, no, no, no.
We gotta go to Reno.
people on me people on me oh god okay okay okay okay i'm running the other way wait what i'm going to the other redeploy dude are you kidding me i'm going to the other redeploy please oh no oh no no no no i still live i still live that is your duty i don't think i can live live live i'm heading
hard here and that makes me very scared great game guys it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay there is another read up there and that is the one i'm gonna take i shall die then goodbye
why do we hear this so often i'm gonna hear you in my sleep what do you
all right there you go we're all back we're all back yeah all right so we're not in the zone so we gotta move into zone again where should we go should we go to like where do we go where are you guys redeploying to i'm falling out there
I believe Am I right?
Am I right?
There's a sniper right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I came there.
Here for that sniper.
Oh, my god.
Axel!
I'm not...
No, no, no, no, Axel, dude!
There's just a fucking rat to think.
There ain't no fucking way, man.
Okay, okay.
There's just a rat.
Don't worry, don't worry.
There's another redeploy.
I'm oh oh my god oh my god oh my god he survived there's a need the airstrike do you have airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the airstrike down there
oh my god oh
yeah those airstrikes are nuts hey please guys top 10 it's okay next game next game next game i believe one more one next game next game they're pissing me off playing this stupid fuck now i see why it didn't really blow up hey it's because our graders came out afterwards so everybody started playing art graders i mean there's a reason why but everyone sticks with that game how many players are our graders huh how many players is our graders i don't know i mean it's a it's a it's a what's It's called extraction shooter.
So people just come in and come out.
I just see people on my friends list just popping up.
Playing arc raiders.
Yeah, I see so many people just playing arc raiders.
Everyone's just arc raiding.
I think a lot of people just...
Do people still role-playing arc raiders or what?
Oh.
And they'll be like, don't shoot, don't shoot.
You know, like shit like that.
Oh.
Or if you feel started shooting again.
Oh, three?
Oh, no, can you play an instrument?
Yeah, I can.
I can play the flute.
We should make a wandering orchestra.
A wandering orchestra?
Actually, you want to join in?
I'll pass.
I'll be the viewer.
He can be the guy who like, you can be our management.
Yeah, you can be our manager.
I'll do that guy.
You guys are the band, right?
I'll do the fucking guy who swings his wand like a magician on the stage.
What was that guy called?
The conductor?
Yeah, the mage throw looking ass.
it conducting yeah the one that just swings a stick thinking he's doing something but you know it's yeah you're just like where are you why guys i can do that you can win a game guys guys do you let's ask our chat you think we can win guys guys guys wait field you won't be the bum in the squad of the bum on the side of the road and we don't get first in this game oh that's right we don't get first in this game Winfield you're out oh you're out and I will ban you from my stream that's right pressure is coming Winfield and I'll ban you on Altair stream too because I modded on that on if we win on this one right now I'll follow you on Twitter I'll follow you we don't need a win it's a it's a it's a trash game Bro,
Axel, when we win...
When we...
He gave a sad smile!
Welcome to the real world.
Trash game.
That's right, Winfield.
Everything is lying on this game now.
Focus.
What the hell is this?
Your stream is being featured on the homepage carousel?
Yeah, with me getting butt fucked left and right.
No!
You language!
Yeah, so keep going.
Hell yeah, let's get this guys.
See, you're on the front page.
You said you were like, oh, how do I get on the front page?
Now you're on the front page.
Is that what you wanted?
Hi, Twitch.
Can you guys change my name from Regis Alter underscore hollow serves underscore Ian to Regis Alter please?
Thank you.
Did you not request for that?
What the fuck?
No, I didn't sign up for this event, my bad.
Bro, that's on you.
You should sign up for the event and then like...
I've been asking for years.
And you should sign up for the event.
Ah, baby man.
Get destroyed, nerd.
Dead man walking.
And then be like, oh, sorry, I couldn't show up because I was sick.
I got sick.
I was making a fat shit.
I couldn't show up.
Yeah.
Oopsies.
I got sick, guys, so I can't do holiday.
And then you get your own custom name.
Someone on me.
Yeah, I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Oh, there's three.
Two more, two more.
Coming over still.
We sat.
Oh, no.
How many people are there?
Two.
One's down.
It's three now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They got the other guy up.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm going back to Axel.
There's three.
I don't think we're going to win this fight.
Ah.
I'm retreating.
I'm bravely retreating.
You just had to add bravely in front of us.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm very bravely retreating right now.
I'm bravely sprinting as fast as I can away from the area.
Relocating.
Oh, can I not climb that?
That's unlucky.
Wait, but what if I...
There's no way that I know I'm up here.
Skadoosh.
Good at the doododoo.
All right.
is going back in okay winfield winfield winfield winfield his name is fun to say at least that's good yeah i got a shot from my back but i don't know from where i'm heading i'm still handing over to you guys.
Someone res knew you guys, careful.
In front of me?
Yep, we're resting.
We're resting.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I know I'm not.
Got you back.
Nice!
Oh my god, are you serious?
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no, I'm dead.
I'm dead here.
I got cross-fired like hell.
Like, there's like 20 people on every...
What do you guys gotta leave?
What do you...
Great game.
It's okay.
I have one more res.
Axel.
It's okay, Axel.
I believe.
Sniper does not work with this ping.
It's just so miserable, man.
Jesus.
It's okay.
I'm finding the closest redeployed, and I'm gonna land there.
Ah!
I checked the entire area.
still there wait wait we feel this safe though windfield is safe wait we all have read applies technically except yeah yeah yeah we all have one don't worry when you go fly to the readaport you live you survive okay look this man he's running with conviction where's the closest one i'm gonna go here
thanks for playing with us the waxel no problem i don't even fucking see the redeploy thingy i see it uh there's one to your right in front of you i'm gonna do the craziest redeploy guys watch these okay windfield die you gotta die windfield you gotta die he died okay good windfield he was born to die oh wait you're here
Yeah.
There is a chopper.
There's a chopper above us.
Okay, I'm going to the houses nearby to see if there's loot.
Yeah.
Oh, there's like...
All right.
I believe this is it.
This is the game guys.
This is it.
There's no loot.
This is the game.
I believe.
This is it.
This is the game.
Axel, we need it from you too.
Yeah.
This is it.
Okay.
There's no gun in this house.
I can't even find a single container.
Wait, there's no guns here.
Where are the guns?
You know what?
I should just...
Oh my goodness.
There's people here.
Where are you?
Should we do a mission then?
Great.
Wait, where is Axel?
Maybe I should just fucking go in a chopper and just go fucking like kill myself, you know, like...
Wait, you go into chopper and then like, like fly into an enemy.
I am gonna go...
I'm playing on NA server anyways, right?
I like keep a cannon, you know what I'm saying?
Keep a cannon that way.
Wait, Axel, you're still alive though.
for now wing ring prediction where is it predicting uh honestly if it keeps pulling towards us this is really good for us isn't it yeah yeah that's true we could just chill here it's like our little suburban house look at that cheap rent watch this guys i close the door and yeah the rent is so cheap that's why oh my god what the fuck i just oh it was a lead look this is my no loot here you I got my gun.
When's my pizza getting here?
Winfield's gonna deliver it once we win.
Yeah, exactly.
So no pizza until we win.
I wish I had guns.
I have a gun for you, Winfield.
You come over.
Come over here.
I got you a gun.
I found a gun.
Yeah, I have gun.
Come over.
Alright.
these squads let's go we're doing it we're doing it all right zone prediction time i think zone would will take us here wait how do i ping on this map yeah oh this is kind of cool what is this wait what are you doing are you on the plane what is that if i get that oh wait that's stupid what's this oh is that my smoke oh oh my god could smoke this entire time oh my god 24 hours to learn that smoke no i couldn't i didn't realize i have like a smoke screen oh guys oopsie so the thing that could have saved us whoa who would have thought so you're giving me a lot of crap from my vision where's your smoke screen huh no no no no no because i yeah have medkit and i've been using that well i am cute so that's what i just had a cargo i just had a car go by me yeah and you're alive you're alive just remember that oh my god they just see me yeah like this game like you know i'm just uninstalling it after this probably yeah just one of those winfield winfield go go and go go to rest go rest right
now winfield i'm gonna
strats count okay just straight for next round um we go to a high loot area we scram we find a house and do nothing man i don't even get the loot ship hey i'm scared guys i'm so scared this is bollocks oh wait windfield wasn't in the helicopter
Oh Do you think it's safe to go outside now?
Go out there and perish like a brave brave warrior.
I'm gonna wait.
I'll wait.
There's no way Oh It'll be fun saying there's a juicy juicy redeploy yeah i want i wonder how my three teammates fucking died oh my god okay okay guys chill guys chill chill a little bit chill a little bit because i hear gunshots okay guys just chill i'm gonna wait till this ring closes and then see oh wait what why do i see people fighting in front of me oh are you all hacking no do you see that on the map yeah oh someone's uh redeploying i think yeah um
you think i can make it all the way here to the i think you can do anything Oh, why is there so much heat airstrikes around me?
Why is the world so dangerous?
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I'm in the garage.
No one ever checks the garage.
I'm in the...
Ah, always rat thing, Mr. Dolphy.
I don't know how you guys died.
Shit, this fucking...
These fuckers rolled up in a tank and decided to just fuck me in a house.
Yeah, I'm saying we could have all been in the garage.
But I don't know why you guys were running around.
Oki, we could have all died together.
Come on.
We could have all been.
Yeah, and I'm alive.
I write my fucking story.
Oh, my God.
There's a dud through our...
What is wrong with this neighborhood?
There was like four things in this neighborhood.
This is why the rent's so cheap, Oki.
Honestly, I would do that too if I was in America.
I'll just buy a Glock to keep my rent cheap.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I said last week.
Keep the crime rate high to make the rent cheap.
Yeah, I'll just like...
I wake up on a Sunday morning.
Oh, it's a nice day.
I'll whip up my Glock, and then I just start going, Baa, Baa, Baa.
Forgetting in there.
You gotta do it the way that...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I don't think I'll be able to redeploy any of it.
us guys it's getting a little scary out here no there's so many there's a helicopter right there helicopter there's another deploy right there there is all right there is one okay i have to cross the city of hell to get to that redeploy and then and then oh there's oh that redeploy nevermind that report is god that's god oh and then there's also oh my god still so big holy dookie if you win this one i'll i'll give you ten bucks oh my god there's people too there's people behind me i'm just literally oh my houses oh my poor house my poor house my poor house oh no oh no this neighborhood is leaving me oh and then someone used the other redeploy at the top so there's a team to the right and then there's someone in the car on my right side and then there's a team to our left just chilling there and oh and I hear gunshots to my left right now okay guys I don't know guys you might need to leave soon okay but when is soon oh I hear people outside my door oh and then there's another artillery
strike oh I can wait a little over a little bit.
Make it count.
Oh, there is literally a team right in front of me.
I don't know if you guys saw the flashes.
The flashes on my map.
Do you see that?
They're like having a little rave party in front of me.
These are the cute trees.
There's a little rave party.
And then there's a team to my role.
Look at that.
They're having a party in those trees right now.
Having a gun.
The fire approaches.
And then there's like a team that's on the car.
as well where the fuck is going on and then there's an artillery strike in front of me how many fucking oh my god i have to leave now too run ducky oh my oh my god
i'm gonna be in the fire a little bit take your knife out Okay.
Oh my god.
At least Deep has Poopsie died.
That's good.
Mr. Poopsie.
Okay, I can still hug the ring.
I can still hug the ring a little bit.
There's a UAV above.
So it probably sees you.
Nice kill!
Mr. Poopsy again!
It is Mr. Poopsy.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Top 11.
Oh, squad white!
Nice.
I'm so fucking scared.
Alright, no armor now!
No armor!
You just got your last three, last three That's all you gotta do.
No army.
Don't bother.
There's a team to my right.
So I know what that means.
I go to my left.
Oh, there's a team to my left, right?
That's hugging the wall just like me.
Are you fucking- No!
No!
You fucking- No!
I'm surrounded!
I'm fucking surrounded!
What do I do?
There!
That's 10 plays!
Top 10.
Winfield is another day.
I'm just saying Winfield.
Oh, Winfield left.
I'm saying.
Winfield.
Okay, but Winfield, I will be a generous, humble guy and you will not be banned on my channel just for today thanks for playing windfield just for today
i've decided to take pity on you yeah i decided to pity you i'm so generous don't worry guys four hours in and we were yeah we got second guys that was our first hour but we got second you don't have to quite point that out i'm already getting sleepy yo i'm getting no no but it's morning for you yeah it's morning how can you be tired axel no i only slept for like three hours come on bro come on axel don't be weak this ain't it this ain't it why are you so weak bro while you i don't you know about high paying ain't it This ain't like Apex,
bro.
I can't fight.
I get Instamelt.
Wait, can you pick service?
I could probably have him host.
Oh, yeah.
You should be hosted.
Be host.
He's gonna be so miserable.
Nah, don't, uh, just keep it.
What do you mean?
Are you a pussy?
Well, I'm just too tired already.
Speaking of pussies, Winfield's back.
Wait, how did he come back?
I thought...
I don't know.
Wait, how did...
He wasn't in my lobby.
Wait, what?
Oh, my.
Is he...
Winfield?
be like you gotta lock in bro you gotta lock in i've been seeing your performance reports and um they've been slacking lately you know like you got do you do you want to provide for your family winfield because it doesn't look like you care about your family you know everyone's worried about providing for a family just get rid of your family then you don't have to provide for anyone right your death and then yeah just make your death and move to another country i am that's why i'm telling If you don't want to be the family guy,
just, you know, just cut all ties, eh?
But family, they buy you Pikachu stuff.
I'm going to check Winfield's stats.
I'm having trouble believing he's won a game now.
I need it.
No, that's right.
I'm looking at your shit now.
We're snooping now.
View profile.
Oh, you're so lucky we got in game.
Oh, wait, there you go.
All right.
Oh, boom.
Winfield, where is your...
Where's your wins, Winfield?
Where's your wins?
Huh?
Where is it?
I don't see wins in here.
We're auditing Winfield right now.
Let's do this.
Isa.
You know, Hollow doesn't let us do...
do sleep streams but maybe now the axles on twitch he can do a sleep stream that's true that's true oh why can't we do sleep stream what's so bad about it wait how do you not know about it because we have to do like high quality content or something that's what they said looks at my past like three years of content high quality content that's i'm getting punched we need to punch what the what what is You got fully your people.
What was I looking at?
Oh my god, I'm not getting fucking.
I'm telling you this game is ass, bro.
Bro, I should not have looked back.
I should not have looked back at you.
I should have just left.
It's for all those times that you said, I'm safe, I'll turn safe.
No, no, it would be all those times.
I said it one time.
Now that's a lie.
those times twice no one time three no no no one time one time today no no no no arguing it's gonna keep going no no oh yep go you're gonna keep lying then oh so that proves that you're lying lie stay alive I'm alive actually a zombie boy
honey anything this shit the salt ass loot loot oh will i find loot let's find out i don't know where like i don't know where the fucking loot box is spawned oh there it is never mind i found it a pistol i air defense launcher thermobaric grenade launcher i'm scared spooky scary skill Lettons send shivers down.
It's past Halloween.
Oh, so?
Why are you doing this to me?
So what is we feel looking at?
Pick up supplies.
Oh, what's this?
What did I pick up?
Are you okay?
Oh, yeah, we fine.
Nice.
Hello, guys.
I am.
here it's a sack whack i am here now i am here to party your sack to be whacked come get your sack whack through the drive-through oh i see the hole i see a hole flying where where okay where is the hole where is he living you said enemy is good wait there's loot box here let's go
i'm waiting for the supposed hoe that we are going to encounter but i Do you like?
Do you like?
I don't know where they are.
Where is this hill?
Well, the other team was in this building, so.
Yeah, but are they still here?
Did they leave?
Wait, they are still here.
They could...
They were...
Winfield.
Someone just...
Someone just parachuted above.
Up on the roof.
North.
Right over here.
Wait, Winfield has people near him too.
Ah.
Right outside.
Yeah.
Oh, they're striking.
Oh, wait, no, that's our strike.
That's our desirous.
Okay.
They're in front of us.
They're like, I hear these people.
We're sort of, like, outside of it, though.
I think he's right above me.
Axel, be careful.
They were right over there.
Careful.
I'm right above you right now.
Wasn't there, like, a ping here?
Yeah, I saw, like, shots.
here i heard people i mean they threw an artillery strikes at us oh right below me right below first floor first floor ground floor very first floor okay nice nice i broke my legs but that's fine wow wow he's smoking them whoa what the i even see this guy king bag you're fucking yay squad way get get right there get reproduced that damn game oh my god they still have more artillery strikes that's crazy i felt like they were through like 20 of those at us
okay what's the plan we are i mean we're in the middle we just want to i feel i don't know we want to chill here because i feel like everyone's gonna fuck here I can send an airstrike if you really want it.
This is my...
I found a perfect place to chill again.
I found my spot, guys.
You guys want...
Guys, let's all sit here.
Let's all crouch around here.
Guys, this is our spot.
Right here.
This one marks and...
Thank you.
Guys, come over here.
Where's here?
This is our spot.
We all...
Are we in the dead center?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're...
No, no, this is totally...
No, this is dead center.
I believe...
I believe our circle is good.
We all prone...
Right here!
Guys, we all prone right here and then and then there's no way no way people will know This is so lame.
Stop smoking.
No, no, no, no.
It's not lame.
It's do you want to do you want to stream for 12 hours?
That's not you.
Where's Altair?
Where is?
I'm journey.
Oh, I will leave halfway through.
Don't worry.
You guys know you people outside Okay, but we can chill here.
We can chill here.
You won't know why would they know that we're here?
there's no way but we're just gonna chill right here like there's no way who is gonna find out who is it i think i'm gonna hide no no they can't no you have to crouch you have to crouch or prone because because they'll okay here you are gonna be okay yeah okay i mean that makes sound makes sound i'm not gonna i'm not gonna okay here you go no one's gonna and then when walks in we go and then we'll win actually she's crazy right she's crazy i hate people like this hate it's gonna be fine it's gonna be all right so it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine and then i'm also gonna get pizza too and then we're gonna win and then i'm gonna get some goddamn pizza afterwards it wins my pizza here i'm gonna go run out and die all right here you go here you go guys this is it this is it look look I'm gonna watch this circle start closing in I'm gonna you know I'm gonna do work messages too while we're oh yes what is what are these pings yeah let me see my pings real quick as well two pings are here
two pings there okay oh a survey okay all right here we go all right see look at that guys see look at that the circle is in our favorite okay i'm bored well too bad we should have you should have clutched that game and won us that game out there now look what's going on now we have to do this that's on you why did you clutch right now that's right out there get into get into fucking cor if you're gonna cry cry and prone in this corner right now oh you fucking you go go in this court out here out here i swear to god people can see us from here go into if you're gonna cry go into a corner and cry like okay this is my corner to cry in go into a That's fucking right.
And I hope someone shoots your ass, too.
Hi, Winfield.
Alright, are you...
Guys, and then...
And then when there's...
Oh, whoa.
Oh, wait, there's people.
Quiet, quiet, quiet.
Don't know.
Thank you, thank you.
You feel just sprinting?
I think they saw.
No, no, no, no, they didn't.
They didn't, they didn't, they didn't.
come down he did not if anything we can have a firing squad we're gonna slap their sack we're gonna whack their sack this is it this is the moment where we start whacking
okay okay don't four dudes waiting in the corner dudes in the corner right here favorite i mean technically we could use the motion sensor right here put up the motion sensor it's loud are you sure people hear this
windfield can people hear this motion sensor like chat can people hear the motion sensor yeah well oh oh take it take it away yes they can take it away take it away okay okay okay needs uh eyesight of people too oh look at that look at that guys look at that we are we are still in the zone look at that see look at that my calculations were correct we survive another day in war what's this it's an airstrike i also have i also have a artillery strike too if anything the enemy is there no no no no no no no no no no no if we get pushed i am throwing my
just yelling john foreskin died okay okay it's okay we can do this
okay see the right i told you this is the perfect spot guys this is imagine if someone walks here and we all just fire squad them imagine that that would be imagine that how tilted how tilted that you're gonna imagine it has been happening to me for the past like exactly exactly and when we're gonna do that to them axel we're gonna do that same exact thing to them and then it will be beautiful and then don't worry guys we're top 19 don't and then they'll uninstall guys do it for the uninstall oh we're still doing for those who have uninstalled uh ahead of you okay we are still in this we're not in the center anymore but we're still in zone maybe it'll pull downwards you know maybe maybe it's gonna pull down guys truly it'll pull down right yeah yeah yeah I believe I I believe I could send on a drone again no no but no no no we don't need it we don't need it we don't need okay so they did I hope
they shoot you first I hope they shoot you first I don't see anybody near us.
Oh, no.
Oh, the zone's coming in.
The zone.
No, our beautiful spot.
I think we're fine.
I think we're fine for now if we decide to move.
We just move at the very end, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Oh, it's slowly shrinking.
Or we can go to ground the zero, like the house.
I don't think we'll make it.
I don't know.
We'll make it.
Do you see that tiny house over there in the middle?
Oh, people on ping, people on ping.
That's close by.
That is very close by.
They're going to walk in.
It's okay.
We'll wait for them to walk in.
I think we can wait, right?
Do we rotate or wait, guys?
Let's have a decision together.
Let's have a vote.
Well, I probably have 30 seconds until my next turn.
Because we could try and go too late.
They're still there.
They're still there?
Do you think we'll make it if we just book it to this house?
We are fucked, ladies and gentlemen.
That house?
You see that house?
You see that?
There's no way we can make it to the house.
You gotta believe, man.
You gotta...
Oh, their artillery strike.
I think this is the time we gotta move.
We gotta move.
They are artillery strike.
Okay.
All right, we gotta move to that house.
You saw the house I pinged?
Yeah.
Where's the exit?
You can just jump through the window here.
Just a little bit loud.
Oh my god, there's a car right in there.
There's a fucking car.
Fuck it.
We just run.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
If chicken Ron could do it, we can do it.
We can do it too.
Oh, it's the weird slanty.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here.
This is it.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
our new home you know we finally are able to afford this new house there's a mortgage though it's just a little slanted it's fine it's a bathroom it's a bathroom oh my god oh my god this is perfect taking a break oh did i just lock myself in here oh no okay wait wait this is perfect
It's not like, it's not like, okay, you guys have to crouch your prone so we don't get detected.
I can just imagine someone just walking past opening this door, seeing three of us just fully geared.
Wait, I hear your gunshots.
I wonder if I can shoot.
Wait, wait, wait.
okay okay no okay they have to the thing is they have to jump in to get in here so we can true that's true that's true i'm the word that all of us were in here okay okay oh my god how is this coming oh my god we have to go through it does it
oh someone failed the rest yeah they did okay top 10 top 10 as long as no stop winfield stop winfield we're gonna die winfield winfield no one would have known we were there no one would have known we were there winfield how could you do this to us winfield the betrayer okay we're not in zone guys we're not in zone how what do we do okay new house new what is going on here there's no more houses i don't think there's a house oh my god i was a winfield winfield which house do we go for i don't think there's i mean there's a house right here but like i don't i don't think it's in i don't think it's in i don't think it's in guys that's the thing and the one above that do we go into that house there is uh do you think we'll make it though do you think we'll make it i don't know we're on low grounds we're gonna have to walk up now.
Oh, there's a tank behind us, guys.
I think we should go.
We should go.
There's a tank right behind us.
Okay.
Oh, there's a tank.
Yeah.
Are we going?
We wait until the circle.
Yeah.
Go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go.
Don't do don't do no people Nice Let's just keep running Dad Keep going, keep going I'm stuck I'm stuck Oh my god Maybe just right here Right here I'm actually stuck I'm actually stuck I'm stuck now Okay I'm fine I'm fine Just keep going Keep going Who cares about me I care about you That your friends care about you People in the house Okay Yeah On the right side Not the left one,
the right one.
Okay, then we'll go.
This one, this one?
Okay.
Hug this wall maybe?
Okay, I see.
Just hug the wall.
We'll go slowly creep in.
I have an artillery strike.
We could destroy the house.
I have artillery too.
I'm going to use it.
You're going to use it?
Okay, I'll use it after.
I got shot.
Okay, this is my last.
Okay.
This is my last resort.
People in front of us close by.
Okay.
I'll use it after you.
I downed over here.
Nice, nice, nice.
Target marked.
Fireball.
He's in the smoke field.
Oh, I got another one.
Here we go.
Another artillery.
Okay, they artillery us.
They artillery us.
We gotta go.
On us.
We shot.
My right.
To my right.
Oh, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's try to get over to Winfield and Axel.
I'm heading over.
Nice.
I smoked us.
Thank you.
I can't jump.
I don't have armor anymore.
Me too.
Oh my god, we're prone here!
Oh my god, guys!
There's two armors right there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just, just, just.
We're in a good place.
We're in a good place, actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in such a good place.
I was smoking.
I got a, like, uh, what do you call it?
Like, I can make terrain if I need to.
You have the little ramp thing.
Oh my god.
There's people in farm.
Yeah, there's people also.
There's a drone in front of us.
Sneaking up, sneaking up, right side.
Sneaking up, sneaking up.
Okay.
I don't see him.
We gotta go though.
He's right over the hill.
Why below me?
Nice.
Last squad is over here, over here.
One ping.
No, there's three squads.
There's three squads.
There's still three.
There's three squads, there's three squads, guys.
People up there?
They're up there.
I'm on the hill.
Okay, okay.
my god okay take cover take cover yeah rotate from the right this guy right here there's the guy where i painted on all right okay i'm gonna try clear right side you see i'm coming with you give me a shot i think i think i think this side is pretty safe this hill is pretty good i can't remember and i still have airstrike so yeah yeah i don't have mine anymore i'll try to play safe okay three squads three squads left Watch out for people just camping.
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking behind us.
I'm looking behind us to see if there's any rats behind us.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Are there people there?
No, guy?
Okay, I see them.
Okay.
I think they're over there on that side.
Hit for one, one, one, 100.
Nice.
Okay.
Two squads.
Two squads left.
You can airstrike that side maybe.
I think you can airstrike that side.
Okay.
down here that down here okay but you got someone a straight i'm
looking behind us to see if there's no any rats nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice oh my god
I just can't kill them.
Oh, I knocked one, too.
No!
Oh, we should have airstrike the right side.
Oh, my God.
See, my strapped worked, guys.
My strapped was the key.
My strapped.
Oh, my, we should have airstrike the right side.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we got sandwich hard.
They did.
Oh, we have to watch them win, too.
Jesus.
How about we just take a small short break go to the restroom get some drinks I mean we can just or we can just continue No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, bro, okay, we got the strat though We got the strat, yeah, yeah, we have the strat now like we had such good rotations guys That's what we mean.
We are rotating.
Didn't you feel a little bit of the excitement of V-Scycure back then?
You know?
Yeah.
Did you not feel the rotations?
Like, oh my God, we were rotating left and right.
I don't know about that one.
I don't know.
No, no.
We were rotating left and right, bro.
We got this.
Oh, boss.
Like, we got this.
Like, our bathroom strat or our base, we should go to that same corner again.
We should.
you're laughing while drinking water yeah i can hear that it's kind of horrible this game she's driving guys all i'm saying is that we almost made it we almost got it there we're so just yeah to be honest that was look at that we were fracking out and everything it's just that unfortunately we got sandwiched there like we got sandwiched really hard i think like when we airstrike the we should restrict right side and then ran at them in the right side oh yeah yeah we should do that but we when we first saw them we saw them on the left after we airstrike them they moved to the right side was that the same team though i think it was it was because the one knock was trying to move to the right as well oh because i was like i thought that was the I thought that was a new team because like we were third.
So I thought the other team was to our left and then out the team.
I think the last guy was like a rat somewhere.
God damn it was us against another rat.
Oh yeah.
It's okay.
Two people behind us got almost killed us.
What the heck?
How did they get behind us?
There were two behind us?
Yeah they flanked her on the left side I think.
Oh I didn't realize that.
I didn't realize that.
I just turned around and there was this guy just running from the I'm like, what?
Whoa, you got cows, crazy.
Wait, is my pizza here?
Pizza.
Pizza time.
Margarita pizza time.
Pizza, pizza time.
Pizza time.
My favorite something.
All right.
D.
All right, here we go.
Pizza time.
I'm so excited.
excited for my pizza pizza we still didn't beat our second place yeah we still didn't beat it the only way to beat it is to get first place okay we're so okay okay okay we have the strat now though we have the strat just rat we are rats we are rats we have to rat to win all right we do the same thing you know what what do we land we should go back to the defense the defense matrix area and then and then we find the corner we find that corner yeah yeah the corner i'm gonna run in try and find that corner that's my i don't remember where it was no guns no abilities run to the corner i don't remember where that corner is but that was a good ass corner corner right there corner right there on red pen okay okay that's all i need to know i'm ready I will take the leftover food.
I don't care.
I broke my legs.
It's okay.
Got a gun at least.
Are you kidding me?
Giving me two shotguns.
Did someone just...
Parachute?
Well, we're gonna find out soon.
Yee-haw.
I found the corner.
You found the corner?
Okay, I know where I'll tear it.
Wait, do you have a gun, though?
I've got two guns.
All you got is fucking kidding me.
What a sick game, bro.
Oh, no, absolutely.
Yeah, I'm not along the way.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He was also looking at me.
Oh,
it's OK.
It's OK.
I believe.
Oh, my God.
It's OK.
I believe.
I can't even lose with this ping.
You're right.
I believe.
Whoa, out there.
Whoa.
Oh, that wasn't a headshot.
shot no way oh okay oh it's okay no way the corner is now the corner calls to us i got house squatted so hard for that guy was that guy rad outratted me it's crazy wait where are we no one can outrat doki where are we now oh my god there's there's people over there nothing yeah i am going having the time of my life grab a gun i never felt this way before oh yeah great game give me a shotgun i got the same gun three times in a row fucking i'm just running out of here on my building on my building that one okay okay i'm coming over
what the did he go bottom bottom bottom Across the street behind us, east.
Oh, yeah, they artillery strike.
They actually strike.
Nice.
Bro, give me a fucking gun, bro.
Jesus.
I've got a shotgun with these people's names on it.
What?
Oh my god, maybe there's a gun here.
Maybe they put a gun in the security.
Loki, armory crate.
Okay.
Oh, you're far.
No, I'm far.
I'm far far.
I'm hoping that, you know, they'll happen to drop one tiny gun.
You'll leave a tiny gun for me.
Oh, no, no gun.
It's okay.
Just.
Oh, they did.
They left a gun.
Thank God.
I got a gun, guys.
Oh, oh, they read the play.
They read the play.
Okay.
I got a crossing, bro.
I'm dead.
Hello.
Wait, where?
Are you fucking prone, please?
Holy shit.
Wait, they're fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Okay, let's get him.
Oh, I see him.
He's over there.
I do also have a shotgun.
Jesus.
One down.
Nice.
Oh, hey, Winfield.
It's just so miserable to control.
Oh, he's out!
Oh, no.
Last two, last two.
I'm dead.
You got this?
Whoa.
Where did he go?
Oh shit!
That's where he went.
Oh, nice spot, nice spot.
Nice, good.
Yeah.
I think you're clipping through, but...
Whoa, no!
Was I clipping through?
I think your arm is clipping through.
No!
All right, we got to kick Doki now.
It's her turn.
I was the one that died first, though.
I wasn't the one that died first.
You guys can't blame that on me.
Guys, oh my god.
There was still another squad there.
There was still...
Jesus, why were they all here?
Crazy, wow.
It's so painful when you try to loot and it takes forever, dude.
Holy shit.
where like my character just beating the shit out back again.
No.
First we'll smack it, then we'll jerk it.
It's actually crazy.
Wait, what?
Axel's gonna do that.
Wait, do you like take turns?
Like, like Axel, who's the, who's the swacking, who's the other one?
I'm the whacker, he's the.
Yeah.
Oh, Axel, are you the other guy?
What the fuck are you guys talking about, yo?
That's a yes.
Okay, Winfield was like...
The Winfield's like, he give him a sniper and we win this.
Okay.
Alright, we give him a sniper and we win this.
If Winfield doesn't win here, I'm gonna assume that he's jorking it.
Yeah.
Also, what else did he say?
He said something else.
Oh, wait.
The...
Dude, you gotta blank someplace else, not this game.
What does that mean?
What is he trying to say?
I don't even understand what he's trying to say.
They couldn't, like, put some kind of realism in this by saying, survive the collapsing wall of wildfire.
It's just a collapsing wall of death.
All right.
Come on, realism.
Where's my wildfires?
Where's my bushfires?
What's your bushfires?
There's so many bushfires here.
are you talking about well axel didn't show me any uh what are you guys talking about bushfires
bushfires bushfires axel now that now that you're in japan i can never go to australia now whoa oh well that was my one you saved yourself you saved yourself to garner somewhere no nothing much really bro there's got to be so much to do in australia like like like kangaroo boxing emu boxing australia right now is just like the world but like in australia it's just a bunch of different people from different countries living there and it's just very diversified right now so you get australia you get to enjoy a lot of different colleges from different places yeah you don't really get to enjoy australia australia itself honestly i feel like it's very like i don't know unless you go to like somewhere really specific Like what?
Like where?
See, that's a good question.
I don't even know.
Maybe Gold Coast?
Gold Coast seems pretty good.
Gold Coast?
Yeah, Gold Coast is alright.
It's not bad.
Alright, where do we go?
Are we trying again?
Alright, oh wait, I think that's the century this time.
I think it's the century this time, guys.
It'll work, guys.
Trust me, it'll work.
I believe...
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna fucking...
In my head.
Other people on the left side.
Alright, I'm going to the right.
I'm gonna try and find a gun.
One little gun.
That's all I asked for.
One gun, please.
One gun, baby, please.
Yay!
Nice.
I got a gun.
Oh, he's dead, dead.
Yeah, you got D-Willy.
And Machoke that hoe.
Do I hear someone?
You do?
I use UAV.
I don't hear anybody.
Oh, there is someone above us.
Are you kidding me?
My gun did.
They're above there.
Yep.
I see them.
They're on the second floor.
Or the third floor.
They're right here in that room.
Great.
One right there.
I'm going up.
On ping.
Gun up as well.
I think they ran across.
They ran across.
They shot through you.
They shot through you to kill me.
I just can't win.
Like, it's just impossible.
Thank you.
I might need help.
I might need cover.
Maybe I should like...
Covering, covering, covering.
Okay.
you're gonna redeploy to us i'm pretty sure oh i was behind the ball oh my goodness oh my god oh he killed you you're my god no i was actually behind the ball you should save me okay what's your oh there's another guy there's another guy right in here is it that no okay that's karma that's actual karma for what i did you take his where's this last person
you guys are coming back in right yeah yeah we're gonna deploy i think since we they might reapply back in here though let them come back oh no jack's gonna get his gun back i'll meet you guys in the corner all right you're good beautiful
all right right here some better loot though hello i'm coming in through the roof hello hello i'm gonna grab my gun back all right and i'm ready for the corner guys oh what the is no yeah i'm done i'm out of nowhere axel no axel will bring you back buddy i'm gonna go straight for the real player I'm gonna bring you back right no no no I'm going over to the redeploy right now you ain't quitting you ain't quitting on me buddy oh thank you thank you Winfield how do I get out of here though first off let me find out okay I'm going to the redeploy right now I'm heading over right above me man all this get the new PC just to get fucking shit ping no solo just okay let's hope that they don't come over this is a little risky you think they know kind of fracking there though you think they know no way they know no way you think they know though they know they know they know definitely no no we're fine but you don't oh you have to do their second chance i feel like they should just use that you
know oh my god they actually came over are you fucking kidding me no they act okay you guys gotta redeploy though to do another redeploy on my way you guys split up you guys went to three different redeploys one of us has to make it one of us will bring you back
It may not be me because I'm looting, but...
It's fine.
Someone...
Right.
It is...
Wait, who...
Okay.
I will fly over to...
What do I fly over to?
I'm going back in.
I'm going back to a defense nexus.
Nice kill.
Fuck you, talk sucker.
That's fucking right.
Oh, they got the res.
Ah, shit.
Where's the next closest res?
I'm going to go to the other redeploy.
I'm going to the other redeploy right now.
Oh, everything's been drained.
I'm at the next redeploy.
Okay, I'll meet up with you then.
You don't know.
They don't know.
I'm at the next one.
Redeploy them.
They don't know.
Remember that little, the little sneaky little tunnel you were in earlier?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No more Axel.
I got you.
Yeah, Axel.
Oh, yeah.
I got you, Axel.
We coming back, bro.
You don't know.
They didn't see me perish.
guys i have to look both ways but it's okay good glad you have good safety okay we're not in the center so that's what i'm worried about i mean we could go to the trailers maybe people next me i gotta be quiet coming down all right i'm gonna find us the next spot i think i think this i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna go to that spot that's the spot i think I think that's I think that is the I think that's the spot I think that's our next rat spot I believe I'm heading over it right now on two because we're not in the center three oh no there's a team right there read the point could do a mission oh we could uh I'm down to do a mission yeah let's do it
let's do wreckage what's wreckage let's fart
what i'm getting targeted fuck oh shit where i think i'm like a mission oh you got a mission oh they took a mission to find you yeah and my guy is uh he doesn't do cardio so i'm heading over oh it's because we're defending the bomb and they're trying to oh okay i'm going to the bomb oh my god we're literally playing cs right now enjoy the machine i'll be in the corner okay i'm heading over what the fuck i can't okay
oh my god it's just like rainbow 16 Don't worry, I got this corner.
There we go.
I got this, guys.
Do we die?
We get hit by that?
I think so.
No, we're five.
Nice!
We got an airdrop, too.
Wait, there is a team coming in.
Is that the red thing?
Airdrop rewards coming in.
Alright.
Let's go grab that outside.
Let's go.
Alright.
What?
Excellent.
It's okay.
I would like it.
There's a car over there.
I like this gun, please.
I don't know if it's good.
We can go get a custom weapon over there if you want to.
Ooh.
We want to move in a zone anyways.
I feel like every time we go for those random ones that just drop, there's always like three people looking at it.
Yeah.
You could do another mission and then get a free one.
I got, I heard shots next to me.
Okay.
I need to look for Alma.
I need to wait.
There's a car right behind us too.
Oh, my legs.
Oh, I picked the worst gun.
Oh, I didn't know what gun to pick.
I thought I didn't know.
That's me shooting my gun.
So I was like, I was like, is it really the worst gun?
Don't say that, guys.
it's the best gun it's in it's in her hands it's a safe oh what's that i think i just got real gunned oh people behind us behind us ping ping ping ping shooting from up the hill fuck you guys ping i don't know oh no i got tanked oh you got tanked okay we got oh god okay i'm going i'm leaving i'm leaving oh i'm gonna shot it now all right i'm gonna i'm running i'm running to the closest redeploy i see it i see it it's to my left i'm heading there right now thank you all i'm saying oh you're oh you're fine okay never mind somehow i'll grab this
yeah armored tank heading your way no no crap oh my god there's nothing here i heard something behind me where do we go can you cover me i'm running towards you guys that way's where the tank is oh that way okay Okay, I'll go left then.
I'm trying to look for like a RPG or something that can destroy a tank, but...
I don't think that's possible, guys.
There's nothing...
Wait, there's a custom weapon here.
Yeah, but I don't think we can get it.
I think the tank is going to look from above.
No, no, no, no.
It's fine.
I'm literally at it right now.
Alright, guys, which one's better?
Guys, tell me what weapon to get, and then I'll get it right now.
Guys, guys, come on.
Tell me which one.
Right now, chat.
At chat.
I can't stand still.
I'm still getting sniped at.
Which one's the SMG?
I can't tell.
MG?
I'm still MG.
Which one is it?
M433?
The one on the very left, I think.
Which one?
I need some shields.
One, two, three, four!
SGX?
I declare it on more!
Okay, SGX there.
Yeah, give me shield.
He'll take this.
Thank you, Axel.
See, that's an investment right there.
all right we're good see you guys i didn't panic at all all right i think we should go to here people are here south south here we got a ride over here this world's a scary place i'm heading straight to this here right here okay i'm heading here that looks like the center this is our next home I missed my corner.
It's her next home.
I missed her bathroom.
Oh, the bathroom is so lit until it was lit.
Yeah, so someone decided to break our only cover area.
Actually, I feel like maybe...
Can't believe you do that, Axel.
Come on.
Yeah, that's fucked, bro.
That's Ashley fucked.
Yeah, my shit.
There's someone on the roof?
Yeah.
Okay, there's someone on the roof.
Then I feel like maybe we should just stay in this house.
then rotate slowly in we're gonna stay here okay and then just like follow the zone although this is our new home now okay but what if you think people know I'm here you think you think this guys is this is this is this can you see me from here your legs clipping out yeah on kind of like this Oh,
that's perfect.
Yeah, yeah.
That's perfect.
No one will know.
No one will know that I'm in here.
Well, look at the steam.
It's a hot tub.
Yeah, it's a hot tub.
Ooh, it's a steamy.
Yeah, it's your hot tub stream.
Oh, I actually closed the door.
Okay.
We're not in the zone.
Okay, someone, someone fucking shot the window so they know we're here.
Oh, there's a team in that house anyway.
Boy.
Oh, there's someone resting right behind us.
You guys want to just follow the zone?
Oh, they're going to kill them.
We could.
Oh, the tank is there.
Okay, we got to be quiet.
We got to be very quiet.
There's a tank.
No tank.
We got to wait until the tank, like, leave us.
I'm going to, I'm just going to wait until the tank, like, passes us.
I don't trust it.
Do, do, do, do, do.
I am a snail.
We are calm people.
Oh, oh, someone.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Wait, someone sent an artillery strike on the tank.
Someone sent two artillery.
Whoa!
Oh my goodness.
Goodbye, tank.
I guess.
We go left or right.
They just want to go left or right.
I know there's people to our right.
What?
There's people on our left.
Like, there's like three people on our left.
Oh, 175?
I think we go right.
We go from the right.
Right, OK.
We can't really go right now.
Yes.
There's people on our left.
There's people shooting all the way.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, what happened?
I didn't smoke.
I smoked.
Go over here.
I smoked it.
Oh, no.
Squats dead.
Sorry, Axel.
Okay.
I just can't win in a fight.
It's just...
All right, we...
Can we redeploy?
Do we have a closer deploy to...
It's like over here, but I don't know.
Okay, we have to figure out right or left, though.
Um...
I would...
Because there is a team right in that house.
There's a team on the right side.
I saw them running from those areas.
So maybe it's them.
So I don't want to go right side.
I'm gonna follow Winfield.
He ran already I Need more shields There is a card who are left Just a ripe for the taking.
Oh, wait, wait, Winfield smart wouldn't feel smart.
Just Are we roof gang?
Yeah, we're roof gang.
Roof gang on the day as moot site.
That's what they call me
Oh, how do you get up there?
Behind us is safe.
We're good.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where, where, where, where?
Where, where?
Right here, right here.
Oh, nice position.
Oh shit, nice out there.
Oh, above us, above us, above us.
Do a little bit right above us.
Okay.
I'm getting inside.
Squad white.
We got squad white.
Yeah.
Did they have any shields?
Very nice.
oh uh i don't oh there's that's extra shields yeah yeah we gotta go in yeah oh there's me thank you um someone's all the way out here on one ping there's three people north at the house on north on the house okay so we and there's one person west on thing we gotta go i guess we can go is there anyone here on three I saw one person over there.
All right, I guess we slowly rotate.
Our life.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Look at the end zone.
End zone is like the open field.
Okay.
Let's try to get some trees for cover then.
I think all we could do is just...
We just have to rotate last, I guess.
Yep.
Five squads left.
Five squads.
squads four squads they killed two rats nice they killed three more squads three more squads i don't have any artillery by the way so two more squads two more squads hi battle he's gonna use the artillery strike do we have artillery i don't think any of us have artillery yeah we gotta go so soon remember there's still people above us so really i wasn't Swap white.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
It should be fine.
Unless there's another person right behind us.
Oh, the fires.
Oh!
Artillery!
How did they know?
That's a...
Oh, yeah.
I took a big hit.
I don't know how they knew we were there, but...
Oh, that's people over there as well.
They just crashed on it.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I don't know if I'm gonna get...
I think I feel like I'm gonna get strike there.
Good luck.
I know.
I don't know if I...
Windfield's playing it very safely.
I also have smokes.
That was so unlucky.
One far north, far northwest.
That's a single, I think.
Okay.
There's a full squad to our...
There's actually a full squad to our left.
You won't be safe there for long.
Yep, I could feel it Super far northwest though
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait There's still three teams three teams
Nice, oh my god, I'm in a bush Field's playing it's we're playing it so safe wait wait wait wait wait Oh, it's in front of me.
He's in front of me.
He's literally right in front of me Oh, wait, they downed each other.
There's two down.
Nice!
Cracked.
Cracked west.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
I got... I got kicked out of the game.
No!
Oh, no!
What the fuck is...
Bro, what the fuck is this game, man?
This game is absolute shit.
Oh, shit, what?
Where did I get hit?
I think that's on.
No, no, no, that was...
No, oh, he was proning, too!
No!
What's the strat there?
No, he got the rock.
We couldn't do anything because they were right there.
Oh, my God.
It was so close.
There's literally two teams just...
They had so much shields!
I was nothing I think we just had to we just had to like I'm in the lobby I'm in the lobby yeah yeah yeah I had no place at it bro we like look for us instead of one second yeah yeah you're back that was a three man I think it's queue up while we're waiting oh I guess not.
Bro, they're still fighting?
They're still fucking fighting.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Why am I flashlight on?
How do you turn off flashlight?
Oh, it's T?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Guys, do you guys know if you turn off flashlight, if you turn off flashlight, it's T.
I'm gonna grab my pizza.
I'll be right back, guys.
I got it for?
Axel, entertain our chats.
I'm just in fire range right now.
How are you guys all doing ladies and gentlemen?
This game is ass.
It's not like apex.
You can't just fight them even with ping.
You are, you are fucked.
You are just absolutely fucked if you have shit ping.
Oh, what's a good fucking...
So what's this?
carbine
what's what's a better gun
assault this firing range okay
oh i actually like this gun more the m4 is the best gun at the end of the day
hey oh strawberry think of the five gifts yo thank you very much
but if I were to if I were to use this gun in hyping I don't think it would do much to be honest how do I hello I'm back thank you for waiting I got myself some nice iced tea peach iced tea peach I love peach tea uh it's
strange i don't like i don't like eating peaches but because i think i'm slightly allergic peaches i love the flavor of it peach rings peach tea peach peaches
yeah see if i can get a fourth how do we
what are you up to I'm just in the firing range
why is it when I look this way and then when I what the fuck is what the fuck is this game is broken bro I look away I look away when I'm not looking bro they're playing fucking squid games with me these fucking
oh my this is actually the squid crazy they are actually squid gaming fucking piece of these guys can i change my look wonder getting pranked out here gosh i look so cool axel how's your house how's the time in japan with the boys right now oh it's okay yeah i met them like once or twice it's chilling yeah nice how much money have you guys spent going out not much actually i remember spending so much money in japan yeah i try to save as much as i can and now you guys don't have that free housing right now right it's just no no um well i got my own place now i mean we only had that yeah we only had that place um when we went for a 3d so than that um yeah it's pretty expensive if you try to get it yourself other than occasions i remember last time i came i decided to go to the same place but i had to um paint myself it's pretty fucking expensive hello hey i got my pizza and i forgot to bring my sriracha so no sriracha no you're talking about being italian for winners no that's fucking
array no wonder why i don't like sriracha sriracha's for winners we're gonna be literally talking about you wanting italian pizza okay so what's the difference between like italian pizza and regular pizza is it like the way they make it do they make it in stone ovens do they do they flop it a little bit extra what do they do um it's this press this dinner oh like new york style pizza yeah yeah yeah italian pizza doesn't default to tomato sauce oh they use like mayonnaise
mayonnaise what sorry i was freaking typing a word message what the fuck i had to like do a double take on that huh well they said that italian pizza doesn't default to tomato sauce so like it's got mayonnaise it's got to be like ketchup sauce mayonnaise berry jam what peanut butter pizza that's good peanut butter pizza I hate peanut butter I'm sorry there's just something about the nuttyness and that's too much I got stuff crushed for for my pizza hut I haven't had that in so long oh this stuff Chris is so good there
if you had to have one only one ingredient on on the top of the pizza what would you have only one only one for me unironically italian sausage really for me it's pepperoni pepperoni like the good ones are the ones that like shrivel up too much and are like plastic i mean you just said the good ones are the one that's like I don't talk to girls very often I mean girls are the ones that's fucking bad I don't know is my stream so dog what is what a hook is my screen of black um we're in game yeah I think it's fog oh no maybe like all tab and tab acting in no it's not that i think it's just i think this game's broken oh i'm in the void maybe it'll fix once you get out of skydiving yeah i don't think so we're in yeah no i don't see anything okay maybe i'll fix it up when you die nope uh but can you like rejoin the vpcs but is there that feature you guys chat chat chat chat if you like all at four can you rejoin us if you can't see chat his screen's black someone said he has to leave i want
to know if you can rejoin i don't think so not i can't rejoin this is this game man this fucking game apparently it's a bug or some shit i like how like um i like how i think my thing's completely dead black my thing every single menu i like how out of everyone that it had to happen to it had to happen to axa all right yeah always axa had to happen to him truly life now it's a sign they're telling me hey don't play this game anymore no no no no no no no it's a sign that you that we're gonna win this nah it's a sign for me to stop playing No,
no, it's a sign that we're going to win this, guys.
I believe.
Look, they haven't...
I don't know about that.
I believe.
If you stop believing, then we're going to be streaming for eight more hours.
Why?
There's so many flies just...
What happened?
What?
Okay, I don't know what the fuck hit me there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
What happened to me?
I don't even know what happened.
Guys, Duki died.
No, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
Duki's alive.
Like, I don't even know what was going on.
Oh!
Uh, north, north, north, north.
someone just does it uh parachute it i got him lavender that's right i'm coming over lavender that's oh i'm down but safe down but safe oh he's one he's actually one in there no i'm so sad i'm so sad uh-oh my race the axel's gone and my pizza om nom nom nom nom nom nom i believe my my
Oh, I'm going.
Alright.
I got a gun now.
Someone was here.
This is all looted.
Wait.
What?
How do you do that?
What the fuck?
I'm heading over.
Do I swim over?
Oh, my God.
You can swim in this game?
I'm heading over, guys.
No way.
I'm gonna be a hero.
That was a dry bite.
Wow.
I'm coming over.
Load out.
Okay, I'm here.
Guys, I'm here.
Alright, I go...
Save me.
I go pick up Altair.
Merci beaucoup.
don't worry Altair we could do this we might be at the five-hour mark but we can do this we just need one good one you know we can fail as many times as we want yeah just gotta win one time yeah yeah yeah we got we got the win we got it we got it we got it I believe I believe we might need to sacrifice a couple all along the way and that may or may not be Winfield I'm gonna eat my pizza
Guess who's back?
I'm a hero.
Back again.
Guess who's back?
It's a me.
Oh no.
Oh my.
Where's Winfield?
Oh, Winfield's hiding there.
He's done.
He's like, I did not.
Oh, my.
He's like, I did not sign up for this, for this long of a session.
I think he thought we would have won a game like three hours ago.
Sorry, Winfield.
We're trying, I swear.
I'm hanging over.
I'm trying, too.
Or am I not trying?
Hmm.
Winfield, we need you to use more than 10% of your power.
Winfield, I need you to kill half the lobby.
Winfield, I need you to get me a pizza.
All right, he has an enemy near him.
I'm going to be on the house next to him.
Helicopter, helicopter, helicopter.
After he didn't see me.
The fuck?
Someone fell from it.
Okay.
I'm going to go to one of the houses.
I'm going to the house that's next to him.
Wait, this is the parking lot area.
we need to do something for wind field if he wins no we don't huh playing with us is the gift don't you have a you know don't you want good morals you know uh to reward those who did well no
no don't you want to enrich someone else's life by sharing your i'd rather enrich my own life can't aren't you capable of love
Oh shit, that's an artillery strike.
I'm over at the big building.
Am I like, is there a way for me to be safer?
There's no way this would hit me, right?
Ooh.
SMGG.
Custom.
All right, I'm heading over to your building.
Knock, knock.
Blue LMG.
Hello.
I'm going to go under.
Oh, wait.
Is there?
Oh, I can't.
I wanted to go in the park.
Oh, oh, no.
No.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
Never mind.
Missile shooter.
Let's get out of here.
what don't wait I have an idea you see that you see that watch this
wait wait watch this enemy landing near us enemy landing near us I think they know were you Mike Irman shot you said enemy near us and it freaked me out okay but did you You think they know?
My legs!
You took my legs!
Okay!
Go out, go out right here!
Go out right here!
Do you think it's noticeable?
Can they see me?
I can see your backpack.
About now?
No.
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
How about now?
No.
Okay, there you go.
Perfect.
You go on the other side.
You do the same thing, but on the other side.
Okay.
There you go.
That's perfect.
Yeah!
There's no way, there's no way, there's no way to know.
Oh, we're not in zone.
You want an LMG, by the way?
No, I'm good.
Aren't you good at the LMG?
I don't know what gun I'm good.
I don't know.
I've still have yet.
We've been playing for five hours, and I've still yet to know which gun is good.
Oh, yeah, I can guess.
Oh, I don't see anybody.
I don't think we're in zone, guys.
I have a feeling that we should maybe go...
Someone super far over here.
Maybe we should go over here to one of those houses.
Winfield!
Go to one of those houses for us, and we'll meet you there.
On two?
Uh, there's people flying into two, so there's probably a fight going on there.
Oh, okay.
Then we'll go.
Uh, there's people on point three.
What about here?
Two.
Uh, could make it over there.
Yeah, we can make it.
Winfield, we're gonna go.
Let's go.
We're going to be on our mission.
There's a car.
We take that car.
We take that car and then like go to...
I'll win this.
Don't worry.
I miss Axel.
Can I win it?
Marty.
We're going to do this.
We're going to do this for you, Axel.
I'm going to take the car.
I'll take it.
Trust me on this.
What if we get two cars?
Okay, let's get two cars.
One of us is going to die.
Got a new mission for you.
Caltar hasn't seen me drift like this before.
Alright, I'm going in.
I'm going to scout for that house.
Sorry.
Beep.
Okay.
Wait, this is my favorite place.
Totally incantikuous, Humvee.
Wait, I know this place.
Oh.
You're right above me right now.
Um...
This is it.
Ah, I just made it on one piece.
You guys better win this one.
I believe in you guys.
There is a team on my... There is a team in my house.
There is a team in my house, Altair.
There is...
I'm taking this house.
Ooh.
It's a gas station.
I think I found the perfect place for myself.
It's okay, Axel.
We're doing this for you, Axel.
Don't worry.
It's going to be so cool.
Loki, I can't go like five minutes without Axel or else I'll start breaking down.
There is a team right above us.
There is a team.
Shhh.
There is a team right above us.
So shh.
Really?
I'll go look.
And I'm taking a look.
that ha i'll tear i swear to fucking god i'm gonna go take a look hey i don't believe you i don't believe you i'm gonna go take a look god i'm stuck in a door and kobe brian meditates before their games nobody on the roof roof is clear This is it.
This is it.
We're fine.
Hey, can you let me in?
I'm at the door.
Can you let me in?
It's fine.
We're in.
We are so... Oh my... What if we're just in the middle of this ocean?
What if... Do you think they'll know?
I'm gonna do it.
I think there's... Everybody's north.
There's a lot of people north.
But like... What will happen if we're just in that middle of that ocean?
Like, like, will people look at the water?
Like, will people know?
Oh, there is a tank.
Will people know?
You see me?
We could try.
There's a boat.
We can get the boat.
I don't think we can get that boat.
I think it'd be more obvious like we used the boat.
We have to leave though.
We have to leave.
There's a tank out there.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Okay, I think the, okay.
Oh, that's cute.
okay we gotta leave though we gotta leave guys we gotta leave where do we go where do we go professing love um let's let's go by the water let's do it let's do the water i feel like we get sniped though we're in the water i feel like one person should be in the middle of the water just to test ethereal and then and then see if we get sniped i'll do it i'll do it begin with w i'll do it don't worry no no windfield windfield is fracking we just won't tear for the team.
We thank you.
I wonder, like, will they know if I start swimming in the water?
We'll cheer you on from here, okay?
You got this.
Is it noticeable?
When I'm in the water?
Is this dude right close to us?
Hold on.
But is it noticeable?
I can't see you from this angle.
Is it noticeable when I'm swimming in the water?
I don't see you.
Okay.
Wait.
This trap might be it.
Okay.
Oh, I could kill someone.
I think they died.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, no!
No!
I am fucking gaming!
Where was I shot from?
Wait, where the fuck was I shot from?
Tank, tank, tank, tank.
No!
We could have seen that coming.
Who could have seen that?
Okay, guys.
So, apparently...
Apparently, there was a team at the bridge looking down at the water.
Oh, there was a team underneath that bridge when I sweat.
Because I was thinking, oh, I'll swim near the bridge area instead of the middle of the ocean.
That was the thing I fucked up on.
I should have just stayed in the middle.
Okay, I'll tear.
Yes.
You test out my secondary.
Okay.
The water?
No, no, don't do it.
I think we need you and one field alive.
Woo!
Yeah.
But this wind would be nothing without Axel.
Even if we win.
No, no, no.
Even if we win, he's, we'll be free.
He's fine.
No, we shouldn't do that for a reason.
There's a creep.
Oh, oh, they see Winfield.
Oh, wow, they're sniping us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys gotta go to...
You gotta follow Winfield.
You gotta follow him.
Following Winfield.
He's got...
He's figuring shit out.
He's cooking right now.
He's cooking.
There is, there are rats under that bridge.
There are rats under that bridge.
I repeat, that is where I died.
Whoa.
I think I see them.
That's how they got me.
Thanks.
They got me through that.
Can we climb the bridge?
No.
Oh, wait, they fucking flew away?
They just, hey, that's my body.
Rookie!
Here's my body right there.
She's dead.
Oh, they're fighting above.
Oh, that's a tank.
That's a tank.
Just sneak behind the tank.
Don't make any noise.
Be very quiet.
Wait.
Check the water.
Are there still rats in that water?
Maybe there's rats in that water.
This feels very dangerous.
Nope.
guys got this I believe in you as I take a nap there is it bridge is safe six squads left is that house safe though geez that's a lot of people there's a guy to oh my god if I get inside this car oh don't do it there's someone in that house i think oh
my god he's crazy oh my god he's fucking crazy oh my god he blew up the tank he blew it up i think we hold this maybe oh my god he's goddamn crazy he blew up the tank just like that just like that what a goat he's an engineer oh my god he's so smart Hide in that bathroom.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Hide in that bathroom.
I'll tear.
This is it.
Hide in that bathroom You don't need to.
You don't need to fucking... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just stay there.
You two just stay there.
Close the door if you can.
Can you close the door?
Oh, yeah.
Close the door.
Okay, just stay there.
Yeah, yeah, keep doing it.
And then it's like a firing squad.
It's literally a fire squad.
And then you walk through.
Yeah, that's the plan.
That's the plan.
That is it.
This is it.
We got the strap.
We got the fucking strap.
Five squads left.
Oh my god.
Technically four squads left because you're- There's a chance.
Technically four squads left because you're part of the- Man, wouldn't it be funny if I did not fucking swim in the middle of that ocean?
Man.
If only I didn't swim in the middle of that ocean.
Oh, this- this hurts my soul.
This is such a cowardly way to fight.
Ooh, bros, across the hallway.
2 bros Looking at each other cuss It's nothing else to do 2 bros Sitting in the hot tub 5p in the park It's for 5p in the park Fuck I love that 2 bros sitting in the hot tub 5p in the park It's for not gay
Huh?
We're not into zen No, no it's fine It's fine The zone closes really slow I believe.
There's no way people throw grenades to check.
No, they wouldn't.
There's no way.
Nobody ever throws grenades in this game.
Nope.
Oh.
I'm still here.
I'm safe.
No.
There's someone I went for.
There's someone on Winfield.
Okay, I got to heal.
I got to heal.
No, no, no, no, no.
Just chill a bit.
Just chill.
It's C-Swiss, too.
You got this.
They're really on Winfield right now.
No!
Winfield!
No, no.
I'll tear.
Nice.
I think you gotta leave him.
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
I will never leave Winfield.
Never leave him.
I will never leave you.
Oh, my God.
Two bros.
sitting in the hot tub it was very hot i see them they're across okay just chill just chill oh last it's the it's the last team it's literally the last team left left no
again again again i thought i saw someone in front of me.
Okay, I would say that aim was very unfortunate to watch too.
I'm glad you didn't have to watch it out here.
I am glad you didn't have to watch it.
I don't...
What happened, Winfield?
It was bad.
What, Winfield, you were clutching it, and what happened?
What the fuck happened?
Okay, I invite Axel back.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, the next one might be my last one.
I'm so tired no no this is it this axle we clearly got second place there was one guy the fact that it was one guy i'm so sad actually got this come on come on oh yeah i'll go one i'll go wait wait wait wait wait wait battle set me a number what an account name is changed should we add battle as a fourth yeah yeah get better than spiritually he is axle hey windfield you've been great thank you very much for thanks for thanks for carrying us man thanks big out don't worry winfield i'm so tired holy i'm dying sorry axel if only i didn't go for the swim
if only i didn't go for i wanted to test my theory out i was told that nobody could see me and i believe believed you what do you mean you and windfield no where is axel i don't know how to join from my yeah i invited you okay good morning battle
oh but it's still not in i think only you can kick people out there i can't kick people okay Because you're the party host.
Oh, wait, wait, you left.
Good morning, better.
Well, well, well.
Let's have a better get in here.
Good morning, sir.
I'm having a bit of difficulty, are we?
Yeah, okay.
How many games have you won, better?
Like 50.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to look at your profile.
I'm going to look at it.
I don't actually know.
Oh, because it's zero?
Ha ha ha.
No.
Oh, how do we know you're not lying?
Because I'm a battlefield gamer.
Oh, yeah.
God doesn't lie.
He never lies.
All right, let's see your level.
All right, Altair and Vitamin.
Yeah.
Also, to my chat, is Beto K or is he too loud, guys?
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
He's always like, you're still streaming.
Yes, we haven't won a single game.
Yes, I know I'm still streaming.
I'm really rooting for you here.
Yes, if I'm live right now, it means we still haven't won a game, okay, guys?
understand what if we were just lying to you we're just we won one maybe yeah yeah you could know what if we're just holding you guys hostage oh i believe it you're you're being held hostage now so wait what i'm gonna hang myself okay morale is high this is what i want we got this no we got this we got better now we got better yeah it's fine as long as we have your luck we can either do it or not we got this do it let's do this let's do this oh yeah i gotta do a png for better i just gotta choose a location you know the forest or my own room or like don't worry you're in no no no no we're gonna need a location bro yeah honestly you don't like your own room is bad with what we're called what we're not where you call also what the fuck is It's a puppet.
I'm a puppet.
It's a cute puppet.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, he looks just like us.
We're idols.
Look at this.
That's right.
We're judging you.
I'm an animal.
Look at this, guys.
Look at this.
I'm just a puppet.
Look at this little guy.
What the fuck is my?
Two drogues for some reason.
They're scared.
They're scared of us.
Dead game.
Is Axl crashing out?
What is going on?
We've been a lot Axl.
It's only been six hours.
Yeah.
Ah.
It's only been six hours, guys.
It's five.
What's Axl's longest stream?
Has he ever done like a 24 hour?
I wish I could just strap a bomb on myself and just run at the man oh my god i'm just looking at i can't help but look at bettos png i'm sorry guys like it looks like he's method acting looks like a fucking maggot no it looks like a little maggot emerging from the ground yeah yeah like just me i'm going to bettol oh there's bettos yeah like a little maggot in the in the sand mr maggot i was all right we got this oh my god level 68 better what the i like i like i like battlefield bro have you have you if honestly like if we didn't know you went outside recently i would not have believed it well i mean there you i mean i'm just real i'm just i'm a genuine gamer for once yeah chat it's very surprising but this man actually touches grass i touch grass as much as i can it's it's very surprising i know well at least you're level 68 things almost as green as the grass that you touch yeah yeah one more level and it's all over though one more level and you can retire yeah you will i won't be on
this game again so we gotta we gotta work fast
i got two hours guys i liked how my last game i like how you joined the game also making sure it's not the level before it yeah it'll be a big moment no the level before it before it the one under minus one oh true oh god that would have been bad yeah yeah we can't have that all right all right what's the strategy just one with battle here just the first one yeah a bad thing I haven't played in a while oh okay but what was the strat um well you dropping you I don't have a strategy I just kill everyone I see okay but what happens when they try to kill you I kill them first all right all right okay bet bet what if you kill them second what happened let's go to neighborhood neighborhood always works okay I say lying wait which is the highest and out okay so you lied you actually lied i'm not over i'm just stupid welcome to gavis battle i just have to try and turn on my flashlight i've been playing with dark raiders oh saturday yeah have you played our raiders yet more fun i said you
played art raiders yet hell no not yet not yet i don't know if you'd like what's stopping you i mean it's an attraction shooter so it's like what's stopping me that game expensive bro I gotta save up money first and then I'll probably get it what if a cheeky cheeky twitch prime sub got you yeah yeah what the hell what is that right now yeah he's multi-streamed oh no he's he's exclusive streaming not even multi they get to see me have a crash out on the front page hey welcome to actual thing yes That's good.
That's good.
They got to know more about you.
You ain't hiding.
Depressed VTuber, ma'am.
Wait, is our VTubers are happy?
9,000 ping.
Yes.
Oh, yeah, you figured.
Oh, God.
That's fine.
I have dog shit guns.
So what guns are good?
I like light machine guns.
Okay.
That's... I got that.
That's in my hand right now.
Wait, is there people on me?
I think that was...
that's us that's us homie no someone to get rock playing no that was us someone called in an airdrop here no you're just being crazy right now you're being no i told you oh and who did i'm using you he wins that he wins that he wins that good job axel so good let's see
people up top of the hill careful that's their whole team like that guy was like just on his own like a moron i don't know yeah who would do that who would do that i would never you know i would never just we have better strategy like that if we do it it's someone else's fault yeah exactly like who the would do something that's stupid right now as we sprint up all them all them all them
agents who would like i'm surrounding them like we're actually fbi like we're you guys have gone crazy yeah we're like actually sliding what is wrong with this game bro i swear it is i'm kind of waggy i'm feeling a little kooky i mean six hour mark anything can happen a little go get a little bonkers yeah i dropped us in a really bad place this is my fault what did you drop welcome to Sack Wackers?
Yeah, welcome to Team Sack Wackers.
No, we're Sack Wackers.
We're here to whack the sacks.
We're Sack Wackers.
Well, are you not a Sack Wacker?
There's a lot of Sack Wacker.
That's right.
How many Sacks have you at?
Ah!
The people, I don't know people!
People, people!
Oh, shit, I'm coming over.
I'm by myself.
He's hurt, he's hurt.
Oh, no.
He's hurt.
I just can't win.
Fucking shit ass ping, man.
No, no, no.
We got you.
You're dead?
I'm dead.
Oh no.
That's me.
Two down.
Okay, okay.
I got another squad wipe.
Yeah, nine.
Nice.
Nice blue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's your body?
Oh, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
We're good.
Yeah, but where's your loot?
I don't think you want it.
It's really bad.
I dropped it.
I dropped like a paper coat.
Thank you.
Oh, there's an assault rifle.
I'm actually going to take that.
Smoke screen.
Which is better?
Wait, Fetto, which is better?
Assault rifle or LMG?
LMG.
Alright.
LMG tab.
I don't think there's...
For me, it's without question.
Axel, Axel, come here.
Alright.
Take this.
What do I have flashlight on?
I already got a purple assault rifle.
Okay.
I'm good.
kind of shit but all right sorry i gave you are we no this is very the one i have oh i'm sorry that's right cry out how could you fucking do that jackson like after everything he's been with for you and with you too should have given the legendary instead how could you do that drop what the fuck is an anti-vehicle drop oh it's like when they send in a vehicle and then someone oh
it drops like uh anti-vehicle equipment like bazookas or mines or oh i want that wait a bit i have some shields for you you want some give me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah beg for it then bitch yeah defense yeah beg for it was me saying yeah not begging for it no no that's not good now yeah gravel can i have them please just a morsel just a singular morsel yeah just a small taste my shoes right now may i have some oats brother the shoes what kiss the shoes that's right yeah one kiss okay one kiss for shield hey don't stretch your fucking lunch here Can you get those goddamn shields?
Eight, why don't you give me eight?
Oh shit, I'm fucked up.
I think your guy needs to beg a little bit.
Oh shit, wait, wait, wait.
I'm ready to die to grab shields back from you.
I'm ready to die.
I'm playing, I pressed the wrong button.
Right here, here.
For the sake of the team, I'm giving them back.
But just know that it's not because...
Oh, you guys, you're in a Lula game with Baby Pier?
What are you guys doing?
We're in a war zone.
I'm getting my shoes.
No more fooling around we got no more fooling around we got I got to go to bed in two hours And if we're this isn't over in two hours.
I'm gonna be real upset Oh, you're gonna go bed.
You think you're gonna go up in two hours
Guys come on, get out that house let's go And we're jumping around like freaks.
We're so ducky ducky what ducky What?
There's a cop.
There's a golf guy.
We're so fucking dying in that.
Come here.
Okay.
Brum.
I gotta freak out.
Yes.
I bet all they're coming.
We got, we have a golf.
I'm sitting in the back of the golf crap.
I'm so getting shot at.
Amber here.
Oh my God.
Okay.
So, but our strat, we want that.
We want that.
Okay.
Our strat was to find a house and stay in a corner.
What?
So far.
a camping strat no just just kill everybody just kill everybody no it doesn't work like that dude you know who you're talking dude doing this for six hours this was the best part it was the closest we've ever got to the finish line it's only 3 30 p.m for you you shouldn't you shouldn't be tired you should be yeah i woke up i slept at 3 a.m 2 a.m and woke up at 5 a.m okay oh that's i drank a coffee at 7 that's on you i need this drop i need this drop i need this i need I need this.
I need this.
Whoa, whoa, buddy.
Smoke grenade.
Don't worry.
Oh, that was great.
There's another smoke too, so they'll never know that there's something inside.
Good work team.
Good use of of...
Why am I lagging?
Where are...
What servers are we on?
I don't know.
I don't know where we are at.
I think we're east coast.
Okay, guys.
What do we get?
What do we get here?
Do I get...
Let's go to a house.
I don't like standing in the middle of a golf field.
I don't know what to get here.
Oh, maybe I'll get this.
I'll get the SGX.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Someone right above us.
Oh, shit.
They're coming in.
Let's get some, let's get some cover.
Oh, wow.
They're dropping in hot.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
One dead.
Nice.
They landed behind the house, behind the house.
Whoa!
Gotcha.
He's one.
That's mine.
I didn't see anything.
I'm going in either.
I don't see the people you're shooting at.
I broke the house.
I destroyed the house.
He's dead.
One down.
Nice.
Is that everybody?
I don't know.
I don't see it.
There are no squad wipes, so we don't know.
One of them might be like 20 miles.
I'm a UAV up, so...
Wait, where's the guy we down here?
I think he... where is he?
No, you're right.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh, they're...
Oh, they're far.
What the shit?
Okay, well...
Wait, where did you see it?
Oh.
There's someone raising a chemical.
all right well they they died they killed themselves that was cool yeah that's cool where are you i think they couldn't they couldn't play without their homie you know what a good homie all right where do we go better i jealous all right there is a tank i can destroy tanks i got that tank demolished looking ass whoa i have a i have an artillery strike too i have a uav over i got smoke screen as well maybe this is the game southwest i have a uav overwatch thing is that what it's called you want to go get the custom weapon drop yeah sure whoa i don't know where the why weren't you here earlier betto i was streaming why the would you hear earlier bro he was playing outer wilds i was playing the outer wilderness there's a guy do you see that there's people dropping on us Oh my god!
Hit who?
There's a guy in this building.
Watch yourself!
He's in there, he dropped in there, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know if he's still in there, but that's where he was.
Oh, I don't say him, I don't say him.
Maybe he ran like a little bitch.
I would too.
Is that even reaching up?
I think we're safe right now.
Now I'm pretty sure he ran away.
There's no way he's still in there unless he's camping.
What is that red light over there?
Oh, okay.
Okay, who sent that in?
Who sent that in?
Oh my goodness.
So that guy is at the special crate.
Inside, inside.
First floor.
Oh, that must have been him.
I'm looking.
Oh, wait, wait.
There's a teammate.
His teammates here.
We don't have to cross this in fight, honestly.
I see them.
I feel like we're giving up.
We're here.
We ran up.
Right by the car.
I'm going to hold high.
Oh, he's resting.
He's resting.
Oh, he is.
Let me get a better angle.
I'm well.
My game volume is on, like, two right now.
How are you guys still?
Guys, we have him.
That's why we're still getting him.
He's probably got to get a hill.
He's got to get it off.
Oh, you got it off.
Yeah, yeah.
Actually, wait.
I think he came.
Yeah.
He went inside.
I'm right here with you.
I'm right behind you.
Hit him 100 100.
Oh, he's tried to get- he's dead.
He's dead.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, boy.
Careful.
We split up.
I don't know where I got shot from.
He's hurt.
I know we got to wrestle on my ass.
I'm pin farming, this is- Oh shit.
This is a- There's an argus target.
I'm waiting until the strike is down I think someone's trying to take my Oh, fuck, I fucked up guys.
I fucked up.
Oh no, Beto Beto We're ping ping.
I shot a man and I I put off where I could chew here.
Oh god Beto, Beto, Beto I killed him.
I killed a guy.
Oh my god.
I'm being shot at that.
I don't know whose team he's on.
I beto.
I'm getting shot at trying to get to you I don't know where I'm getting shot at.
I'm good.
No, Beto.
Okay.
Axel.
Let's go.
He's on me.
there's multiple teams they're down in the fire here they're killing me i'm dead i got one i got one i got one i got i mean there's the response station here yeah yeah let's just do it let's do it they're in a bad spot they're in a bad spot yeah yeah i gotta heal i gotta heal oh christ where's that sniper he's on me okay i have to stay here i've got one i got the other guy yeah you guys are doing good you guys are doing good oh yeah it's getting tight you guys you guys can do it you got you got you got you're doing you're good get in here quicker quicker get in here get in where inside the zone thank you i'm leaving am i dead no no no you're fine i'm in the fire you're fine you're fine you're fine you're fine you're fine you're so fine you're no no no no no no no you're so fine you're so healthy whoa oh my god they're i'm getting shot right here right here right here right here on ping all right take high take high first people oh that's you that's you okay i see them i see them where
are they keeping pinged one I nearly broke him.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Watch your left.
Wait, there's a case right here in front of you.
I just fired us.
Okay.
Nice.
That's dead, dead, dead.
On your left.
All right.
Let's, uh, let's go together.
Axel is going.
I have no shields.
Oh, I haven't.
Oh, I have.
Shield, shield, shield.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm following Axel right now.
fighting someone?
Yeah, just a vehicle they ran off.
Okay.
I'm looking below us just in case.
Make sure there's nobody right behind us.
I like this car.
It's very safe.
Uh-huh, sure.
They just drove off.
There's people in front of us.
Okay.
Yeah.
Are they in a vehicle or what?
Bad position.
I don't know how I can shoot that.
Careful training.
There's people on the street as well and up the hill.
I see the guy right here.
There's multiple.
I'm shooting the guy under the truck right now.
I don't see the guys on the hill right now.
We need to reposition.
This is...
Where are we going?
I can smoke us.
Just keep going.
Yeah, just watch up ahead.
Yeah.
It's got to be on our left as well.
checking we're close behind this hedge here we're in front of me all right yeah you're running from us nice oh right side right side right side right side oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he got smoke if he could use yeah yeah i smoked i smoked this i smoked this yeah yeah yeah just i have no shields watch behind it don't have shields on your street i'll try your shields yeah yeah yeah thank you watch behind as well keep an eye on that yeah yeah yeah watch him behind i'm watching too i'm watching what better we're walking with zone actually my Everybody good with shield?
I have four.
Yeah, I'm good with shield.
I'm good with shield.
I don't know where that team behind us went, but we're playing soft side.
So this is, this looks okay.
We could, we could take the jump tower if you want to.
I like, I kind of like playing this in its own way, but we could take it.
All right.
There's nobody around us.
Yeah.
We could walk.
Give me a second.
Give me a second to drain.
Okay.
I'll let you know if it's, it touches you.
Thanks.
I'll let you know if the fire gets closer.
Shots, uh, far over there.
All right.
There's a team right over here.
If you want to help me, help me.
You're by yourself.
I'm on my way.
I'm still.
Careful.
I hear him for 16 about.
I'm just looking, checking behind us.
Behind this, behind this shit house.
West, west, west.
There's a fight.
I see them.
Yeah, yeah.
He's down.
One down.
Here.
I think they're going to pick him up in there.
Cracks.
Under 60?
64?
Oh, he's so low.
oh my gosh oh watch out that's fine yeah i got someone at 100 i hit 160.
what the fuck are these guys aim they're so good they're pretty nuts yeah from that range i didn't just have better guys now i have smoke and we need it god i have an overload out i need to look for armor i ran out of armor in that fight i have one left Yeah,
kill somebody.
We'll try to look for one if we can.
He's the guy close to us.
Oh, this guy's a red LFG.
He has red LFG.
Watching for us here.
I got one?
Nice, nice, nice.
I'll see you squad, squad, squad, squad.
Yeah.
All right, class.
Four of the squads, four of the squads.
I'm glad.
In front of me.
I like this ridge.
I like this ridge for a little bit.
He's down.
I got armor.
I'm coming back.
I'm hitting that.
I have to loot it.
Are you ready?
I'm ping.
He's down.
Nice.
I'm heading over to you.
I am game done.
I'm armouring up real quick.
There's one more ahead.
Watch behind here.
Nice.
I can loot up here.
There's armor.
He has armor.
I'm checking my left.
I'm checking.
I'll check left side.
I can give you guys ammo.
Who needs ammo?
I'm good.
I have three.
On me.
I'm with you?
I'm down.
I dropped ammo.
It's just one left.
One left.
On that team.
I'm rising.
I'm rushing.
I'm watching left for us.
He's 1 HP at the other side of the hedge.
Oh.
Oh, it's touching.
Oh, squad white!
All that.
Yeah, no, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming over to battle.
You need shields?
I'm okay for now.
Actually, yeah, yes, yes.
All right.
I like this right here.
Yeah, I dropped a shield.
I'm going to I'm going to drain.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh, but they picked it up.
I'm going to need shields.
I'll pick.
I'll just one.
Just one.
Okay.
Over there.
There's a team.
Both teams.
Both teams southwest.
Play slow.
Yeah, we can play slow.
I turn on UAV.
Watch your left.
Two on the left side and two on the right side.
Okay, okay.
I'm using the hedge as cover I'm gonna take an off angle on the right side if I can We kind of have ring here.
So just be careful here if we have height.
Yeah, shoot this guy Shoot where he's down.
Oh, nice nice nice big one.
I'll see who we are shooting at.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Watch the right.
Watch the right side right side right side Okay, I'm looking right.
I'm looking here.
I see them.
You ping them coming over coming over
Where the fuck are you seeing them?
He's down on the hill here.
You know what?
I'm...
He's...
Don't push.
Just play safe.
I think there's only two people on this team.
On the right side.
Two people.
That's where my needs, but I should have waited.
Left side, left side.
70.
I'm pushing.
Yeah, I'm pushing too.
I got my SMP up.
Left, both left, both left.
One dead.
Yeah, one copy.
I'm down.
He's up.
Lisa!
Nick!
Oh my God!
Holy shit!
Let's go, baby!
Oh my God!
You guys have a good night.
Oh, thank you.
We're free!
That's all we did!
Fuck, yeah.
Holy night.
Holy fuck!
That's all we did, is it?
We just needed an IGL here.
Oh my Gets!
Yeah!
That's us, guys!
It's us!
I've never seen this screen before!
Me too!
Oh my god!
The last 23 kills!
We just needed a leader.
The battle was like the real leader all along.
He's...
Better with 10 kills.
Oh my god!
Guys, guess what?
Level 69!
Wait, really?
Yep, that was my level up.
God, you know, nice, nice, honestly, nice, that's, let's look at, let's look at, I'm gonna look at Betel's, wait, it says 68 for me, did you lie?
No, no, it's here, it's here, look at that, guys, 69!
Let's fucking go, baby.
Oh my god, wait, sorry I didn't match, why are we matchmaking?
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, what a game, what a game, honestly full squad is fun though full squad is fucking fun yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now that we but yeah now that we figured out the perfect comp guys no no more bathrooms for us guys lfg is actually okay what the fuck that was the first time yeah bro it better have been here earlier we could it could have been over it's so much funnier than The fact that it was the very last game that Axel was gonna do and we won.
I told you, the victory is just so much better.
So much better when you win.
Sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack, sack.
We did it.
GG's, everyone.
GG's guys.
I'm so happy for us.
Thanks, Biddle.
yeah yeah of course guys anytime thanks thank you thanks out there and thanks axel had a great time so sorry and thanks for forcing us to do this yeah yeah so thank god you had this brilliant idea to play this game until we win yeah problem yeah we did it as a team guys i've always knew i always knew we were gonna do it i i believed in us that hard i knew i knew it was gonna happen lost a little bit of her soul before it yeah yeah but like we're fine everything is fine now everything is fine we made it it's like the idle journey you know everything looks darkest before the dawn yeah we started from 25th place 24th place no look at us i don't feel like i earned any of this
yippee okay doki i guess i'll see you in two days yeah i'll see you in battle Yeah, yeah, I'll see you in two days But I gotta teach us too Because we both haven't played Our graders yet Oh, this is gonna be Uncle Battle Yay Okay, a little bit of a Taste for today We're free Cheers,
guys Cheers You guys have a good night Yeah, love that guys Bye bye Say ya Say ya We did it We fucking did it, guys We didn't need a rat we didn't need a rat at all we just it's not crazy we just played the game and we killed so many people guys we we fucking oh my god we actually did it we needed an idea yeah it's just too easy too easy guys anyway i'm I'm gonna head out now Thank you all for watching I'm tight As always everybody Stay hydrated Posture check Get up and move around Get that blood flowing You stay up for me Head to bed Cause You deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody Bye guys Bye